GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
OUR SPECIAL --
FOR HUMANS BREEZE OF HUMAN
SERVICES AND TODAY WE ARE HOPING
TO ADDRESS THE BEHAVIORAL NEEDS
OF CHILD OF CHILDREN IN CARE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH --
THIS IS MY HOPE. FOR US TO GET
KIND OF A FOSTER CARE ONE A ONE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING SO THAT WE
ALL KNOW --
WHAT'S HAPPENING ESPECIALLY WITH
THE NEW I LEGISLATIVE YEAR
COMING --
WE'RE HOPING TO GET SOME IDEAS
OF WHAT FIRST OF ALL WHAT IT IS
AND WHAT WE CAN ALL DO --
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES EVERY NOW FOR FOSTER
YOUTH --
CHILDREN AND TODAY I WITH US I
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF COOLEY
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
MR COOLEY IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
SOME.
OPENING REMARKS.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR A
MADAM CHAIR --
YEAH I'M JUST VERY DELIGHTED TO
BE AT THIS JOINT HEARING WITH
THE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE IN
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON FOSTER
CARE.
OF TO LOOK AT HOW THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING --
SOMEBODY REMARKED UPON THIS
BUTTON FOSTER CARE DOES INDEED
MATTER.
AND THE EFFORT TO USE THE TOOLS
IN THE PUBLIC POLICY TOOL KIT.
OF PUBLIC POLICY AND RESOURCES.
AND REALLY FOCUS.
ON ON THESE KIDS THEIR CARE
GIVERS TO TRY.
TO STRENGTHEN THE STABILITY.
THAT THEY NEED TO DEAL WITH THE
TRAUMA THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
HAVE BEEN ADVERSE IN THEIR LIFE.
TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO SUPPORT THE
CARE GIVERS.
WHO PROVIDE THAT VERY VITAL
STABILITY?
THE CAN HELP THEY MOVE THROUGH
THE ADVERSITIES OF THEIR LIFE
AND GROW TOWARDS PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENSHIP --
I THINK THAT THE SERVICES ARE
VERY IMPORTANT BOTH FOR THE
NEEDS THEY MEET.
BUT ALSO AS A AS AN INDICATOR
THAT WHATEVER ADVERSITY SAVE
ENCOUNTERED.
IT CONVEYS A SENSE OF THEY ARE
VALUED.
THAT THERE RESPECTED.
WE'RE LOOKING DO A PULL THEM IN
THEIR DIGNITY IS INDIVIDUALS.
I THINK THAT'S THE HIGHER
ASPIRATION OF THIS FIELD AND IT
IS A VERY COMPLICATED FIELD.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF LA ILL --
AND THE BACKGROUND WORK OF DAFT
IN THE TEAM THE COMMITTEE TO
JUST KIND OF HIGHLIGHT.
THE DIFFERENT.
PARTIES IN THE PROCESS OF
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS A
RELATIONSHIP A STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW. TO DIFFERENT RULES OF
ELIGIBLE IS THAT APPLY TO
CHILDREN GENERALLY FOSTER USE
THOSE WITH TRAUMA.
ADULTS SOME OF THEM MEDI CAL
SYSTEM.
ON HOW ALL THIS DIFFERENTIATES
THE NEED TO PARTNER STATE AND
COUNTIES.
AND MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL --
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
ROLE DSS.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING
IS JUST TO REALLY TO EDUCATE.
THE MEMBERS. TO UNDERSTAND MORE
DEEPLY ALL THIS COMPLEXITY.
BUT ALWAYS WITH A VIEW TO KIDS
WE SUPPORT THEM.
AND PERSONALLY I WILL SAY I DO
FIND THIS COMPLEXITY
[inaudible]
MIND BOGGLING.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING COMING FROM
A LAWYER.
THAT I WOULD FIND IT MIND
BOGGLING BUT I DO FIND IT MIND
BOGGLING.
WHAT I KNOW ABOUT EXPERTISE?
IN GENERAL IN ANY HUMAN ENDEAVOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERTS CAN LOOK
AT THAT COMPLEXITY.
AND SEE THE SIMPLICITY THE LIES
WITHIN.
AND SO REALLY AS I SIT HERE
TODAY I'M JUST LOOKING TO LEARN.
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
OUR EXPERTS SO THAT THEY CAN
KIND OF HELP ME LOOK PAST THE
COMPLEX IS JUST TRYING TO SEE
WHAT MATTERS.
WHAT'S THE SIMPLEST ALLIES
WITHIN SO THAT WE CAN THINK
ABOUT THE TOOLS AND LEGISLATIVE
TOOL KIT.
ARE.
NOT JUST IN OUR OWN LET'S SAVE.
FOCUSED AREAS BUT REALLY AS WE
LOOK TO A NEW GOVERNOR. TO KIND
OF BE AN INTEGRATED LEGISLATURE
WHOSE.
KAREN FOR THIS STANDARD IS A
CHAMPION.
AND REALLY TO SET THE AGENDA THE
NEXT GOVERNOR ON WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN IN THIS IMPORTANT AREA SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU BOTH CO CHAIRS AND IF
YOU WILL ALLOW INDULGE ME I
WANTED TO SAY A SPECIAL THANK
YOU -- TODAY
ACTUALLY HAPPENS TO BE MY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTORS BIRTHDAY
AND SHE'S HERE AND THE BACK SO
IF -- AND
SHE HAS BEEN A CHAMPION IN THIS
AREA FOR A LONG TIME AND MARLA
COHEN IT'S QUITE APPRECIATIVE OF
HAVE YOU CAN.
AND YET HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BIRTHDAYS AND HOW MANY OF OUR
FOSTER KIDS DON'T PROPERLY
CELEBRATE EACH YEAR.
AND HOW OFTEN DO THEY GO LACKING
AND WITHOUT AND HOW MUCH
PROMINENT DIVERSITY DO THEY FACE.
I'M EXCITED TO HEAR FROM EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
DO BETTER.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS A
PUBLIC SERVANTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING A GOOD
PRODUCT.
AND THAT OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
WORKS OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT
WE HAVE THE APPROPRIATE CRISIS
INTERVENTION BUILT WITHIN IT.
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE SEEN
A FEW MORE BILLS SIGNED THIS
YEAR THAT DEALT WITH THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM.
PARTICULARLY ONE LOOKING AT AN
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WERE ANSWERING
CALLS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
HAVING BEEN ANY OUR DOCTOR
MYSELF I KNOW THAT PROBLEMS
DON'T ALWAYS OCCUR FROM --
NINE TO FIVE AND IT'S NOT MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY ANDAND YET IF
IT'S A CRISIS FOR YOUR CHILD --
AND YOU'RE A FOSTER PARENT.
ARE WE PROVIDING ENOUGH SERVICES
TO THEM AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE
TODAY ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO
BETTER.
AND HOW WE CONTINUE TO STRIVE
WITH THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU FOR THAT CULTURES.
THANK YOU AND THIS IS MY THE END
ALMOST OF MY SECOND YEAR HERE
AND THE COMPLEXITIES THAT --
MISTER COOLIES TALKING ABOUT ARE
MIND BOGGLING --
I THINK THAT IN MANY MANY
HEARINGS AND SPECIALLY AND
HEALTH AND SOMEONE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SOMEONE COMMITTEE --
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT YOU KNOW JUST
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT WE ARE
ENGAGED IN.
AND SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE THE
ESSENCE OF WHY WE'RE HERE IS
LOST THE HUMAN FACTOR --
I'VE SAID IT IN SEVERAL
COMMITTEES --
WITH DOCTOR ARAMBULA WE I FEEL
THAT A LOT OF TIMES WE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS BUDGET.
LINE ITEM AND THAT BUDGET LINE
ITEM -- BUT
THE IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THERE'S
IN HUMAN CONNECTION TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND THE LACK OF
HUMAN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
FOSTER KIDS THE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR CqC OUR
SOCIETY ARE.
QUITE FRANKLY RESPONSIBLE I
THINK THAT.
WE ALL TRY TO BE ENGAGED AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE BUT I THINK WE HAVE
TO STOP TALKING ABOUT.
CHILDREN IN FOSTER KIDS AND YOU
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING AS A LINE
ITEM IN THE BUDGET.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT A LINE
ITEMS ARE IMPORTANT BUT THE WAY
WE HAVE THE DISCUSSIONS CAMP BE.
THIS IS MONEY THEREFORE WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS.
HAS TO BE THIS IS THE WAY THAT
WE CAN GO BOOKS HELP. TO SUPPORT
THESE KIDS THAT NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS TO THOSE KIDS IN OUR
SYSTEM THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ADULTS.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE EITHER
FUNCTIONING WELL FUNCTIONING.
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY OR NOT AND I
THINK THAT'S LOST SOMETIMES IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THAT.
WE CAN SAY THAT WE WANT TO HELP
BUT IF WE DON'T PUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR MOUTH IS BUT YET HAVE
THAT HEART. FOR THESE KIDS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ADULTS WITH
ISSUES.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T DO WHAT WAS
RIGHT ARE BUY THEM AND I'M ALSO
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF YOU BEING
HERE TODAY AND I WANT TO LEARN
MORE.
YOU KNOW IN OUR OWN WAY WE ALL
GET THE INFORMATION BUT IT'S
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT TO SEE IT.
THROUGH YOUR EYES BECAUSE YOU'RE
ON THE GROUND DAY IN AND DAY OUT
AND DOCTOR ARAMBULA WHEN HE WAS
AND IN.
AN ER DOCTOR I WAS A TEACHER WE
SAW THOSE ISSUES MANIFEST
THEMSELVES IN EITHER THE
EMERGENCY ROOM OR IN THE
CLASSROOM.
BY WE FELT AT LEAST I DID AS A
TEACHER THAT THERE WAS NOTHING
THAT I CAN DO.
YOU KNOW IS JUST SOMEBODY WAS
DIRECTING ME AND TELLING ME WHAT
I SHOULD DO WITH THAT THOSE KIDS.
AND I IF I HATE THE TERM THOSE
KIDS BECAUSE THOSE ARE OUR KIDS
AND SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN HAVE A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION.
AND IT'S JUST THE FIRST STEP YOU
KNOW BY NO MEANS ARE WE GOING TO
SOLVE ALL OF THE ISSUES HERE --
BUT I WANT TO KNOW THE BASICS
THE ONE THE ONE ABOUT FOSTER
KIDS AND HOPEFULLY ALL OF US
THAT ARE AFTER THIS LITTLE THING
CALLED THE ELECTION IN A COUPLE
WEEKS WE CAN REALLY SIT DOWN AND
TALK ABOUT.
SOLUTIONS OR POSSIBLE
LEGISLATION INTRODUCED TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE WORK THAT
YOU DO SO THANK YOU AGAIN ON
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO BRING
OUR FIRST PANELISTS.
UP WE HAVE --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS FOR FAST YOU AND WE
HAVE CUT THE COMPANY NANA
CATHOLIC FOR ANY CLASSES THAT.
I GOT THAT IN A CABIN MSW
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND WE
HAVE WENDY SMITH PH T. L. C. S.
W. DISTINGUISHED CONTINUING
SCHOLAR IN CHILD WELFARE.
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SESENTA DORK PICK
SCHOOL OF SOCIAL WORK.
IT IS BUT I'M I'M GLAD TO DO IT
SO THANK YOU AND WELCOME
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THAT AFTERNOON SO AS YOU SAID MY
NAME IS KATHERINE I CAME BACK
I'M FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AND I'M CURRENTLY A COUPLE
MONTHS AWAY FROM MY MSW AT UC
BERKELEY RAM SPECIALIZING IN
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES.
I ALSO AM A PART OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION ARE SEE WHY SEE
A REALLY AMAZING AND INCREDIBLE
YOUTH ORGANIZATION THAT JUST
PASSED A BILL THIS YEAR AROUND
STABILITY.
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN AND I
BRING THIS UP BECAUSE I THINK
THE CONCEPT OF STABILITY IS
CRITICAL HERE FOR TALKING ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
AND IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
VERY FOUNDATION OF YOUTH BEING
SHAKEN AND TORN FROM UNDERNEATH
US AND EVERY MOMENT OF OUR TIME
IN FOSTER CARE.
IT'S HARD TO HAVE ANY.
ANYTHING ELSE BEYOND THAT AND WE
REALLY NEED STABILITY THAT'S
FOUNDATIONAL AND WITH THE FOSTER
STABILITY CAMPAIGN WE TALK ABOUT
STABILITY IN ALL ASPECTS IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT PLACEMENT WHICH
WE ACTUALLY CALL A PLACE TO LIVE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT BADS.
RATE OR A ROOF IT'S REALLY ABOUT
A SAFE PLACE TO CALL HOME AND
THAT ALL YOUTH DESERVE THAT.
SO WE ALSO TALK ABOUT STABILITY
IN SERVICE SAYS AND THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT WHAT I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU IN MY STORY TODAY.
ACTUALLY WENT THREE THIRTY TWO
DIFFERENT PLACEMENTS IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM I WAS ALSO IN
JUVENILE HALL SEVERAL TIMES AND
I WAS ALSO HOSPITALIZED SEVERAL
TIMES.
I BROUGHT AN IMAGE TODAY THAT I
MADE WHILE REFLECTING ON MY
EXPERIENCE AND I I WROTE A
MANTRA IT SAYS I AM POWERFUL I
AM CAPABLE I AM WORTHY IT'S THE
SYSTEM THAT'S BROKEN.
AND ON HERE I ALSO WROTE ALL THE
DIAGNOSES SAM AND ALL THE
MEDICATIONS THAT I WAS
OFTENTIMES FORCED TO TAKE
PARTICULARLY IN GROUP HOMES.
AND WHILE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
PARTICULARLY DUE TO THE BRAVERY
ADVOCACY OF OTHER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO COME BEFORE ME.
I KNOW WORKING WITHIN THE SYSTEM
MYSELF THAT FOSTER YOUTH STILL
SUFFER AND THAT.
THIS LEGISLATION IS AND ALWAYS
AND FORCED.
SO IT REALLY WAS NOT HELPFUL FOR
ME GROWING UP I THINK WAS THAT.
MENTAL HEALTH WAS MORE ABOUT
OBLIGATION AND THAT WAS WHAT I
WAS REQUIRED TO DO IT WAS ABOUT
GETTING PUNISHED IF YOU DIDN'T
GO TO THERAPY OR GETTING
PUNISHED IF YOU DIDN'T TAKE YOUR
MEDICATION SO I WAS NEVER GIVEN
A STRONG SENSE OF WHAT HEALTH
AND WELLNESS MET.
AND THAT I WAS ENTITLED TO A
HEALTHY AND SAFE LIFE AND
HEALTHY AND SAFE RELATIONSHIPS
SO I FOUND THAT ELSEWHERE
OFTENTIMES ON THE STREETS WHEN I
A WILD AND THEN AGAIN WAS
PUNISHED FOR THAT.
AND I WOULD CHALLENGE YOU ALL TO
DO WHEN THINKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH AND THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM.
IS TO SHIFT SERVICE SAYS AND
TARGET THINGS AT THE ADULTS WERE
FAILING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
YOUTH.
BECAUSE IT CAN BE EASY TO
PROBLEM AT HIGHS AND CRIMINALIZE
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR BEHAVIORS THAT
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND.
BUT I CHALLENGE YOU TO TAKE TIME
TO UNDERSTAND THOSE BEHAVIOR AND
PUT YOURSELF IN A POSITION WHERE
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO SLEEP THAT NIGHT.
NO IDEA IF YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
YOUR FAMILY AGAIN.
NO IDEA IF YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND NO IDEA
REALLY IF YOU'RE GOING TO LIVE.
LET'S TARGET THE SERVICES
INSTEAD AT THE ADULTS WHO ARE
FAILING TO RESPOND CORRECTLY TO
THESE BEHAVIORS WE NEED TO TRAIN
CARE GIVERS ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS
NOT JUST TO BE TRAUMA AND FORMS
BUT TO CREATE SPACE AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO HEAL AND THEIR CARE.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE RESOURCES AND
COMMUNITIES.
CHILDREN TO ENTER FOSTER CARE
THROUGH FAULT OF THEIR OWN IT'S
OFTENTIMES BECAUSE OF FAILURES
OF ADULTS AND OFTENTIMES BECAUSE
OF FAILURES OF SYSTEMS WE KNOW
THERE'S ENTIRE ZIP CODES I READ
ABOUT AS ZIP CODE IN LONG BEACH
WHERE ALMOST 90% OF THE CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN REMOVED.
THAT'S A SYSTEM PROBLEM AND
INSTEAD WE TARGET SERVICES TO
CHILDREN AND PROBLEM AT HIGHS
THEM FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR WHICH IS
THE MOST REALISTIC RESPONSE TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WHEN WE SEE BEHAVIORS THAT WE
SOMETIMES LABEL AS OUTBURSTS A
REALLY CONCERNS ME BECAUSE
FOSTER YOUTH SOMETIMES ARE THE
ONLY ONES WHO I THINK ARE
RESPONDING CORRECTLY TO THE
CIRCUMSTANCE AROUND THAT?
THIS IS A STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
FOSTER YOUTH ARE TRYING TO TELL
US THAT AND I KNOW I WAS.
THROUGHOUT MY TIME IN CARE.
I WAS ANGRY AND I ONE WAS
WILLING TO LISTEN TO ME OR TO
HEAR THAT.
SO I DID OUT SO I HAD OUT FIRST --
I A WILD AND THEN I WAS PUNISHED
FOR THAT BEHAVIOR.
AND THEN I WAS MEDICATED FOR
THAT BEHAVIOR AND WHAT I DIDN'T
TAKE THE MEDICATION I WAS
PUNISHED MORE.
AND I FELT VERY LOST AND I'M
FINE TODAY RIGHT I'M IN GRADUATE
SCHOOL AND I DON'T THINK THAT.
THAT'S NOT THROUGH JUST MY OWN
WORK AND THAT'S NOT BECAUSE
THERE'S SOMETHING INHERENTLY
SPECIAL ABOUT ME IT'S BECAUSE
SPECIAL ABOUT EVERY SINGLE
FOSTER YOUTH.
WHO LIVES IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU
REALIZE ON ALL OF YOU TO REALLY
DO YOUR JOB AND SUPPORT THEM?
BETTER THAN WE ARE NOW.
I REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE SOME
SORT OF PROCESS FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY PARTICULARLY
AROUND PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION.
WHICH I STILL SEE TO BE OVER
PRESCRIBED PARTICULARLY IN
CERTAIN COUNTIES AND I WANT
THOSE COUNTIES TO BE HELD
FINANCIALLY ACCOUNTABLE.
I WANT THEM TO KNOW THAT IT'S
NOT OKAY TO IGNORE IN JOKE ABOUT
THE LEGISLATION THAT THE STATE
PASSED IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CHILDREN.
I WANT YOU THE VOICE AND CHOICE
TO BE A PART OF EVERY PROCESS.
BECAUSE LEGISLATION WILL MEAN
NOTHING FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN
CARE UNLESS IT COMES FROM THE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN CARE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY
FIND MEANINGFUL WE MADE LOOK
FROM THE OUTSIDE AND THINK
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO CHANGE BUT
THERE MAY BE A ROOT CAUSE THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE I UNDERSTAND BETTER
THAN WE DO WHEN WE GET FURTHER
REMOVED FROM AT SO REALLY WHAT I
WANT TO ASK YOU.
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND FOSTER
YOUTH IS TO MAKE STABILITY --
REALITY FOR CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
YOUTH SO THAT YOUTH CAN GROW.
AND LEARN AND DREAM.
JUST AS OTHER CHILDREN BECAUSE
AS YOU.
SAID EARLIER THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS SOMEBODY ELSE'S KIDS
THESE ARE ALL OF OUR CHILDREN
AND I KNOW VERY PERSONALLY HOW
MUCH IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT I ALSO SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE DO NOT ACT SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UP I'M WENDY SMITH --
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
ESPECIALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
CHAIRS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK CUT ENOUGH.
FOR SO MANY THINGS SHE SAID
WHICH I WOULD HAVE LIKE TO SAY
AND COULDN'T FIT INTO.
MY DISCUSSION AND PROBABLY
COULDN'T OF SAID AS WELL IN ANY
CASE SO THANK YOU --
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO ADDRESS A
LENGTHY LIST OF TOPICS IN THE
INTERESTS OF PART OF THE ONE A
ONE I WILL NEVER GET TO THE MALL.
AND SO I SENT YOU SOME SLIDES
THAT COVER SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SPEAK
ABOUT.
UP I WANT TO SAY A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE RELATIVE TO
FOSTER CARE AND THE REASONS WHY
I THINK I WAS ASKED.
TO COME AND TALK WITH YOU --
AS A PROFESSOR OF SOCIAL WORK AT
USC I TAUGHT CLASSES IN CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT DEVELOPMENT AND
TREATMENT.
AND DESIGNED A COURSE ON SOCIAL
WORK PRACTICE WITH YOUTH LEAVING
CARE.
I WROTE THE BOOK THAT BECAME THE
TAXED FOR THAT COURSE AND I'VE
LEFT A COPY WITH YOU FOR YOUR
USE -- AS I
SPENT THIRTY FIVE YEARS DOING
PSYCHOTHERAPY IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE WHERE.
A NUMBER OF MY CLIENTS WE'RE
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND OTHERS
INCLUDING THAT OF THOSE PEOPLE
WERE SURVIVORS OF CHILD SEXUAL
ABUSE AND CHILD PHYSICAL ABUSE --
I'VE WORKED WITH FOSTER USE
SERVING COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
HELPING TO DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT
A RELATIONSHIP BASED.
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM.
AND CURRENTLY I CHAIR THE LA
COUNTY COMMISSION FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND ALSO SERVED.
ON THE FIRST FIVE LA COMMISSION
THAT ADDRESSES ISSUES FOR VERY
YOUNG CHILDREN.
SOAK SOME OF THE KEY CONCEPTS
THAT I HOPE YOU'LL KEEP IN MIND
AS YOU THINK ABOUT.
OF FOSTER CHILDREN IN FOSTER
YOUTH AND WHAT YOU MIGHT.
DO TO IMPROVE THEIR SITUATIONS.
OUR EARLY OCCURRING TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES.
AND DISRUPTION OF SIGNIFICANT
ATTACHMENTS AND THE IMPACTS OF
BOTH OF THOSE HAVE ON THE
DEVELOPING BRAIN AND THE
DEVELOPING CHILD.
AND I THINK THEY ARE FUNDAMENTAL
TO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
CUTTING INTO.
ADDRESSED.
OF CHILDREN WHO ENTER CARE HAVE
ALREADY EXPERIENCED SOME KIND OF
TRAUMA WHETHER IT'S NEGLECT
ABUSE.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR MENTAL
ILLNESS OF APPARENT
INCARCERATION OF APPARENT.
ILLNESS OR DEATH OF A PARENT SO.
FOR THEM THEM TO EXPERIENCE
REMOVAL FROM HOME IS ANOTHER
SERIES OF LOSSES INFORMATIK
EVENTS INCLUDING FURTHER
DISRUPTION OF WHICHEVER
IMPORTANT ATTACHMENTS EXIST FOR
THEM.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT IT IS THROUGH ATTACHMENT
EXPERIENCES RELATIONSHIP
EXPERIENCES THAT WE DEVELOP THE
ABILITY TO MANAGE POWERFUL
EMOTIONS THAT'S KIND OF WHERE IT
GETS LAID DOWN AND IF WE DON'T
LEARN IT WHEN WERE LITTLE WE
HAVE TO LEARN IT LATER --
FROM MATIC EARLY EXPERIENCES
HAVE PROFOUND EFFECTS ON
NEUROBIOLOGY.
IN THE SENSE THAT THEY ORIENT.
THE CHILD TO DEAL WITH STRESSFUL
ENVIRONMENTS AS OPPOSED TO
POSITIVE ENVIRONMENTS.
AND THIS HAPPENS MOST POWERFULLY
IN THE FIRST FIVE YEARS OF LIFE
WHEN. 90% OF BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
TAKES PLACE.
THERE'S A SECOND PERIOD OF
IMPORTANT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
DURING ADOLESCENCE AND I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY.
THE USE AND OVER USES
PSYCHOTROPIC MADS IS A SPECIALLY --
AT SIRIUS FOR US.
TO BE THINKING ABOUT SINCE THE
BRAIN IS IN ITS SECOND IMPORTANT
PERIOD OF GROWTH.
AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW THESE
MEDICATIONS ULTIMATELY REALLY
AFFECT PEOPLE --
EARLY LIFE STRESS PREDISPOSE
CHILDREN TO BEHAVIORAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL PROBLEMS THAT CAN
BE LIFELONG.
AND THE GREATER THE EXPOSURE TO
MALTREATMENT AND TRAUMATIC
EVENTS THE GREATER THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT CHILDREN WILL
STRUGGLE.
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
BUT IT A SECOND POWERFUL
INFLUENCE ON MENTAL HEALTH IS
STABILITY STABILITY OF PLACEMENT
STABILITY OF RELATIONSHIPS. ONE
THIRD OF YOUTH IN CARE
EXPERIENCE THREE OR MORE
PLACEMENTS AND SOME STUDIES
REPORT.
THAT ONE THIRD EXPERIENCED EIGHT
OF MORE.
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW OF
KIND OF PREVALENT SINCE THAT WAS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS YOU POSED.
36261% OF FOSTER CHILDREN AND
YOUTH ARE.
OF FOUND TO BE IN THE CLINICAL
RANGE FOR BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS AND
322404% MEET THE CRITERIA FOR
PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS.
NOW AS KATERINA POINTED OUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY'RE NOT
SITUATIONALLY.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
RESPONDING TO THE CITY AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING SOMETHING
BASICALLYWRONG WITH THEM BUT IN
TERMS OF CRITERIA THAT THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY USES.
THEY DO MEET THOSE.
MORE THAN 80% OF CHILDREN IN
CARE HAVE SIGNIFICANT EMOTIONAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
AND THAT RATE IS FOUR TIMES WHAT
IT IS IN THE GENERAL POPULATION.
THE MOST COMMON DIAGNOSES.
AMONG FOSTER CARE POPULATIONS
ARE ATTENTION DEFICIT
HYPERACTIVITY DISORDER
OPPOSITIONAL DEFIANT DISORDER
CONDUCT DISORDER [inaudible]
ANXIETY DEPRESSION EATING AND
SLEEPING DISORDERS SOCIAL PHOBIA
SEPARATION ANXIETY.
MOOD DISORDERS AND ESPECIALLY
PTSD.
PTSD IS REPORTED IN 25%.
OF ADOLESCENCE IN FOSTER CARE.
THAT RATE IS TWICE THE RATE OF
RETURNING VETERANS.
AND IT'S MORE THAN SIX TIMES THE
RATE OF YOUTH IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION.
TEENS IN CARE OF FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE ATTEMPTED SUICIDE.
AND FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE A DRUG DEPENDENCY DIAGNOSIS
THAN THEIR PEERS. FOR YOUNGER
CHILDREN DEVELOPMENTAL ISSUES
ARISING FROM EARLY LIFE STRESS
INCLUDE LANGUAGE DISORDERS POOR
SOCIAL ADAPTIVE SKILLS.
AND DELAYED FINE MOTOR SKILLS.
IN OLDER CHILDREN WE SEE HIGHER
RATES OF LEARNING DISABILITIES
AND BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS.
COMPLEX TRAUMA CAN LIMIT OVERALL
NEUROCOGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT
RESULTING IN MEMORY DEFICIT AND
DIFFICULTIES WITH PROBLEM
SOLVING.
COGNITIVE SCORES ARE LOWER FOR
KIDS IN CARE THAN FOR THEIR
PEERS AND OVER 40% OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN AND PLACEMENT.
REQUIRE SPECIAL EDUCATION WHY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE EITHER SEVERE
ATTENTION DIFFICULTY THEY'RE
COPING WITH A LOT COMING FROM
THE INSIDE.
AND OVER THERE POOR INCOME
IMPULSE CONTROL OR AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIOR THAT PREVENTS THEM FROM
BEING SUCCESSFUL IN A REGULAR
CLASSROOM.
AMONG OLDER ADOLESCENTS PTSD IS
THE MOST COMMON DIAGNOSIS
FOLLOWED BY ALCOHOL DISORDERS
MAJOR DEPRESSION AND OTHER
SUBSTANCE RELATED PROBLEMS AND
GIRLS ARE AT HIGHER RISK FOR
BOTH PTSD AND MAJOR DEPRESSION.
LGBTQ YOUTH ARE OVER REPRESENTED
IN FOSTER YOU POPULATIONS.
IN THE GENERAL POPULATION
ESTIMATES ABOUT 8210% HELLO HOW
RELIABLE YOU KNOW GIVEN THAT.
MANY PEOPLE DO NOT SELF REPORT --
BUT UPWARDS OF FIFTY I PERCENT
OF YOUTH ELEVEN AND ALL DURING
CARE IDENTIFIES L. G. B..
LGBT YOUTH IN CARE HAVE TWICE
THE RATE OF CLINICALLY
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS.
TWO TO THREE TIMES HIGHER ODDS
OF HAVING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS AND SIX TIMES THE
LIKELIHOOD.
OF CLINICALLY SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA.
LGBTQ YOUTH ARE HIGHER RISK OF
EXPERIENCING MALE CHILD
MALTREATMENT.
THEY HAVE AN ESTIMATE AT AN
ELEVATED PREVALENCE OF
SUICIDALITY.
AND TWICE THE LIKELIHOOD OF A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEM. FOR
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED
CHILDREN AND YOU CAN SEE I'M
JUMPING AROUND BECAUSE THESE
WERE ALL THE THINGS THAT --
I THINK YOU WANTED TO KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT --
AN UNDERLYING HISTORY OF ABUSE.
MAKES A CHILD MUCH MORE
VULNERABLE TO TRAFFICKING. TO
BEING TRAFFICKED.
THE PREVALENCE OF CHILD ABUSE
AMONG SEASICK CHILDREN.
IS ESTIMATED BETWEEN 32% AT A
WHOPPING 93%.
THESE CHILDREN ARE AT ELEVATED
RISK FOR SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES INCLUDING SELF HARMING
BEHAVIOR PTSD.
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT USE OF
ALCOHOL AND OTHER SUBSTANCES
RISKY BEHAVIORS CRIMINAL
OFFENDING SCHOOL FAILURE.
AND MULTIPLE SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT.
THE EXPERIENCES OF EARLY LIFE.
WHEN THEY'RE POSITIVE AND WHEN
THEY'RE NEGATIVE HAVE PROFOUND
IMPACT ON DEVELOPING CHILDREN?
MALTREATMENT REMOVAL FROM HOME
LOSS OF SIGNIFICANT
RELATIONSHIPS AND ONE OR MORE
PLACEMENTS DURING CHILDHOOD OR
ADOLESCENCE.
CAN SET A CHILD ON A PATH TO
PLACEMENT INSTABILITY SCHOOL
FAILURE.
AND FAILURE TO THRIVE IN
RELATIONSHIPS AND IN LIFE.
BUT INTERVENTIONS AND POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE THE SAME
POWER. TO CONSTRUCT A POSITIVE
PATH [inaudible]
EARLY DEVELOPMENTAL AND A
SCREENINGS.
CAN POINT TO INTERVENTIONS THAT
CAN IMMEDIATELY BEGIN TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WHETHER THEY'RE
SYSTEM INTERVENTIONS OR CHILD
CENTERED INTERVENTIONS.
AND PREVENT LONGER TERM CON
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA.
WE SHOULD DO ALL WE CAN TO
RESTORE AND SAFEGUARD HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENTAL AND EDUCATIONAL
TRAJECTORY FOR THE CHILDREN IN
OUR CARE.
PROVIDING ENVIRONMENTS
INTERVENTIONS AND RELATIONSHIPS
THAT PROMOTE HEALING AND GROWTH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARM DO WE IF YOU CAN
THE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
ANY COMMENTS.
A WHO.
WELL I'LL ASK THE QUESTION --
KATRINA THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR A
PERSONAL ACCOUNT.
IN YOU --
SAID A BIG GATE WOULD BE
FOCUSING RESOURCES ON SORT OF
THE CARE GIVERS THE FAMILIES.
THAT THEY WOULD DO A BETTER JOB
OF PROVIDING SUPPORT.
HOSE WHEN YOU'RE SORT OF
STATEMENTS OF A BIG PRIORITY
WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE DO YOU
THINK -- YOU
KNOW.
WHAT WOULD BE IF YOUR SAY ONE
BIG THING THAT COULD HELP
[inaudible]
CARE GIVERS.
BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN THAT ROLE
IN PROVIDING STABILITY OF WELL
WHAT WHAT MIGHT IT BE WHAT DO
YOU HAVE IN MIND.
WELL I THINK THEY USE LAST
CENTERS QUALITY PARENTING
INITIATIVE HAS DONE SOME GREAT
WORK AND I KNOW INVENTOR COUNTY
THEY HAVE A PROCESS CREATED
ACTUALLY BY A FOSTER PARENT.
PARENT PARTNER SO SOMEONE WHO
WAS AND I THINK STILL AS A
FOSTER PARENT AND NOW SUPPORTS A
MENTOR AS OTHER FOSTER PARENTS.
AND BASICALLY WHEN A FAMILY PUTS
IN A SEVEN DAY NOTICE THEY
PROVIDE SEVEN TO TEN WEEKS OF
TRAINING AROUND.
TRAUMA GRIEF AND LOSS AND 90% OF
THE SEVEN DAY NOTICE SAYS ARE
THAN REST SEND IT BECAUSE THE
FAMILIES HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF BOTH WHAT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GOING.
TO THRILL AND THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY AND WHAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY DO TO CREATE A HEALING
ENVIRONMENT SO I THINK SEEING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL COULD REALLY
IMPACT STABILITY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
AND BECAUSE EVEN WHEN.
FOSTER PARENTS FEEL LIKE GIVING
UP THEN THEY'RE GIVEN THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR ROLE IS
AND UNDERSTAND HOW TO DO THAT
WHILE RATE.
THAT THAT'S FOR RESIDENTS WITH
ME WHEN I WAS GROWING UP I WAS
THE YOUNGEST OF FOUR BOYS.
AND WHEN I WAS IN [inaudible]
MIDDLE SCHOOL.
MY PARENTS INVITED A YOUNG MAN
FROM THE SENATOR COUNTY FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM STAY WITH US.
AND HONESTLY THEY DID NOT KNOW
HOW TO DEAL WITH HIM.
HE WAS DIFFERENT THAN THEY ARE
THERE FOR BOYS.
AND IN A FAIRLY SHORT TIME HE
WAS NO LONGER IN THE WHOLE.
AND MY PARENTS WERE GOOD PEOPLE
AND HILL.
TRUST ME.
RAISING FOR COOLEY BOYS WAS A
LITTLE BIT LIKE BEING A LION
TAMER -- BUT
SOMEHOW THEY DIDN'T REALLY KNOW
HOW TO DEAL WITH THIS YOUNG MAN
AND HIS NEEDS.
AS FOR GAVE UP SO COULD I JUST
ADD.
TO A CATALINA'S COMMENTS TO SAY
THAT ANOTHER WAY OF I THINK
MAKING SOME SYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS.
IS THE PRE PLACEMENT FAMILY FOR
JUST THE REASON THAT YOU MENTION
THAT IS IF PEOPLE HAVE DIRECT
HELP IN PREPARING. FOR THE
PERSON THERE THAT'S ACTUALLY
COMING TO THEM AND HOW.
THAT RELATIONSHIP CAN BE YOU
KNOW HELP TO START.
IN A GOOD WAY ESPECIALLY.
YOU KNOW IF THAT HAPPENS BEFORE
THE CHILD IS PLACED.
AND MAYBE DURING THE PLACEMENT
YOU KNOW AT THAT HAPPENS NOW BUT
I THINK THERE IS NOT.
AS MUCH PRE PLACEMENT INDIVIDUAL
SPECIFIC.
WORK.
OKAY.
THAT MAKES SENSE TO YOU CREEK
TWENTY YEAH I THINK THAT.
MY BIGGEST PROBLEM IS THAT IT'S
THE SYSTEM CAN BE VERY QUICK
INCLUDING CARE GIVERS OR
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES VERY
QUICK TO CALL THE POLICE ARE
FIFTY ONE FIFTY OR PUNISH THE
YOUNG PERSON --
WHEN REALLY THE PROBLEM ISN'T?
THE PROBLEM ISN'T THAT YOUNG
PERSON'S BEHAVIOUR IT'S THE WAY
THAT PEOPLE AROUND THEM ARE
RESPONDING TO IT AND IF THEY HAD
PEOPLE AROUND THEM WERE
RESPONDING TO THAT BEHAVIOR MORE
APPROPRIATELY THEN THE BEHAVIOR
WITH CHANGE.
THAT'S WHAT BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE
TEACHES US RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT DEVELOPMENT --
IS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
BRAIN SCIENCE YOUNG PEOPLE
RESPOND TO REWARDS AND FOSTER
CARE IS A PUNISHMENT BASED
SYSTEM WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE --
HAVE TO EARN GOOD THINGS BUT
IT'S A LOT HARDER TO EARN A GOOD
THING THAT IT IS TO BE PUNISHED
FOR SOMETHING THAT YOU DIDN'T
EVEN REALLY NEED TO DO.
AND THAT'S KIND OF AN
ELABORATION ON YOUR OWN INITIAL
TESTIMONY YOU WERE DESCRIBING
YOUR EXPERIENCE.
RIGHT NOW OKAY THANK YOU.
FIRST OFF --
COMPANY NOW YOU.
HAVE A TREMENDOUS VOICE AND I
BET THERE'S A WONDERFUL
BACKSTORY. FOR FOR WHY YOU
BECAME A SOCIAL WORKER AND
WANTED TO HELP OTHERS.
BUT I REALLY WANTED TO FOCUS IF
I COULD AS WELL ON TO WHAT WE
CAN DO BETTER.
WHEN WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY?
I WAS RECENTLY AT A NATIONAL
CONFERENCE ON A SAYS I'M A BIG
FAN AND DON'T GET ME SO BOXING
ABOUT DRAMA OKAY.
AND YET. ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS
ECHOED WHAT YOU WERE SAYING.
AND I'M SAYING IF WE'VE
INCARCERATED SOMEONE AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT THEY'VE BEEN
PLACED INTO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM WHY ARE WE NOT
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDING THEM
PARENTING COURSES. FOR WHEN
THEY'RE RELEASED.
IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY WHILE WE
HAVE THEM IN OUR HAPPEN WITH US.
TO HELP GIVING THEM SOME TOOLS
THAT THEY NEEDED ABOUT BEING A
PARENT IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY.
HAVING THREE YOUNG DAUGHTERS
MYSELF THERE ISN'T A RULE BOOK
THAT THEY HAND YOU AND YET.
LIKE THE DOCTOR WAS SAYING THOSE
EARLY ESTABLISHMENT OF THAT
THOSE DISRUPTIONS AN ATTACHMENT
ARE SO LIFELONG AND TRAUMATIZED.
SO I'M GONNA WANT TO REACH OUT
TO YOU GOT THAT ENOUGH WE CAN TO
FIGURE OUT IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN GIVING
VOICE TO BECAUSE I AM WILLING TO
ACCEPT YOUR CHALLENGE AND FIGURE
OUT HOW.
THOSE OF US CAN DO A BETTER JOB
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE LISTEN TO
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
BUT FINALLY IF I CAN WE'RE NOT
GOING TO COME UP WITH THE
ANSWERS OURSELVES THAT'S WHY WE
NEEDED THIS HEARING TODAY.
AND I'M SO APPRECIATIVE THAT
YOU'RE HERE TODAY TO GIVE VOICE
TO THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
NIGHT AND MY MY AND SOMETHING TO
THINK ABOUT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT
GOING -- TO
SOLVE ANY ISSUES RIGHT NOW BUT
MY IS THE GROUP HOMES I MEAN
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
CONCERNS RIGHT BY.
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT THE GROUP
HOMES I HAD A SITUATION ACTUALLY
MY SISTER WHERE SHE MET A FOSTER
KID OD TWO WEEKS AGO?
AND HE WAS --
REALLY SHAKEN UP AND SAYS I HAVE
TO GO HOME I HAVE TO GO HOME --
AND IT WAS LIKE SEVEN PM AND HE
SAYS IF I DON'T MAKE IT HOME BY
EIGHT I DON'T GET TO EAT.
AND AND THAT IS STILL WITH ME I
IT'S DISTURBING ME STILL BECAUSE
I WISH I KNEW WHAT THE KIDS THAT
YOU KNOW I WISH I COULD DO
SOMETHING --
BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS OUT OF THE
ORDINARY FROM WHAT I HEARD YOU
TALK ABOUT ITS THE PUNISHMENT
BASED SYSTEM.
ABOUT WHAT THEY DO AND DON'T DO
AND I WOULD AT SOME POINT YOU
KNOW AND HOPEFULLY --
WE CAN CHAT AFTER YOU CHAT WITH
THE DOCTOR ARAMBULA ABOUT THE
THE GROUP HOMES.
AND IS THERE ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO. TO SUPPORT BECAUSE I
ALSO KNOW THAT IN A GROUP HOME
THERE IS YOU KNOW WHAT I KNOW.
MORE THAN ONE CHILD PER CARE
GIVER AND SO HOW DO WE SUPPORT
THOSE GROUP HOME --
CARE GIVERS BIG BEING THAT
THERE'S MULTIPLE CHILDREN IN THE
HOME AND AND YOUR EXPERIENCES
THAT OBVIOUSLY IT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE IT WAS A POSITIVE ONE IF
YOU WITH A WALL TO SET A COUPLE
TIMES.
THERE WAS A REASON FOR IT AND SO
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR OR MAYBE IF
pTHOUGHT INTO IT MAYBE WE CAN
MEET AT SOME POINT I AND SO THAT
YOU CAN HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO IN TERMS OF
TRAINING THOSE THAT ARE HAVE
MULTIPLE --
KIDS IN THEIR CARE.
AND I DON'T.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIX IT TODAY.
I MEAN IF I'M A FOR HONEST I
WISH WE CAN COME UP WITH ALL OF
THE FIXES AND SAY HEY OKAY THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE DOING AND IT'S
GOOD AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON BUT
THAT'S NOT OUR REALITY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY BUT IT FEELS.
HORRIBLE TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
WHILE THIS IS NOT OUR REALITY
THEY'RE STILL FOSTER KIDS THIRDS
SUFFERING RIGHT NOW.
AND SO THAT'S IT'S DIFFICULT TO
TO TALK ABOUT BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS.
IN IN FUTURE I'M HOW OF THE
FOSTER AND THE GROUP HOMES OR
EVEN THE JUVENILE --
CENTER WE CAN PROVIDE SERVICE
SERVICES. TO THE CARE GIVERS SO
THAT THEY CAN SUPPORT THE KIDS A
LITTLE BIT BETTER NOW BEALL
CONTACT YOU AND SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN YOU KNOW THROUGH THE SEA
WHITE -- SEE
WE CAN YOU KNOW HAVE A BIGGER
DISCUSSION AT SOME POINT BUT
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN FOR NOW IF YOU CAN
THINK ABOUT IT AND YOU KNOW IN
THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS IF WE CAN
MEET WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU YES.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD ONE MORE
COMMENT I WE'RE GOING TO DISCUSS
THAT LATER WHEN KATHY CENTRELINK
IS UP HERE AND MAYBE I'LL JUST
PREFACE IT BY THE BUT YOUR
COMMENT REGARDING.
THAT -- WE
PENALIZE PEOPLE BY CALLING THE
POLICE.
WHO ELSE CAN WE CALL?
AND WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO THAT'S A
BETTER RESPONSE THAN THAT.
THAT MAKING SURE WE'RE MEETING
THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT'S WHAT I HOPE KATHY IS ABLE
TO TALK ABOUT LATER AND
SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON BECAUSE THE
ANSWER CAN'T BE TO LOCK THEM UP.
THEY CAN'T BE TO DRAMATIZE THEM
pOF BEHAVIORS THAT ISN'T WORKING
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
AND CHANGE THE SYSTEM AND THE
PORT THAT.
THANK YOU WE GET WE'RE GIVING
YOU A LOT OF HOMEWORK BUT THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
THANK YOU.
AND I'M A CAL GRANT TO GO BEARS.
THANK YOU THEN NEXT UP JOINING
US NEXT IS AND GET MY GLASSES ON
WE GOT BEN JOHNSON A SENIOR
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST
LEGISLATIVE.
ANALYST'S OFFICE KING CAME
SUNSET AMEND L. C. S. W.
CONSULTANT TO THE ACTOR SHASTA
COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
I DEBRA SILVER DIVISION CHIEF
HIGH RISK SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
ALLEY COUNTY.
AND ART Là LAURA HINES --
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFERED STE
OFFICER STANFORD USE SOLUTIONS
AND STEVE ELSE AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER CASA PACIFICA.
TO HAVE ENOUGH CHAIRS.
THANK YOU ALL ALL FOR BEING HERE.
HI THERE --
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE --
THE PREVIOUS PANEL TOUCHED ON
EXPERIENCES PERSPECTIVES --
FROM --
INDIVIDUALS IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND I'M GONNA DISCUSS
REALLY THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AS IT INTERACTS WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM --
I JUST NOTE AT THE OUTSET THAT --
HOW HOW MENTAL AT THE HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM IS
STRUCTURED IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT
IT'S IT'S REALLY A LARGE SYSTEM
THAT?
SERVES MULTIPLE POPULATIONS
ADULTS CHILDREN NON FOSTER CARE
CHILDREN AND AND AND AND AND
FOSTER CARE CHILDREN SO IT'S A
REALLY A WIDER SYSTEM AND FOSTER
CARE CHILDREN.
ARE ARE IMPORTANT SUB SO CAN I
GO BACK GO BACK AND FORTH A
LITTLE BIT BETWEEN THE TWO BUT
JUSTIN -- TO
PREFACE THAT DISCUSSION AT WAY
I'M I HAVE A HANDOUT THAT SHOULD
BE IN YOUR PACKETS --
OVERVIEW OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND FUNDING FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN --
AND SO STARTING ON PAGE ONE JUST
TO GIVE SOME BACKGROUND --
THERE ARE ABOUT SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN THE STATE'S
FOSTER CARE.
SYSTEM AND ALL FOSTER CHILDREN
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE OUR
MEDIC HOUSE THE STATE'S MEDICAID
PROGRAM --
AND SO ON LIKE ADULTS AND NON
FOSTER CHILDREN WHERE
ELIGIBILITY WILL DEPEND UPON
HOUSEHOLD INCOME OR ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS FOSTER
CHILDREN GAIN ACCESS TO MEDICAL.
REGARDLESS CHILDREN GENERALLY ON
MEDI CAL INCLUDING FOSTER
CHILDREN ARE ENTITLED TO A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY OF SIR OF
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
BENEFITS.
THAN ADULTS ARE --
THIS BENEFIT IS KNOWN AS THE
EARLY PERIODIC.
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT OR E. P. S. T. E. P.
S. D. T. BENEFIT.
AND IN GENERAL THE EPS TEACH --
INDIVIDUALS UP TO AGE --
TWENTY ONE TO PERIODIC PERIODIC
HEALTH SCREENINGS TO CERTAIN
SERVICES THAT WOULD NIGHT WOULD
NOT OTHERWISE BE AVAILABLE TO
ADULTS AND TWO RELATIVELY LESS
STRINGENT MEDICAL NECESSITY
CRITERIA.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE SERVICES
MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES ARE A COMPONENT UNDER
THE PST TEAM.
NOW FOR MEDI CAL SERVICES WE CAN
GENERALLY DIVIDE THEM INTO
SPECIAL THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND NON SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
SPECIAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ARE THOSE FOR THAT ARE --
RELATIVELY INTENSIVE AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH --
GENERALLY WITH A HIGHER LEVEL OF
SEVERITY OR LIFE IMPAIRMENTS --
CAUSED BY THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION --
AT LEAST ON THE ADULT SIDE OR
JUST -- TO
MENTAL CAT MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS THAT PRECLUDE
APPROPRIATE DEVELOPMENT IN
CHILDREN --
EXAMPLES OF SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ARE PSYCHIATRIC
INPATIENT SERVICES OR GROUP OR
INDIVIDUAL THERAPY AND COUNTIES
ARE THE ADMINISTERING ENTITY FOR
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN THE STATE.
ON THE OTHER HAND FOR NON
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WITHIN MEDI CAL INDIVIDUALS MAY
ACCESS THESE PRIMARILY
OUTPATIENT --
LESS INTENSIVE SERVICES CARE
PHYSICIAN AND THESE ARE PROVIDED
THROUGH EITHER MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE OR THROUGH FEE FOR SERVICE
FOR FOSTER FOSTER CARE KIDS ARE
NOT --
MANDATORILY ENROLLED IN MANAGED
CARE SO MANY OF THESE CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE ARE GOING TO
ACCESS THE ANY MILD AND
POTENTIAL MILD TO MODERATE
BENEFITS THROUGH THE FEE FOR
SERVICE IT FOR THREE THREE THE
FEE FOR SERVICE SYSTEM WITH
THEIR PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN
THERE.
ULTIMATELY THERE ARE MULTIPLE
STATE AND COUNTY ENTITIES THAT A
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TOTAL CARE
AND SUPERVISION OF CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE --
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENT
SUPERVISED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE REALLY FOR
THE FOSTER CARE SIDE OF THINGS --
FOR THE CARE AND SUPERVISION OF
THE CHILDREN WERE AS COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS --
WITH OVERSIGHT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND INCLUDING THE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
THAT ARE DELIVERED FOR CHILDREN
AND FOR FOSTER CHIP FOSTER
CHILDREN SPECIFICALLY --
FINALLY WAS THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS IN THE FEE FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS THAT WILL DELIVER
THOSE AND TULARE MILD TO
MODERATE BENEFITS --
AS WELL AS SCREENING AND
REFERRAL OF CHILDREN --
TO SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
TURNING TO PAGE THREE PROVIDE A
AN OVERVIEW OF CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SO THESE ARE THE MEDI
CAL SERVICES AND THESE ARE
REALLY AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
THE SERVICES THAT --
FOSTER CHILDREN MIGHT UTILIZE --
BEING CATEGORICALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL AND REALLY COVERING
SORT OF A BROAD SERVICES AND
SPREAD MEDI CAL AND SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IS JUST A
IT'S A KEY AREA.
OF SERVICES THAT FOSTER CHILDREN
ARE GOING TO ULTIMATELY RECEIVE
AND AS WITH THE AS WITH MEDI CAL
BENEFITS BROADLY THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR SPECIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IS IS BROADER FOR
CHILDREN AND FOR ADULTS I
UNDERSTAND THE NEXT SPEAKER IS
GOING.
TO GO INTO THAT IN GREATER
DETAIL SO ALL --
I'LL LEAVE THAT THEIR BUT SO
MOVING ON TO HOW WHERE FOSTER
KIDS FIT INTO THE LARGER
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
IN A GIVEN YEAR ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN RECEIVES A SPECIAL ANY
SPECIAL BE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SO THIS IS ALL CHILDREN
ON MEDI CAL.
ABOUT FORTY FORTY THOUSAND OF
THESE ARE OUR FOSTER CHILDREN SO
ABOUT 15% OF THE SPECIAL THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
CHILDREN'S CASELOAD.
REPRESENTS FOSTER CHILDREN.
TURNING TO PAGE --
FOR THERE'S A FIGURE HERE --
AND THIS SHOWS THAT FOSTER
CHILDREN UTILIZE SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT A MUCH
HIGHER RATE THAN ALL CHILDREN ON
MEDI CAL --
ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THAT FIGURE
ABOUT 50% OF FOSTER CHILDREN
WILL RECEIVE AT LEAST ONE
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
WITHIN A GIVEN YEAR.
AS COMPARES TO LESS THAN 5% FOR
MEDI CAL CHILDREN GENERALLY SO
ABOUT TEN TIMES THE RATE --
NOW. ONE SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE MIGHT ONLY MEAN THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GETTING AN
ASSESSMENT HOWEVER --
SO TO REALLY BE ABLE TO SEE WHO
IS REALLY CONTINUOUSLY ENGAGED
IN TREATMENT AND SO FORTH --
I WOULD TURN TO THE RIGHT SIDE
OF THE FIGURE WHICH SHOWS THE
NUMBER OF THE RATE OF AT WHICH
CHILDREN --
RECEIVE AT LEAST FIVE SPECIAL
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WITHIN A GIVEN YEAR AND THAT
SHOWS THAT ABOUT 35%.
OF FOSTER KIDS ARE. TO SOME
DEGREE CONTINUOUSLY ENGAGED IN
SOME SORT OF SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR OR AS THAT RATE IS ABOUT 3%
FOR MEDI CAL --
CHILDREN AS A WHOLE SO THEY DO
UTILIZE --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT A AT A
AT A HIGHER RATE THERE.
THE ON TURNING TO PAGE FIVE THE
STATEWIDE SPENDING AVERAGES ALSO
DIFFER FOR FOSTER CHILDREN
VERSUS --
YOU KNOW NON FOSTER CHILDREN ON
MEDI CAL WE AT ONE COULD SAY --
THERE THIRTY THREE DEAF 50% HIGH
CAPITA EXPENDITURES ON FOSTER
CHILDREN SO THAT COULD POINT TO
THE FACT THAT --
FOSTER CHILDREN ARE RECEIVING
RELATIVELY MORE INTENSIVE
SERVICES AS WELL NOT ONLY JUST A
A HIGHER NUMBER OF SERVICES.
AND THEN LASTLY JUST NOTE THAT --
SPENDING ON THE SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SERVICES WITHIN
MEDI CAL AND AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
HAS INCREASED FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANTLY IN RECENT YEARS.
GROWING OVER ALL FOR ALL KIDS
FROM ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION TO
TWO BILLION BETWEEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN IS ABOUT 6%
ANNUAL GROWTH RATE.
AND THE RATE OF GROWTH --
IS JUST A A LITTLE SMALLER FOR
FOSTER KIDS BUT PRETTY
COMPARABLE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S MEDI CAL
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ANOTHER --
IMPORTANT AREA OF SERVICES AND
FUNDING IS WHAT'S AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT --
ALSO KNOWN AS PROP SIXTY THREE
OR SHORTEN TO MHSAA AND THIS
PROVIDES --
FUNDING TO REALLY INCREASE --
THE ARRAY OF SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE --
TO BOTH CHILDREN AND TWO ADULTS
IT'S OUT FUNDED IT'S THE THE
REVENUES GENERATED BY SURTAX ON
INCOMES OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT'S REALLY FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING OFTEN --
SERVICES THAT WOULDN'T BE
COVERED BY MEDICARE ALL SO NOT
BY SPECIAL WHAT THESE ARE NOT
NECESSARILY SPECIALLY MENTAL
SERVICES.
AND THESE WOULD BE SUCH THINGS
AS WRAPAROUND SERVICES
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICES --
AS WELL AS SORT OF VERY HIGHLY
INTENSIVE SERVICES --
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGH NEEDS
AND ESPECIALLY ON THE PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION THAT THAT
IS SORT OF TARGETED TOWARDS
CHILDREN --
IN GENERAL AND SO FOSTER CARE
KIDS WHILE WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY DATA REALLY ON HOW MUCH.
PREVENTION EARLY AND
INTERVENTION FUNDING SAY.
IT GOES TOWARDS FOSTER CARE KIDS
BECAUSE REALLY COUNTIES HAVE.
A WIDE WIDE AMOUNT OF LATITUDE
AND DISCRETION OVER HOW THEY
SPEND THESE FUNDS IN THE TYPES
OF POPULATIONS THAT THEY TARGET.
IT IS LIKELY THAT FOSTER CARE --
CHILDREN DO BENEFIT SOME FROM
THE SERVICES.
UP NEXT I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM WHICH IS A PACKAGE OF
LEGISLATIVE COLLATION --
PASSED IN RECENT YEARS THAT DOES
A BROADER ARRAY OF THINGS AND
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON REDUCING
RELIANCE IN ON INSTITUTIONAL
SETTINGS LIKE CONGREGATE CARE
AND BOOSTING THE CAPACITY OF
HOME BASED FAMILY PLACEMENTS --
CCAR AS IT'S KNOWN DOES A SET OF
CHANGES TO SPECIAL ATIV MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE DELIVERY --
IN REALLY TRYING TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO THOSE SERVICES --
THE FOR EXAMPLE CCR PLACEMENT
SETTINGS THAT TYPICALLY SERVE
FOSTER CHILDREN WITH SOMEWHAT
ELEVATED NEEDS ARE WILL NOW BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
EITHER BY.
DIRECTLY EMPLOYING MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS ON THEIR STAFF OR BY
WORKING WITH CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS --
WHO WILL COME AND SERVE THE THE
THEIR CHILDREN?
AND THEN THE LAST SECTIONS AND
NOW ON PAGE --
EIGHT I'M GONNA GIVE A A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF FUNDING FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES HERE --
FUNDING IS RATHER COMPLEX AND AS
I NOTED AT THE OUTSET.
THE WAY THAT THE FUNDING IS
STRUCTURED IS THAT IT SUPPORTS
SORT OF MULTIPLE POPULATION SO
THERE IS.
IN GENERAL IT'S THERE IS NO
FUNDING THAT'S SAY --
ART THERE'S IN GENERAL FUNDING
IS NOT STRUCTURED SO THAT
SPECIFICALLY TARGETS FOSTER
CHILDREN INSTEAD IT'S IT'S
FUNDING GENERALLY FOR CHILDREN'S
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OR OR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
INDIGENT POPULATIONS BROADLY.
BUT FOSTER CHILDREN DO RELY ON
THESE FUNDING STREAMS FOR THE
SERVICES THAT THEY DO RECEIVE SO --
JUST A JUST A HIGHLIGHT THAT SO
THERE'S A FIGURE ON PAGE EIGHT
THAT KIND OF GIVES AN OVER
ARCHING VIEW AND THEN AS I GO
THROUGH THE NEXT PAGES ALL ALL
BRIEFLY KIND OF DESCRIBE WHAT
THOSE ARE.
SO FIRST THERE'S THERE'S FUNDING
FOR THE NON COUNTY --
BASED THE HEALTH SERVICES THESE
ARE THOSE MILD TO MODERATE
SERVICES AND AND THAT'S GENERAL
THE STATE GENERAL FUND --
AND MATCHED WITH THE FEDERAL
MEDICAID DOLLARS THAT GO THROUGH
EITHER THE STATE'S FEE FOR
SERVICE SYSTEM OR THROUGH
MANAGED CARE PLANS FORTUNATELY
THE FUNDING AMOUNT IS IS UNKNOWN
AT THIS TIME --
BUT IT IT IT LIKELY IS FAIRLY
WELL ULTIMATELY FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT --
THE NEXT THE NEXT MAJOR FRONT
FUNDING SOURCES ARE THOSE THAT
GO TO COUNTY BASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THESE THERE ARE AN
ARRAY OF FUNDING SOURCES AND
I'LL JUST DESCRIBE --
THE THE MAJOR ONES HERE.
FIRST HERE IS THE FEDERAL FUND
PARTICIPATION THIS OF THE
FEDERAL MEDICAID FUNDING --
THAT THE STATE RECEIVES NOW --
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS --
YOU GET A DIFFERENT SORT OF
MATCH RATE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF MEDICAID --
DOLLARS FOR FOSTER CHILDREN IT'S
GENERALLY GOING TO ALWAYS BE 50%
SO FOR ANY SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE THAT A FOSTER
CHILD IS GOING TO USE --
THAT'S TYPICALLY GOING TO BE
MATCHED WITH A 50% OF FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE AT LEAST A 50% OF
FUNDING WILL COMPRISE THAT WILL
BE COMPRISED THERE.
IN -- TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FOR COUNTY
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
FOR ALL MEDI CAL AND REALLY
SEARCH FOSTER KIDS FUNDING WAS --
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR MEDICAID WAS
THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
NEXT WE HAVE --
LOCAL REALIGNMENT DOLLARS AND
WHAT THESE ARE IS THAT THE STATE
DEDICATES A PORTION OF SALES TAX
AND VEHICLE LICENSE FEE REVENUE.
AND SEND IT TO COUNTIES TO PAY
FOR THE COUNTY'S RESIDENTS --
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES FAVOR
OF SERVICES COMPRISE BOTH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SUBSTANCE
USE SERVICES FOR COUNTIES HAVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF HOW
MUCH FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVE
GOES TO MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIFICALLY OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SO FORTH.
BUT THIS IS REALLY THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF NON FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES --
FOR CHILDREN CELL AND IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THERE'S AN
ESTIMATED TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WENT TO
COUNTIES AND LOCAL REALIGNMENT
REVENUES FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES AND THIS FUNDING
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR FOSTER KIDS.
NEXT THURS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FUND THIS IS GENERATED
THROUGH THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT AND PROVIDES THOSE
VARIOUS INTO INTENSIVE --
PREVENTIVE SERVICES AND IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ABOUT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS WILL GO DOWN
TO COUNTIES --
TO SUPPORT COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES --
AND AND SOME PORTION OF THAT --
MAY SUPPORT SERVICES FOR FOSTER
KIDS FINALLY THERE'S THE STATE
GENERAL FUND CONTRIBUTION NOW
BECAUSE THE STATE DEDICATES OF
FUNDING IN THE FORM OF THE LOCAL
REALIGNMENT REVENUES. TO
COUNTIES FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THE GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTION TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IS ACTUALLY SOMEWHAT
LIMITED --
GENERAL FUND TODAY --
TYPICALLY GOES FOR WHAT YOU
MIGHT CONSIDER NEW STATE FEDERAL
OR JUDICIAL MANDATES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPOSED SENSE WE SORT OF
CREATED THE FUNDING FORMULAS
THAT SEND THE VEHICLE LICENSE
FEE AND SALES TAX REVENUE DOWN
TO THE COUNTIES.
AND SO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THERE'S AN ESTIMATED
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND THAT
GOES -- TO
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL REALLY FOR
ALL MEDI CAL AND RELEASE AND
FOSTER CHILDREN SERVICES.
ARE INCLUDED IN THAT SO ALL LAST
TOUCH ON SOME OF THE TRENDS --
FUNDING FOR COUNTY MENTAL
SERVICES HAS GROWN FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANTLY IN RECENT YEARS --
BETWEEN TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY
TWELVE THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TOTAL FUNDING
FOR COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
HAS GROWN FROM ABOUT FIVE POINT
FOUR BILLION TO ABOUT SEVEN
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS --
THIS IS AN ANNUAL GROWTH RATE OF
AROUND 8% AND I MEAN JUST TO TIE
IT BACK TO SO THAT'S SORT OF ON
THE REVENUE SIDE FOR COUNTIES TO
TIE BACK TO WHERE SPENDING.
AS WE SAW FOR CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH SIR SPENDING INCREASES ON
THE RANGE OF ABOUT 526% SO
LITTLE HIGHER REVENUE GROWTH --
BUT YOU KNOW CERTAINLY NOT A
MAGNITUDE DIFFERENCE THERE --
SO THAT'LL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS
IT COMPLICATED AIRY BUT HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
WILL BE READING ABOUT THIS IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT I'M SURE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
AFTERNOON I'M KIM SUDIRMAN AND I
AM A CONSULTANT FOR THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I'M ALSO RETIRED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR FROM YOLO COUNTY
AND PREVIOUSLY AT SEVERAL OTHER
COUNTY AS THE CHILDREN'S DEPUTY
OVER CHILDREN YOU SERVICES.
SO QUITE A FEW YEARS SERVING OF
THIS POPULATION WHICH WE'RE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT TODAY AND SO MY
PORTION IS REALLY SPECIFICALLY
TO MEDI CAL --
I'LL DO A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH IN GENERAL --
BEEN WENT OVER QUITE A BIT OF IT
BUT I WANTED TO REALLY --
I HAVE THREE HAND OUTS FOR YOU
AND I WILL MENTION THEM BUT NOT
WALK THROUGH THEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE MORE DETAILED SO THAT
YOU CAN SEE.
THERE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALTY SERVICES DEFINITIONS
SO IT'S A LIST OF ALL THE
SERVICES IN THE DEFINITIONS THAT
GO WITH THEM --
MEDICAL NECESSITY WHICH I WILL
TALK ABOUT FOR EPS T. T. AND
THEN A BRIEF --
PAGE ABOUT MANAGED PROVIDE SO --
LET ME JUST BEGIN.
BY SAYING THAT --
THERE ARE SERVICES BETTER PEOPLE
THINK OF WHEN THEY THINK OF
MENTAL HEALTH THAT ARE FAIRLY
TRADITIONAL.
PEOPLE THINK OF OF INDIVIDUAL
THERAPY FAMILY THERAPY GROUP
THERAPY AND SEEING A
PSYCHIATRIST THAT WAS A VERY
COMMON SERVICES IN THOSE ARE
SERVICES.
THE CAT THAT THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND OR THEIR
PROVIDERS --
THAT THEY CONTRACT WITH PROVIDE.
BUT THERE'S A WHOLE TON OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES THAT
ARE CRITICAL FOR THE CHILDREN --
IN THE FOSTER YOU FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THAT ARE CRITICAL AND
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE MUCH OF
WHICH ARE NOT PROVIDED BY THE
COUNTIES.
BY THE COUNTIES ORGANIZATION
PROVIDERS WHICH YOU'LL HEAR FROM
SOME OF THEM THIS AFTERNOON
AFTER MYSELF AND SO THAT
PARTNERSHIP IS REALLY CRITICAL --
WE THINK OF OUR PROVIDERS AS US
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THAT PARTNERSHIP AND WORK WELL
TOGETHER TO SERVE THE KIDS
BECAUSE SO MUCH.
IS IN THE COMMUNITY AND MY MY
OPINION AFTER BUSINESS IS IF WE
COULDN'T DO COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES AND I REMEMBER THE DAYS
WHEN WE DID NOT.
OTHER THAN CASE MANAGEMENT WE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE THE
KIDS AS THEY NEED IT AND
CERTAINLY TODAY AS WE HAVE BEEN
DOING --
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT WRAPAROUND
YOU HEAR SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS LIKE --
YOU KNOW WE DID CHILDREN SYSTEM
OF CARE BACK IN NINETY FOUR WHEN
IT STARTED.
YOU KNOW EPS CITY YOU'VE HEARD
OF ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS
WRAPAROUND WAS MENTIONED.
ALL OF THOSE ARE DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND AS YOU HEARD KATERINA TALK
ABOUT THEIR STILL NEEDS I KNOW
SEE SEE OUR CONTINUING CARE
REFORM.
IS TRYING TO TAKE A STAB AT
GETTING THAT CHANGE AND I THINK
WE'RE MAKING GOOD HEADWAY BUT
WE'RE AT THE BEGINNING --
YOU'LL HEAR I'M SURE ABOUT THE
GROUP HOME PROVIDERS A
RESIDENTIAL PROVIDERS THAT ARE
WORKING HARD AND MAKING CHANGES
BUT THERE THAT IT'S JUST A START.
SO I'M HOPING THAT --
NEXT YEAR YOU HEAR A VERY
DIFFERENT SCENARIO FROM HR YOUTH
THAT WENT THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
THIS YEAR THEN YOU HEARD FROM
KATERINA WHO WENT THROUGH THE
SYSTEM.
QUITE A FEW YEARS AGO BECAUSE I
THINK WE HAVE MADE SOME GAINS
NOTHING'S PERFECT BUT I WANTED
TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF THOSE
COMMUNITY BASED LIKE SERVICES --
LIKE TBS THERAPEUTIC BE ACTUALLY
PROBABLY MOST OF THOSE SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED.
BY --
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS WHICH
IS A REALLY A ONE TO ONE KIND OF
SERVICES AND THEN RECENTLY
INTENSIVE CARE COORDINATION
INTENSIVE HOME BASED SERVICES --
AND THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE
AGAIN ALL OF THOSE ARE NOT IN
THE OFFICE.
THERE IN THE COMMUNITY THEY'RE
OUT AND ABOUT THERE WHERE THE
CHILDREN ARE THERE PROVIDED IN A
FOSTER HOME THEIR PROVIDED IN A
RESIDENTIAL SETTING.
THEIR PROVIDED.
AT THE MALL AND WHEN YOU GO FOR
A WALK AND WHEN YOU GO EAT OUT
AT MCDONALDS. TO HELP REALLY.
ADDRESS KIDS NEEDS IN THE MOMENT
NOT WAIT TILL NEXT WEEK FOR THE
FIFTY MINUTE HOUR AND WHO CAN
REMEMBER THE SAME STORY THE SAME
WAY ABOUT HAPPENED.
INTO THOSE SERVICES ARE REALLY
CRITICAL ALONG WITH TVS AND THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
PURE MENTAL HEALTH.
THAT VERY MUCH INTERACTED INTER
RELATE SO I THINK THAT THOSE ARE
VERY CRITICAL --
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE I JUST
WANT TO COMMENT ABOUT THAT
THAT'S HAVING THAT'S A LITTLE
BITOF A SLOW START AS FOSTER
PARENTS.
IT'S A SCARY THING TO BE A
FOSTER PARENT IT'S EVEN MORE
SCARY THING TO THINK I'M GONNA
LEARN HOW TO PROVIDE.
MEDICAL SERVICES AND DOCUMENT IN
A MEDICAL RECORD SO THERE ARE
SOME A LEARNING CURVE THAT'S
GOING ON AND I KNOW OUR FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES IN THE COMMUNITY
ARE WORKING.
ON RECRUITMENT AND TRAINING AND
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT THE I
THOUGHT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
COUNTRY ON SAID WAS.
IN RELATION TO TRAINING THE
PARENTS IS REALLY CRITICAL TO I
REALLY WANT.
TO ECHO THAT AND THAT IS THE
INTENT OF THERAPEUTIC FOSTER
CARE THAT IS THE INTENT OF C. C.
R. WITH RESOURCE FAMILY HOMES
NOW -- IN
THE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF STUFF A LOT OF NEW
PRACTICES THAT ARE REALLY BEING
FOCUSED ON TO HELP.
THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE REALLY
WORKING WITH OUR CHILDREN DAY IN
AND DAY OUT TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ON
HOW TO TO DO A BETTER JOB.
SO I WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
AND THEN JUST A COMMENT IN
RELATION TO THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN CHILDREN AND ADULTS
SERVICES.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED CHILDREN
SERVICES REALLY AND THEN --
MEDICAL NECESSITY DOCUMENT THAT
LOOKS LIKE THIS REALLY TALKS
ABOUT THAT CORRECT RUMELIA RATE.
WHICH IS VERY DIFFERENT IF THAT
A CHILD BECOMES ELIGIBLE IF A
SERVICE IF IF FOR THE CHALLENGE
CAN BE CORRECTED.
OR AMELIORATED THE VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE THAN FROM A VERY
SEVERE --
DIAGNOSIS THAT REQUIRES MAJOR
INTERVENTION SIX FAST TO BE
ELIGIBLE AND IF THERE'S NOT A
BELIEVE THAT THEY'LL BE A MAJOR
TURNAROUND.
THEN THEY MAY NOT MEET CRITERIA
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT IN THE
CHILDREN'S WORLD AND SO WE HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO DO SOMETHING
VERY DIFFERENT AND THAT IS UP TO
AGE.
TWENTY ONE UP TO AGE TWENTY ONE
SO THROUGH AGE TWENTY SO IT'S
ARE TRANSIENT TRANSITIONAL AGE
YOUTH POPULATION AS WELL.
AND THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL AND
CHILD WELFARE HAS ALSO BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD WITH SOME OF
THE THB PLUS AND I'M BLANKING ON
WITH THE T. H. P. PART IS.
BUT IT'S REALLY FOR THE I
HOUSING PROGRAM TEACH BE FLAT SO
ANYWAY WORKING WITH THAT
POPULATION.
AND THEN FINALLY JUST TO COMMENT
ABOUT PRIMARY CARE --
MANAGE CARE UP PLANS AND THE FEE
FOR SERVICE --
THERE'S LIMITATIONS YOU KNOW
THEY ARE REALLY THE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN.
AND THE ANALOGY I USUALLY GIVE
IS IF YOU HAVE SOME KIND OF A
HEART CHALLENGED USUALLY BEGIN
WITH YOUR PRIMARY CARE.
PHYSICIAN YOU BRING AGAIN WITH
YOUR PCP AND IF YOU'RE SHE SAYS
THAT YOU CAN.
OUTLET MAY PRESCRIBE THERE SIR
LET ME WORK WITH YOU ON THIS
CHANGE YOUR EATING HABITS DO
THIS EXERCISE.
AND YOU CAN BE STABLE YOU'RE
DONE.
BUT IF.
YOU NEED SOMETHING ELSE TO MORE
SERIOUS YOU NEED TO SEE A
CARDIOLOGISTS THAT YOU GET
REFERRED.
THERE THE SPECIALTY THAT'S WHAT
COUNTY SPECIAL TEAM AND HEALTH
DOES AND ARE CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS.
THE SHIFT THAT THAT HASN'T QUITE
BEEN AS SUCCESSFUL.
IS WHEN YOUR DONE AFTER YOU'VE
HAD SIR HEART SURGERY.
AND YOU'VE BEEN MONITORED FOR A
YEAR OR SO AND YOU'VE BEEN
STABLE AND YOU'VE CHANGED YOUR
EATING HABITS.
AND YOU'RE TAKING YOU WERE
TAKING YOUR MEDICATION REGULARLY
AND THEN YOU STABILIZE AND
YOU'VE DECREASED YOUR MEDICATION
AND I WERE JUST TAKING A BABY
ASPIRIN.
ONCE A DAY YOU GO BACK TO YOUR
PCP.
WE HAVE A HARDER TIME AS AS
CHILDREN AND ADULTS STABILIZE
GETTING THEM BACK TO THE PC P.
BECAUSE ONCE THEY HAD THAT
DIAGNOSIS.
ONCE YOU HAD HEART PROBLEMS THAT
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE NO
LONGER HAVE A DIAGNOSIS.
BUT YOU'RE STABLE SO THOSE ARE
SOME BUT THAT THE FOR SERVICE
AND MEN MANAGED CARE PLANS
REALLY ADDRESS THAT BEGINNING.
AND ORDINARILY WOULD ADDRESS AT
THE END AFTER SERVICES HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AND SO WERE THE
MIDDLE AND THE FOLKS HERE AT THE
TABLE DO REALLY GOOD WORK AND
HARD WORK. TO ADDRESS THAT
SYSTEM AND SO THAT PARTNERSHIP
IS REALLY CRITICAL.
OTHER PARTNERS I JUST WANT TO
ECHO SOME OF WHAT'S BEEN SAID
WITH THE MALE HEALTH SERVICES
ACT BUT ALSO EDUCATION IS A
CRITICAL PART.
OUR KIDS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN
SCHOOL AND WE WANT THEM IN
SCHOOL SO PARTNERING WITH
EDUCATION OBJECT BUT GENERAL
EDUCATION AND SPECIAL ED --
AS WELL AS THE FAITH COMMUNITY
IS REALLY CRITICAL AND WE REALLY
NEED.
TO NORMALIZE EVERYTHING IN A
MUCH BETTER WAY KIDS SHOULD BE
PLAYING LITTLE LEAGUE KID SHOULD
BE PLAYING SOCCER THEY SHOULD BE
TAKING GUITAR LESSONS AND BALLET
LESSONS.
TO AND SO THAT PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY LIVE IN
IS REALLY CRITICAL SO I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THOSE PIECES.
TO THINK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM DIANA WAGNER
DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S SERVICES
FOR SHASTA COUNTY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
PRIOR TO MY WORK AT WITH THE
COUNTY.
AS A CLINICIAN I PROVIDED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO FOSTER YOUTH
FROM PROBATION IN CHILD WELFARE
AS A THERAPIST AT VICTOR
TREATMENT CENTERS AND SHASTA
COUNTY FOR SIXTEEN YEARS.
SHASTA COUNTY BECAME AN HHO SAY
ELEVEN YEARS AGO.
WHICH IS WHEN WE DIVIDED INTO
FIVE BRANCHES ONE OF THOSE
BRANCHES.
CHILDREN SERVICES BRANCH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR BOTH.
CHILD WELFARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
AND THEIR FAMILIES FOR AGES ZERO
TO TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD.
THERE ARE OTHER COUNTY IS SET UP
SIMILAR SIMILARLY TO SHASTA
COUNTY BUT MOST OF THEM ARE
STILL SEPARATE SEPARATE AGENCIES.
WHILE I MAY HAVE AN EASIER TIME
COORDINATING SERVICES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH DUE TO THE STRUCTURE AND
SHASTA COUNTY.
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CHILD
WELFARE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS
ABSOLUTELY POSSIBLE AND MUST
OCCUR IN ALL COUNTIES IN ORDER
TO BEST SERVE FOSTER YOUTH.
IN SHASTA COUNTY.
FOSTER YOUTH ACCESS SERVICES.
THIS WAS CHANGED IN DECEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AS WE
IMPLEMENTED THE PROCESS OF A
FULL COMPLETE COMPREHENSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH ASSESSMENT TO ALL
FOSTER YOUTH.
AGES THREE TO SEVENTEEN YEARS
OLD IN TWO WEEKS OF ENTERING
FOSTER CARE.
YEAH ASSESSMENT IS COMPLETED BY
CO LOCATED MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIAN IN OUR INTAKE UNIT.
THIS CLINICIAN MEETS WITH THE
CHILD PARENTS CARE GIVERS AND
OTHER IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN THE
CHILD'S LIVES IN ORDER TO GATHER
THE INFORMATION.
THE CHILD ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND
STRENGTHS IS A PART OF THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS. THREE
ASSESSMENT IS CONDUCTED.
IN THE SAME MANNER ANNUALLY FOR
THREE TO TWENTY YEAR OLDS.
INTER COUNTY IMPLEMENTED A
SIMILAR PROCESS IN FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS A CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY I'M REQUIRED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL FOSTER YOUTH
RECEIVE AT LEAST ONE SCREENING
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
WHEN THEY ENTER FOSTER CARE AND
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER?
BUT WHAT WE DISCOVERED IN CHEST
COUNTY BY ONLY COMPLETING THE
SCREENING IS THAT WE WERE NOT
GETTING A FULL PICTURE OF THE
FOSTER USE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
WHICH IS WHY OUR PRACTICE WAS
ADJUSTED.
THE SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED
TO FOSTER YOUTH AND PARENT CAN
ANSWER QUICK QUESTION SO FOR THE
THINGS YOU FELT WERE BEING
MESSED.
THAT PROMPTED THE ADJUSTMENT.
SO JUST AS FOR AN A FOR EXAMPLE
OKAY FOR EXAMPLE --
THERE WAS A SET OF FIFTEEN
TWENTY QUESTIONS THAT WERE KIND
OF CHECKED OFF YES OR NO WHERE
THEY FELL OUT --
TO DEPRESSION.
ONE TO FIVE BECAUSE A CHILD IS
BRAND NEW TO THE SYSTEM THEY MAY
NOT BE FORTHCOMING WHEN YOU'RE
ASKING JUST THOSE SIMPLE
SCREENING QUESTIONS VERSES
LOOKING AT THE CHILD IN THE
WHOLE PICTURE.
BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY SERVING THE
WHOLE CHILD NOT JUST TWENTY
SIMPLE SCREENING QUESTIONS.
CONTROL THANK YOU COUNTY --
AS FAR AS SERVICES PROVIDED TO
FOSTER YOUTH AND THEIR PARENTS.
AS YOU ALL KNOW TITLE FOR EASY
CANNOT BE USED TO SERVE. FOR
SERVICES SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH
SO WE RELY ON OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE SERVICES NEEDED FOR YOUTH
AND THE COMMUNITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO SERVE THEIR PARENTS.
IN SHASTA WE ARE ABLE TO USE EPS
D. T. OR MHSAA FUNDING TO
PROVIDE A WIDE RANGE OF EVIDENCE
BASED.
AND SUPPORT OF THERAPIES FOR
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS.
SOME EXAMPLES OF THIS ARE WE
HAVE AN EIGHT WEEK PARENT
ENGAGEMENT FORCE THAT IS RAN BY
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIANS AND A
DRUG AND ALCOHOL COUNSELOR.
THIS IS USED TO SERVE PARENTS
WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE BEEN REMOVED
FROM THEIR CARE TO ORIENT TAKE
THEM TO CHILD WELFARE. TO ASSESS
THEIR NEEDS.
MAKE REFERRALS TO COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS AND ADDRESS THEIR
TRAUMA.
WE HAVE A POSITIVE PARENTING
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT AN INCREASE
IN PARENTING SKILLS WHILE
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF BOTH THE PARENTS AND
FOSTER YOUTH.
WE USE A ZERO FIVE CLINICIAN TO
WORK WITH NEW PARENTS AND
RESOURCE FAMILIES THAT
SPECIALIZE IN THIS VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
WE HAVE CLINICIANS AN
ORGANIZATIONAL PROVIDERS.
THAT WE FIND IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THE INDIVIDUAL THERAPY IN HOME
BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT INTENSIVE
CASE COORDINATION AND FAMILY
THERAPY THAT'S NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS.
WHEN MOVING FROM FAMILY
REUNIFICATION TO FAMILY
MAINTENANCE WE HAVE CLINICIANS
TO HELP SUPPORT?
THE KIDS TRANSITIONING BACK HOME
OR YOU MAY DECIDE TO USE OUR
WRAPAROUND TEAM IN ORDER TO
ASSESS THAT TRANSITION AND
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE ENTIRE
FAMILY.
WE ALSO HAVE CASE SAFE CARE TO
THAT SERVES CHILDREN ZERO TO SIX
AND THEIR FAMILIES TO INCREASE
PARENTING KNOWLEDGE WHILE
ADDRESSING HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES OF THE CHILDREN.
OUR SOCIAL WORKERS AND
CLINICIANS COLLABORATE.
IN SHASTA.
BY HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIAN AND DRUG AND ALCOHOL
COUNSELOR SIT WITH THE
INVESTIGATION DIVISION CASE
STAFF MEANS TO BRING THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND PERSPECTIVE TO THE
TABLE.
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE NEXT STEPS
IN AN INVESTIGATION AS PULP AS
PART OF A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
APPROACH.
WE ALSO HAVE CLINICIANS THAT ARE
CO LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE CHILD
WELFARE DIVISION.
SO TO INCREASE COMMUNICATION AND
SERVICES TO YOUTH ON CASE
SPECIFIC NEEDS.
WHICH IS VERY HELPFUL AND
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE IN
ALL COUNTIES.
SO WHAT DO COUNTIES NEED TO
EFFECTIVELY SERVE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY UNDER C. C.
R..
WE NEED TRUE SHARED LEADERSHIP
FROM THE TO STATE DEPARTMENTS
FOR MEANING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF CHILDREN YOUTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
IN CONSISTENT COMMUNICATION HAS
A RIPPLE EFFECT ON LOCAL
AGENCIES AND I SEE THIS FIRST
HAND AS THE DIRECTOR FROM BOTH
PROGRAMS.
AND THIS NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
FOR EXAMPLE BOTH STATE
DEPARTMENTS SK FOR SCREENING
DATA FROM THE TWO COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS.
THIS WAS DUE ON THE SAME DAY
WITH DIFFERENT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
CANS IMPLEMENTATION VERY LITTLE
THOUGHT TO COORDINATING
IMPLEMENTATION STRATEGIES MEANS
DIFFERENT REPORTING DIFFERENT
SETS OF QUESTIONS DIFFERENT AGE
GROUPS.
AND EVEN THOUGH WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE USING THE CANS TO WORK
TOGETHER.
WE NEED A COORDINATED DATA
SYSTEM AT A MINIMUM.
SO THAT WE CAN JOINTLY TRACK THE
INFORMATION.
ON THE YOUTH TO MAKE PROGRAM
DECISIONS TO MEET THE CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES NEEDS.
WE NEED STATE LEADERSHIP TOWARDS
A MULTI GENERATIONAL APPROACH TO
HEALING TRAUMA BOTH FOR CHILDREN
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES.
I AM PLEASED TO PARTICIPATE ON
THE AB THREE FORTY WORK GROUP
LED BY DH CS THAT IS CONSIDERING
VARIOUS TRAUMA SCREENS FOR ALL
CHILDREN SERVED BY EPS D. T..
AND THAT WORK IS AN IMPORTANT
START TO ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE WE WORK
WITH FAMILIES IMPACTED BY A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE MENTAL ILLNESS IN THE
HOME FAMILY SEPARATION.
AND MMHM MULTI GENERATIONAL
ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
AS A CHILD WELFARE DIRECTOR AND
CLINICIAN.
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO BE
TALKING ABOUT IN ADDRESSING
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
NOT ONLY THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BUT ALSO THE PARENTS IN ORDER TO
BETTER SUPPORT AND PROTECT THE
CHILDREN IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT IS ONE THING TO SIMPLY
IDENTIFY TRAUMA WE HAVE MUCH
MORE WORK TO DO TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE EXPOSED TO TRAUMA HAVE
THEIR NEEDS ADDRESSED AND
PREVENT FUTURE HARM.
THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
NO I JUST WANTED TO BUY GOODS
AND TO MENTION THREE FORTY AND
OUR OFFICE WAS THE AUTHOR OF IT --
HOW APPRECIATIVE I AM ROOF AND
HOW IMPORTANT THE WORK IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL IS
EFFECTIVE AT THE?
GRASSROOTS LEVEL.
I WANTED TO IF I COULD HIGHLIGHT
THE MULTI GENERATIONAL MODEL
THAT YOU WERE SPEAKING TO WENT
AND HIGHLIGHT WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION DID DO WELL.
IN INVESTING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TEN OF
FUNDS TO GO AND HELP WITH --
HOME VISITING FOR OUR CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS FROM ZERO TO TWO AS
WE START LOOKING TO HOW WE CAN
MAKE THOSE MULTI GENERATIONAL
CHANGE IT IS IT HAS TO START
WITH OUR YOUNGEST.
AND THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE AND LOOK TOWARDS THIS
PROGRAM IS A WONDERFUL EXAMPLE.
BUT WILL WANTS TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THE VIEW YOU IF I CAN ON THE
POSITIVE PARENTING PROGRAM.
HOW IS THAT SCALABLE ARE THERE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHER COUNTIES
TO LEARN FROM IT ARE THERE?
OTHER CHANCES FOR PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT TO BE BENEFICIAL AND AGAIN
I'M JUST GONNA SAY.
IT'S NOT EASY BEING A PARENT AND
WE HAVE TO GIVE PEOPLE AS MANY
TOOLS AS WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
I ACTUALLY I'M GOING TO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU AND ALSO KIM.
BOTH ON THE TOPIC OF OTHER
THINGS WE CAN DO TO STRENGTHEN
WHAT HAPPENS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
A WE HEARD ABOUT THE ALL THE
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS AT
WORK.
SOCIAL EVENTS IN YOUR VIEW --
CAM ON ARE THE THINGS YOU CAN DO
IMPROVE HOW THE SYSTEM FOR THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
AND FOR YOU DIANA I AWAY FROM
THE STATE'S STANDPOINT WE CAN BE.
SUPPORTING THE WORK YOU'RE
DELIVERING AS FOR THE GRASSROOTS
LEVEL.
BY SUPPORTING EDUCATION OF YOUR
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CITY
OFFICIALS --
COUNTY MANAGERS CITY MANAGERS.
IS THERE ANY ROLE.
THAT THE STATE CAN SUPPORTS OF
THE LOCAL LEADERSHIP.
IN UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE ENCOUNTERING AND HOW
RESOURCE CAN BE BROUGHT TO BEAR
SO WHAT'S.
YOUR ON THE FRONT LINES
DELIVERING THINGS BUT YOU'RE IN
A COUNTY BUDGET STRUCTURE.
AND IS THERE A WAY IN WHICH THE
STATE COULD BE ASSISTING WITH
[inaudible]
EDUCATION.
PROMOTED IN PRIORITIES --
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR MORE
SYNERGIES WITH THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY APPROACH DESCRIBE
THAT SORT OF THING.
SO IT IS SORT OF GENERALIZED
THOUGHTS ON THAT SO NOT
NECESSARILY STRICTLY SHASTA
COUNTY YOU ALREADY.
TALKED ABOUT VENTURE ANOTHER
SHIFT YOUR PERSPECTIVE
[inaudible]
YOU WANT.
OKAY.
SO -- YEAH
THERE'S JUST THERE'S ALWAYS
THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH MONEY.
AND WE KNOW THAT --
PROBABLY THE THE I THINK OF TO
CHALLENGES ONE OF THEM IS THAT
WE RELY HEAVILY ON MEDICAID
FUNDING.
AND WITH REALIGNMENT IS WHAT WE
USE THEM USE FOR A MATCH FOR THE
50% OF THE F. P..
AND OF COURSE EVERYTHING COMES
IN ARREARS THE ENTIRE MEDICAID
SYSTEM FOR COUNTIES IS THAT YOU
PROVIDE THIS SERVICE.
YOU PAY THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
PROVIDED THE SERVICE THAT IS AS
AS A CLINICIAN OR A THE AGENCY
THAT THEY WORK FOR WHETHER IT'S
THE COUNTY OR THE PRIVATE AGENCY --
GETS PAID THE PRIVATE AGENCY IS
PAID AND THEY SUBMIT A CLAIM THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
SUBMITS A CLAIM.
AND AND THEN WE'RE PAID IT'S
ALWAYS REIMBURSEMENT.
THERE'S A PACE THERE'S TIME LAG.
AND SO MOST COUNTY DEPARTMENTS --
THERE OPERATE THEIR SERVICES IN
ARREARS --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDS
COME AFTER THE FACT AND THAT'S
RUNS ABOUT A TWO YEAR.
AFTER THE FACT SO WHEN THE
RECESSION HIT BACK BEING A
DIRECTOR IN YOLO COUNTY.
YOU KNOW THINGS WERE LOOKING
OKAY IN AT IN THE MOMENT WHEN
THE RECESSION HIT BECAUSE WE
WERE STILL.
UP YOU KNOW TWO YEARS BEHIND
THAT BUT BOY WHEN THE UPSWING
CAME WE WERE IN THE PIT.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY TOUGH AND
SO MOST OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OPERATE IN ARREARS.
BUT NEW IDEAS COME FORWARD AND
NEW IMPLEMENTATION SEIZE HERE IS
A GREAT EXAMPLE OF A OF A GOOD
IDEA.
AND REALLY BUILT ON THE
INTENTION AND PLANNED GOAL OF
MEDI CAL SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED TO OUR
FOSTER YOUTH.
THAT COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH SHOULD
INCREASE THE SERVICES WHICH WILL
OCCUR AND YOU HAVE TO PAY YOUR
STAFF FIRST AND YOU HAVE TO PAY
YOUR CONTRACTOR PROVIDERS FIRST
AND THEN YOU CAN SUBMIT CLAIMS
TO BE READ AND BURST.
SO THAT'S A CHALLENGE JUST AN
OVERALL GENERAL AND THAT'S THE
THERE WERE A BUT THE FUNDING IS
STILL LAGGING THE SPENDING AT
THE LAGGED AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY BECAUSE THERE'S A
TIME.
I MEAN THERE'S A TIME LAG BY
DESIGN OF THE SYSTEM.
NOT NECESSARILY THERE SOMETIMES
TIME LIKES WITH DH CS BUT MORE
THAN THAT IT'S A SYSTEM DESIGNED
BY TWO YEARS.
WELL TWO YEARS IS THE MHSAA TIME
LAG PLAN AND THAT'S BECAUSE
PEOPLE FILE TAXES AFTER THE
YEARS OVER.
AND THEN AFTER THE YEARS OVER
PEOPLE DO FILE GET EXTENSIONS.
AND SO YOU KNOW THERE'S JUST
THERE'S A TIME LAG THE AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET INTO THE WE'VE
DONE THIS ONE BY IT WE HAD A
VERY --
COLORFUL MEETING.
ABOUT PROP SIXTY THREE FUNDING
AND I BELIEVE ALL YOU ALL WERE
IN IN THAT MEETING AND SOUL.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
DO IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE THERE IS
BACK MONEY LAYING AROUND THAT
HASN'T BEEN REVERTED BACK TO
WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED TO SO.
WHAT I'M GETTING AT IS?
THERE IS MONEY THERE YEAH WHAT
CAN WE DO TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MONEY GETS.
TO THE PROVIDER RIGHT MEDIA
RIGHT AND SO I WOULD NEED TO GO
BACK TO THE ASSOCIATION BECAUSE
MY FORMAL ASSIGNMENT IS NOT THE
FISCAL PIECE.
AT SO WELL I KNOW MUCH OF IT I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
OUR FISCAL.
FOLKS -- BUT
WE CAN OUT WITH ABSOLUTELY LIKE
TO HAVE A MEETING TO DISCUSS
THAT BECAUSE THERE IS AN ISSUE
WITH TIME LAG.
AND THEN THE OTHER COMPONENT IS
I'M NOT SURE THAT THE DESIGN C.
C. R. WAS DESIGNED TO BE COST
NEUTRAL BUT IT'S AN INCREASE IN
SERVICES.
AND SO THERE'S SOME ISSUES OF
PROP THIRTY PARTICULARLY WITH
CANS AND SOME OF THE OTHER
SERVICES THAT.
WE WILL BE REIMBURSED BUT
THERE'S FORMULAS THEIR SET UP
AND PROJECTED BUT THEY'RE DONE
YEAR YOU KNOW BEFORE HAND AND
NOW WE'RE IN IT.
AND SO IT'S OF THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS SO WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
IT CB HD WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION WITH YOU ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU WELL AND THEN JUST TO
YES.
KIND OF OF ALONG THE SAME LINES --
I UNIT I KNOW YOU TALKED ABOUT --
TYPICALLY PROP SIXTY THREE MONEY
BUT A YOU ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS.
AND IF YOU'VE BEEN IN THE
MEETINGS THAT WE WERE AND THAT
WAS THE MAJOR PART OF MY
FRUSTRATION BECAUSE EVEN HAVING
THEM SITTING IN FRONT OF US THEY
SAID THERE WAS A DISCONNECT
RIGHT IN FRONT OF US.
AND SO --
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S GOING TO BE A
NEW ADMINISTRATION BITE. TO PRE
EMPT THAT.
IS THERE A WAY THAT YOU CAN GIVE
SOME SUGGESTIONS AND POP
POSSIBLY HAVE MEETINGS WITH --
DOCTOR RANDALL I SIT AND SOMEONE
AS WELL AND MISTER COOLEY JUST
KIND OF OFF LINE --
TO CAN HELP AT LEAST FOR ME I'M
ASKING FOR MYSELF I KNOW --
DOCTOR RAMBLE AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED THIS MANY TIMES BUT
WHAT.
CAN WE DO TO PREEMPT THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT WHAT HOW WE
CAN FIX IT AND I'M NOT.
UNREALISTIC IT'S STILL
GOVERNMENT IT'S NOT GONNA BE
FIXED OVER NIGHT BUT IF YOU CAN
GIVE US SOME SUGGESTIONS AS TO
HOW WE CAN MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS BETTER I KNOW YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE SYSTEMS BEING.
COMPATIBLE --
HAVING ONE SYSTEM BUILDER IN MY
OPINION PRETTY EASY FIX SAYS.
BEING THAT --
IF THE WILL IS THERE THINGS THAT
YOU SEE ARE NOT AS EASY THAT IS
GOING TO TAKE US THAT ARE GOING
TO TAKE US A COUPLE YEARS.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN BECAUSE WE CAN GET
GRABBED THE ADMINISTRATION THE
BEGINNING.
AT ME MAYBE I'M IN FANTASY TO OF
WORLD BY TO GRAB THEM IN THE
BEGINNING AND AT LEAST TELL THEM
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
WHETHER IT BE THE FOLLOWING YEAR
OR TWO YEARS OR I MEAN.
LET AT SOME POINT THIS IS WHAT
WE NEED AND SO WE CAN START
TALKING TO THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION.
I ABOUT THE SUGGESTION SO MORE
HOMEWORK IF YOU CAN MEET WITH US.
NUMBER ONE BUT NUMBER TWO IF YOU
CAN.
PUT DOWN ON PAPER WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT YOU SEE THAT CAN BE
FIXED THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
REQUIRE MONEY THE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENTS COSTS
NOTHING.
SO THAT MONEY IS NOT AN EXCUSE
SO THOSE THINGS THAT.
DO NOT COST ANYTHING THAT ARE.
PRETTY SIMPLE LIKE THE FORMS FOR
EXAMPLE THE FORMULAS YOU SAID
SOMETHING ABOUT THE FORMS IN THE
FORMULAS IF WE CAN FIX THOSE
FORMS THAT BECAUSE CUT DOESN'T
COST ANY MONEY.
IT'S ABOUT STREAMLINING AND
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
DEPARTMENTS COMMUNICATE WITH
THEMSELVES SO.
THAT'S THE HOMEWORK --
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT THE TIME
FOR IT BUT THAT'S MY ASK OF YOU
AND I AM AVAILABLE --
YOU KNOW I BASICALLY AT ANY TIME
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AND
I'LL HAVE MY MY FOLKS REACH OUT
TO YOU AS WELL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS OR FOLLOW UP
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SO.
MY ONLY EXPERIENCE IS IT WITHIN
SHASTA COUNTY AND SO WALL I HAVE
A HAVE A GREAT --
CHAU -- AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL WHO'S VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF FOSTER YOUTH IN
THE WORK THAT WE DO WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT --
IN THERE ARE A COUPLE OF BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND THAT ARE VERY
INVESTED IN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES --
TO CHILDREN --
AND SPECIFICALLY.
SO I I FEEL SUPPORTED THEIR WHAT
HAPPENS THOUGH IS THAT IF WE ARE
NOT GIVEN SPECIFIC MONEY FOR THE
INITIATIVES THAT COME DOWN OR
THE EXPECTATION THE WORK THAT'S
DONE -- ALL
OUR GENERAL FRIENDS REALLY GOES
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OF AND SO THAT'S THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE RUN INTO AND SO WE OFTEN
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION ARE WE
GOING TO AB IT'S IT'S HONESTLY
MY CEOS --
LITTLE METAPHORS THAT HE GIVES
ABOUT PREVENTION YOU KNOW WE
COULD EITHER STANDARD A CLIFF
AND LOOK AT THE CAR THAT JUST
WENT OVER THE EDGE AND CRASH AND
HAVE TO GO DOWN WITH THE
AMBULANCE.
OR WE CAN BEGIN TO PUT UP A
FENCE THAT'S GOING TO KEEP THAT
CAR FROM GOING OVER AND SO IF WE
DON'T START DOING SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES AT THE
CHILDREN'S LEVEL --
THEN WE ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE
ANY DIFFERENCE IN THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING AND SO I DO FEEL
SUPPORTED BUT AGAIN FUNDING HAS
TO COME SPECIFICALLY TO OUR
PROGRAMS.
IN ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
USE IT BECAUSE OTHERWISE CHEN
OFFENSE REALLY DOES GO TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT RIGHT AND ALSO JUST --
WE TALKED ABOUT PROP SIXTY THREE
MONEY I AND AND I KNOW THAT THAT
YOU GAVE US THE INFORMATION BUT
THERE WAS NO SPECIFICS AS TO WHY
WHAT.
PROP SIXTY THREE MONEY SHOULD BE
USED FOR AND IF WE DON'T GIVE UP
THE COUNTIES SPECIFIC DIRECTIONS
ARE GOING TO USE THAT.
FOR WHATEVER IT IS THAT.
CAN I MAKE THIS THING AT THE
TIME CAN I JUST ADD JUST HAVING
BEEN AT THE COUNTY FOR SO MANY
YEARS.
THE OTHER PIECE THAT HAPPENS IS
WHEN SERVICES ARE SUCCESSFULLY
PROVIDED.
AND CHILDREN IN YOU ADULTS AS
WELL.
ARE SERVED AND THERE'S A CHANGE.
THE COST AVOIDANCE AND COST
SAVINGS RARELY IF AT ALL GET
FILTERED BACK TO THE PROGRAM
THAT WAS SUCCESSFUL IN MAKING
THAT CHANGE.
AND SO THEN IT'S BECAUSE IF WE
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
IN JUVENILE HALL.
IF WE DECREASE HOSPITAL BED DAYS
IF WE'D DECREASE THE NUMBER OF
CALLS TO THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE THERE'S LESS BREAK INS.
THOSE DOLLARS DON'T TURN AROUND
TO THE PROGRAM THAT SUCCESSFULLY
PROVIDED THOSE SERVICES PROVIDED
TBS BY A COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDER WHO THE CHILD NO LONGER
BREAKS INTO A STORE ANYMORE.
THOSE DON'T COME BACK AND SO.
IF WE COULD FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
ADDRESS THAT AND KEEP THAT GOING
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM THAT WOULD
BE AMAZING.
LIKE IT'S HAPPENING TO US TWO OF
MY MY BY IT BUDGET YEAR IS
ENDING AND I DIDN'T USE ALL OF
MY FUNDS AND GUESS WHAT HAPPENS
I GET TO LOSE THEM.
AND SO A LOT OF PEOPLE AND I
KNOW I WAS A TEACHER AS WELL AND
WHEN WHEN WE DON'T USE THEM IT
WAS A USING MY NEWSHAM.
WE'RE ALL BUSY TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO SPEND THE MONEY
INSTEAD OF SAVING IT FOR A RAINY
DAY AND AND KEEPING IT FOR FOR
OTHER SERVICES THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED SO.
I THINK WE'RE ALL IN THE SAME
SITUATION AND I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF A GOVERNMENTAL MENTALITY
THAT HOPEFULLY WE CAN BREAK
THERE AND AND TRY.
TO WE CAPTURED ALSO THAT YOU CAN
INCREASE YOUR PROGRAMS OR
EXPANDING WITH AND YOU KNOW THE
THE COMMUNITY THAT YOU START OF
SELF.
THANK YOU.
K. ANY OTHER.
YOU KNOW WE'VE TAKEN ON VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH --
SO WE HAVE DEBORAH DEBORAH AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY.
I WAS ASKED TO EXPLAIN TO YOU
THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY --
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE'RE
STILL WORKING THROUGH OUR
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT INDICATING
A LAWSUIT --
SO IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AS
STRATEGIC PLAN WAS INITIATED
WHICH CODIFY THE CRITERIA FAR
EXIT FROM THAT LAWSUIT.
SAID THESE CONDITIONS SPECIFIED
SEVERAL THINGS SYSTEMATIC
SCREENING AND ASSESSMENT OF ALL
YOUTH.
DEVELOPMENT OF A COLLABORATIVE
MODEL BETWEEN DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH KNOWN AS A
COORDINATED SERVICES ACTION TEAM
OR SEE SAT.
IMPLEMENTATION OF A SHARED COR
PRACTICE MODEL AND EXIT CRITERIA
WHICH INCLUDE PASSING SCORES ON
A QUALITATIVE SERVICE REVIEW.
US RUN NOT QUITE THERE YET BUT
WE'RE WORKING ON IT.
THE FRONT END IN TAKEN LINKAGE
SYSTEM HAVE BEEN FORMALIZED FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS.
AND BOTH AGENCIES HAVE DEDICATED
STAFF TO COORDINATE AND SUPPORT
THE PROCESS.
THAT SO THE WAY IT WORKS IS --
IN OUR SYSTEM THAT --
THE CASE CARING SOCIAL WORKER
COMPLETES A MENTAL HEALTH
SCREENING TOOL FOR EVERY CHILD
WHO'S REFERRAL IS PROMOTED TO A
CASE -- THE
MENTAL HEALTH SCREENING TOOL IS --
BEHAVIORAL CHECKLIST DESIGNED
FOR NON MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SO QUESTIONS
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE.
IT DOES THE CHILD APPEAR TO BE
DISCONNECTED ÍEXCESSIVELY
PASSIVE AS WELL AS HAS A CHILD
EXPERIENCED OR WITNESSED
PHYSICAL AND OR SEXUAL ABUSE OR
SEVERE NEGLECTED TO BEHAVIORAL
CHECKLIST.
SO IT MOST MENTAL HEALTH
SCREENINGS ARE POSITIVE.
DUE TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
BROUGHT THAT CHILD TO OUR
ATTENTION AND ANY NEGATIVE
SCREENS ALTHOUGH THERE RARE ARE
DOCUMENTED AND REQUIRE AN ANNUAL
REASSESSMENT.
IS SO THE MEANT THE MENTAL
HEALTH SCREENING TOOL WITH
SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION IS
ELECTRONICALLY FORWARDED TO OUR
COLOCATED MENTAL HEALTH STAFF --
LOCATED EACH REGIONAL OFFICE SO
THERE ARE ONE HUNDRED SUCH STAFF --
WHO SERVE THAT FUNCTION IN LOS
ANGELES?
COLOCATED MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH
STAFF REVIEW EACH SCREENING TOOL.
AND THEY MAKE A DETERMINATION OF
ACUITY.
AYE CHILDREN WHOSE NEEDS ARE
DEEMED A CUTE OR URGENT ARE
IMMEDIATELY LINKED TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND NEWLY DETAIN CHILDREN WHOSE
NEEDS ARE DEEMED A ROUTINE ARE
REFERRED FOR A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY ASSESSMENT TEAM ARM
MATT ASSESSMENT WITHIN TEN DAYS
OF REFERRAL.
I'M SO AND NINETY TEEN CHILDREN
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR MAD
ASSESSMENT AND FEAR REFER TO CO
LOCATED STAFFER ASSESSMENT AND
THEN LINKAGES WELL.
AS SO THE MAD ASSESSMENT I THINK
IS IS UNIQUE TO THE COUNTY AND
IT ADDRESSES MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL.
AND DEVELOPMENTAL ISSUES AS A
WHILE AS CHILD AND FAMILY
STRENGTHS IN NEEDS --
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE HAVE
FORTY EIGHT MATT AGENCIES AND
THEY COMPLETE AROUND SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED MATT ASSESSMENTS PER
YEAR --
ABOUT FOURTEEN MILLION MEDI CAL
DOLLARS ARE ALLOCATED TO THIS
PROGRAM AS WELL DCFS PAYS THREE
AND A HALF MILLION FOR THEIR
SUMMARY OF FINDINGS REPORT --
AND THE MATTER SAYS ARE BY THE
WAY MAY REFER THE CHILD FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES --
AT ANY TIME DURING THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS WHICH TAKES --
THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE DAYS --
TRADITIONALLY THE SUMMARY OF
FINDINGS RESULTS WERE PRESENTED
AT KIND OF A STANDALONE MEETING --
WE BEGAN TO NOTICE POOR
ATTENDANCE AT THOSE MEETINGS AND
POOR INTEGRATION OF MATT
FINDINGS INTO CASE PLANNING.
SO WE INITIATED A MAT CF TO
PILOT IN FOUR REGIONAL OFFICES --
IN IN THE PILOT THE ASSIGNED
MATT ASSESSOR ATTENDS CHILD AND
EXCUSE ME IS IT TENDS FAMILY AND
STAFF ENGAGEMENT ACTIVITIES.
AND THEN THEY PARTICIPATE IN THE
FIRST CHILD --
AND THERE THEY SHARE AND
TRANSLATE THEIR FINDINGS FOR THE
FAMILY AND THE TEAM --
SO WE ADJUSTED THE CHARTING
STRATEGIES A BIT FOR CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAM MEETINGS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MATT FINDINGS
REINCORPORATED.
INTO THE SEA IF THE ACTION PLAN
BECAUSE THE CFT ACTION PLAN IS
CARRIED FORWARD WITH THE CHILD
THROUGHOUT THE LIFE OF THE CASE --
AND SO THIS IS REALLY IMPROVE
THE FAMILY SENSE OF AGENCY --
IN REGARDS TO THE MAT ASSESSMENT
FINDINGS AT HAS HELPED WE FOUND
INFORM THE DEVELOPMENT OF MORE
USEFUL AND RELEVANT CASE PLANS.
SO WE'VE COMPLETED MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED MATT ASSESSMENTS
IN THIS WAY --
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TO BE
EXACT --
WITH THIS NEW PROTOCOL AND WE
WE'VE RECEIVED VERY POSITIVE
FEEDBACK FROM CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES SO NOW WE'RE PREPARING
FOR ROLLOUT INTO ADDITIONAL
OFFICES.
THE KIND OF ON A GRANULAR LEVEL
OR DOING LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE CHALLENGES --
THAT WE HAVE IN LA --
IT IS THE SIZE JUST THE SHEER
SIZE OF THE OPERATION.
ARM RIGHT NOW --
WE HAVE EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN CARE --
OVERSEEN BY FORTY TWO HUNDRED
SOCIAL WORKERS ACROSS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL OFFICES.
IS AN ENORMOUS OPERATION IT'S
IT'S NOT EASY TO GET EVERYONE
ALIGNED IN THE SAME DIRECTION
ALL THE TIME THAT'S ONE OF OUR
CHALLENGES.
THAT'S AN UNDERSTATEMENT THANK
YOU -- AND
SO I THINK.
A BIGGER CHALLENGE --
AT RELATED TO IT CAT TO RENO WAS
SAYING TO IS ALTHOUGH THE FRONT
END WORKS EFFICIENTLY IN THE WAY
THAT I'VE DESCRIBED --
I DO THINK WE EXPERIENCE GAPS
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT INITIAL
SCREENING ASSESSMENT AND LINKAGE --
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I WE
FIND IS THAT THERE'S REALLY NO
CENTRAL DE MH DATA SYSTEM.
THAT LONGITUDINALLY TRACKS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE LINKAGE --
SO WE DON'T HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF ANY INDIVIDUAL
CHILD'S TRAJECTORY IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
AND BECAUSE WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT TRAJECTORY WE REALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP
GOOD STRATEGIES. TO ENSURE
CONTINUITY OF TREATMENT WHEN A
CHILD IS REPLACED OR TO EVEN PRO
ACTIVELY RESPOND --
TO ANY ESCALATED MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS IN AN EFFORT TO AVOID
REPLACEMENT THAT'S OUR GOAL --
SO.
IN CONCLUSION I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT WE CARE ABOUT THESE
CHILDREN VERY MUCH.
AND ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
PARTNERS AND COLLEAGUES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH TO
MAKE SURE THEY GET WHAT THEY
NEED.
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS QUESTION.
AND IS IN THE WAKE OF THE KD OF
LITIGATION.
IT IS THAT'S FAR OF A IMPETUS TO
THAT'S FOR A LONGITUDINAL
TRACKING SYSTEM.
I MEAN OF JUST. EIGHT K?T A
REQUIRED AS TO YOU KNOW TO
ENSURE ADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THESE CHILDREN AND
I THINK THAT WE ARE ARE FOCUSED
A LOT ON SOME TECHNICAL ASPECTS
OF IT AS WELL AS IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CORE PRACTICE MODEL BUT
NO THE LONGITUDINAL TRACKING.
IS SOMETHING NOW THAT WE'RE
SEEING STEP YEAH AND I DO WANT
TO SAY WHEN I SAID IT'S HARD. TO
GET EVERYONE A LINE.
I'VE MADE IT SOUND LIKE A JOKE
BUT ACTUALLY I JUST THOUGHT IT
WAS VERY PRACTICAL OBSERVATION.
THAT IN ALL ITS WANTING TO MOVE
A SINGLE BATTLE SHIP IT'S
ANOTHER THING TO MOVE A WHOLE
FLEET -- SO
I JUST.
I FELT YOU WERE JUST BEING VERY
PRACTICAL SAYING.
NEXT TIME YEAH AND I DIDN'T MEAN.
TO IN ANY WAY IMPLY THAT THAT
WAS OUT OF THE ORDINARY ACTUALLY
THANK YOU THINGS TAKE TIME YEAH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
CAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SO
NEXT WE HAVE LARA HINES.
HI A GOOD AFTERNOON I'M IN A
KIND OF A JUSTICE [inaudible]
RIGHT CELL.
BUT NINE FIVE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING MADE --
THIS IS VERY EXCITING TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE OF
FIRST HAND INFORMATION TO YOU --
I WOULD LOVE TO ACTUALLY DO THE
SAME THING WITH OUR POOR
SUPERVISORS AT A LOCAL LEVEL.
BECAUSE THIS IS VERY COMPLICATED
WORK -- AND
PROBABLY MORE NOT IN AT EVERY
DAY SELL --
I AM A DOCTOR LARA HEIGHT CEO OF
STAMFORD YOU SOLUTIONS WE ARE
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
FOUNDED RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
ON EIGHT THE MAN AT THE STANFORD
MANSION AT STANFORD HOME FOR
CHILDREN IN NINETEEN HUNDRED AS
AN ORPHANAGE.
WE HAVE EVOLVED SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER TIME --
WE NO LONGER HAVE ANY CONCRETE
CARE SO OUR COMMITMENT IS TO
SERVE THE YOUTH --
IN THEIR HOMES OR IN FAMILY.
WITH US SUPPORT OF OUR STAFF SO
WE PROVIDE OF ROCK OF VARIETY OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
THAT -- WERE
REFERENCED EARLIER --
ONE IS WRAPPED AROUND A
WRAPAROUND A TRADITIONALLY WE'VE
UTILIZED IT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AS A SERVICE TO BASICALLY MOVE
CHILDREN FROM GROUP HOMES INTO
BACK INTO COMMUNITY.
MANY OF OUR WRAPAROUND CHILDREN
OUR INTENTION IS FOR THEM TO
RETURN TO SOME SORT OF FAMILY --
CAN SOMETIMES BIRTH FAMILY --
IF WE CAN'T DO THAT WE ALSO
SUPPORT THEM IN FOSTER CARE
FOSTER HOMES.
BUT WITH ALL OF OUR YOUTH OUR
PRIMARY FOCUS IS PERMANENCY.
SO THAT'S BEFORE C. C. R. EXIST
OUR COMMITMENT.
OF WE KNOW THAT ALL OF US --
GROW BEST AND FAMILY AND
EVERYONE EVERY HUMAN BEING NEEDS
A SENSE OF BELONGING CAM AND
CONNECTION SO THAT'S OUR FOCUS
ON WE HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE TO
ALSO BE ABLE TO DO PREVENTION
WRAPAROUND.
WHICH IS --
WHEN A CHILD IS IDENTIFIED AS?
IN AT RISK OF ENTERING --
AND WE'RE USING --
ACTUALLY TILED TITLE FORTY
DOLLARS AND IT IS PRIMARILY OUR
PROBATION USES SO THEY'RE OFTEN
ARE PLACED ON A STATE MANY
PEOPLE AREN'T AWARE OF THAT BUT
MANY PROBATION YOUTH.
FROM THIS AREA ARE PRE PLACE OUT
OF STATE INST INSTEAD OF DOING
NOT -- THERE --
WORKING WITH THE FAMILY SYSTEM
WE HAVE REALLY HIGH SUCCESS
RATES WITH THOSE ON THOSE AT
THAT POPULATION BECAUSE IT'S
EARLIER.
IN -- IN
KIND OF THE TRAUMA.
OCCURRENCE SIR THOMAS CYCLE --
THAT IS IT'S ABOUT THREE TO FOUR
MONTHS --
AND OVER 90% OF OUR CHILDREN ARE
ABLE TO STABILIZE IN PREVENTION
OR APPLE ROUND WE ARE AT RISK OF
LOSING THOSE FUNDS WITH THE
FORTY WAIVER.
CHANGES SO OF WE ALSO HAVE
FLEXIBLE INTEGRATED TREATMENT
WHICH IS.
TYPICALLY OUTPATIENT SERVICES
THOSE ARE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN THE COMMUNITY WE DO FAMILY
INDIVIDUAL GROUP SERVICES --
MOST OF OUR YOUTH ARE REFERRED --
WHO HAVE BEEN IN AND OUT OF
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALIZATION AND
ARE AT RISK OF HIGHER LEVEL OF
KERR -- SO
THAT'S ANOTHER PROGRAM WE ALSO
DO TVS THERAPEUTIC BEHAVIORAL
SERVICES THOSE SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED UP WHERE THE CHILD HAS
HIGH RISK OF BASICALLY LOSING
THEIR PLACEMENT SO IT MAY BE IN
SCHOOL.
SO THEY MAY BE AT RISK OF
GETTING KICKED OUT OF THE SCHOOL
WILL DO TARGETED --
VERY TARGETED ON THE BEHAVIOR
THAT PUTS THEM AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR PLACEMENT IT MAY BE IN A
HOME.
IT IT COULD BE IN A GROUP HOME
SO THERAPEUTIC BEHAVIORAL SUCH
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED WHEREVER
THAT CHILD IS AT RISK OF LOSING
PLACEMENT.
THAT IS ALSO VERY SHORT TERM
ABOUT THREE MONTHS --
ACTUALLY ON AVERAGE OURS IS
SEVENTY DAYS OF SERVICE AND WE
HAVE 92% PLACEMENT STABLE AT THE
STABILITY AND THAT --
PROGRAM DELIVERY MODEL WE ALSO
DO FUNCTIONAL FAMILY THERAPY --
THAT IS SPECIFIC TO OUR JUVENILE
JUSTICE POPULATION OR PROBATION
YOUTH AND WHAT THAT REQUIRES
WORK WITH THE WHOLE FAMILY
SYSTEM.
AND THOSE YOUTH --
OUR PHONE BASICALLY WE WE CAN'T
START FUNCTIONAL FAMILY THERAPY
UNTIL THEY'RE IN A FAMILY HOME
AND WE WORK THE WHOLE FAMILY
THAT LIVES IN THE HOME.
PARTICIPATES IN A FUNCTIONAL
FAMILY THERAPY AND IT LASTS
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN WEEKS AND
IT'S EVIDENCE BASED.
ON WE ALSO PROVIDE SCHOOL
SERVICES --
WE DO A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WE DO SOME TELEPHONE BE FOR
YOUTH THAT ARE IN A
NONTRADITIONAL EDUCATIONAL.
SETTINGS ON AND EMBEDDED IN ALL
OF THE WORK WE DO IS FAMILY AND
YOUTH PARTNERSHIP.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A DEPARTMENT
FOCUSED ON NOT --
BECAUSE WE KNOW --
THE FAMILY AND YOUTH VOICE IS
CRITICAL TO THE WORK WE DO.
AND TO THE SUCCESS THE ONGOING
SUCCESS AFTER THE YOUNG PEOPLE
AND THE FAMILY IS BASICALLY STOP
SERVICES WITH US SO WE WANT TO
REALLY IN BAD THE SKILLS THEY
LEARNED THROUGH OUR THROUGH OUR
SERVICES.
AND THEY CONTINUED TO DO THE
WORK AFTER US AND THEY ALSO
ADVOCATE SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE
HAVE IS AN EMPOWERMENT TRAIN
CENTER.
IT'S ACTUALLY FUNDED THROUGH US
PAD -- THAT
WE TRAINED FAMILY ADVOCATES FOR
PERRIN ADVOCATES AND YOUTH
ADVOCATES TO DO THE WORK NOT
JUST IN OUR PROGRAMS BUT ACROSS
THE REGION.
I THE OTHER THING WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED BECAUSE STAFF
RETENTION HAS BEEN A REAL
CHALLENGE FOR US --
CgA QUALIFIED STAFF AND STAFF
THAT EVEN WANT TO DO THE HARD
WORK OF GOING INTO FAMILIES
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN NG CALL
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE AN ON CALL
COMPONENT TO THE WORK WE DO.
ON THOSE FOR PATHWAYS ON AND
THAT'S ALSO FUNDED THROUGH OFSHE
HAD WERE WERE IDENTIFYING --
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN THE WORK AND WE
TRAIN THEM AND THEY GET THEIR
INTERNSHIP HOURS AND EXPERIENCE --
AT OUR PROGRAM AND HOPEFULLY
THEY STAY WITH US HUH OR OR
THERE IS SOME STAY WITH US AND
SOME DECIDE YOU KNOW BUT MAYBE
IT ISN'T THE RIGHT FIT FOR THEM.
BUT ULTIMATELY THEY WILL HAVE
GROWN THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
MOST HAVE ACTUALLY WANTED TO
STAY IN THE FIELD SO THAT'S
REALLY POSITIVE --
BUT THAT'S VERY NEW THAT'S OUR
SECOND YEAR OF DOING THE CAREER
PATHWAYS --
WE ALSO DO SOMETHING CALLED --
I'M SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH IT
BECAUSE OF CCAR --
I SSE INTENSIVE SERVICES --
IF IT WAS AYE TSC SO IT'S REALLY
HARD FOR ME TO CHANGE MY
LANGUAGE WE DID IT OF SEE FOR
MANY YEARS --
SO IT'S INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE --
AND WE ALSO DO STANDARD
TREATMENT FOSTER CARE AND THOSE
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER YOUTH
ARE TYPICALLY THOSE THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD BE AND
CONGREGATE CARE THEY HAVE HAD
MULTIPLE PLACEMENTS --
REALLY STRUGGLED ON IN IN ANY
PLACE THAT THEY'VE BEEN EN AND
WE IDENTIFY --
PARENTS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE --
SO IT'S IT'S OFTEN SAID SPECIAL
ED TEACHER OR A ON SOMEBODY
THAT'S BEEN IN THE FIELD --
A LOT OF DIFFERENT FOLKS THAT --
NURSES ACTUALLY MAKE GREAT --
ANY MEDICAL PROVIDER OF A ON
TEACHERS MAKE GREAT AT AYE SFC
PARENTS --
WE ARE STRUGGLING OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGES RECRUITING THIS THIS
ON POPULATION.
A LOT OF IT IS VERY HARD ON THE
BEST WAY TO RECRUIT IS WORD OF
MOUTH FROM OTHER FAMILIES --
AND WITH SOME OF THE CHANGES
WITH C. C. R. WE'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN A REDUCTION OF PEOPLE EAGER
TO JUMP ON BOARD SO THAT HAS
BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR US --
THERE ARE ALSO --
ONE OF OUR AREAS OF IDENTIFYING
CAN AND SUPPORTING CAN IT'S A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY WITH C. C. R.
BUT WE ARE JUST AT THE BABY
STAGES OF REALLY PROVIDING THE
SAME LEVEL I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
SYSTEM.
SAME LEVEL OF SUPPORT TO THE CAN
FAMILIES IDENTIFYING THEM
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE TREATED
ON WITH THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED TO SUPPORT.
THOSE PHOSTRIA IF.
I'M I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CHILD FAMILY TEAMING
JUST BRIEFLY IT IS IN ALL OF OUR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS IT'S
BEEN EMBEDDED IN OUR PROGRAMS.
SINCE WE STARTED WRAPAROUND MANY
YEARS AGO --
WITH IT REQUIRES PROPER
FACILITATION AND THE ASSURANCE
THAT THAT YOUTH VOICE AND THE
PARENT VOICE ARE AT THE TABLE.
WE ACTUALLY REQUIRE THAT THERE'S
A YOU HAD THE PRESIDENT
PROFESSIONALS CAN INTIMIDATE
BOTH THE THE PICK THE PARENT AND
THE YOUNG PERSON.
AND WE WANT SOMEONE THAT'S
BASICALLY SUPPORTING THEM IN
THEIR VOICE IN THE WORK WHAT
DECISIONS ARE MADE IN THE C. F.
T. ARE TO BE HONORED AND THAT'S
AN EXPECTATION THE FEAR IS.
THAT THOSE DECISIONS ARE AND
DONE AFTER OUTSIDE OF THE C. F.
T..
WE ALSO --
HAD A UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
LEVEL OF CARE COULD BE ON
BASICALLY REVIEWED LEVEL OF CARE
PLACEMENT FOR A FOSTER YOUTH.
IN THE C. F. T. AND NOT IS A
CONCERN THAT THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY HAPPENING THAT WAY
AND PARENTS AND ESPECIALLY THE
PARENTS ARE LEFT OUT OF THAT
DISCUSSION --
SO WE ARE IN THE BABY STEPS OF
THAT BUT THAT'S ALSO A CONCERN
AND THEN --
AYE ALREADY TOUCHED ON ON THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
FOSTER PARENTS ONE THING THAT WE
ARE DOING --
IS IDENTIFYING MENTOR PARENTS.
THAT SUPPORT OTHER --
FOSTER PARENTS IN THE WORK WE DO
OBVIOUSLY WE TRAIN AMEND TRAUMA
INFORMED WORK AND PRESENTING
PROBLEMS THAT THE YOUTH HAVE AND
THAT THAT BEHAVIORS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY.
BECAUSE OF THE ANYTHING PERSONAL
BETWEEN THE FOSTER PARENT AND
THE FOSTER YOUTH BUT BECAUSE OF
A REACTION --
TO ETCETERA --
TRAINING PARENTS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN THE
EMOTIONAL RESPONSE THAT OCCURS
WHEN YOU'RE RAISING A CHILD
THAT'S SCREAMING AT YOU ARE
THROWING SOMETHING OUT YOU OR
DAMAGING.
YOUR PRIZE VEHICLE OR SOMETHING
YOU KNOW SO THAT IS AN ONGOING
WORK AND THE MENTOR PARENTS HAVE
SERVED A REALLY REALLY KEY ROLE
THAT SAY SOME OTHER.
OF US YOU KNOW --
HAVE A HARD TIME DOING BECAUSE
WE CAN'T NECESSARILY SAY WELL MY
KID DID THAT TOO EVEN IF WE DID
YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY DEAD BUT IT
IS REALLY HELPFUL WHEN A FOSTER
PARENT SAYS I'VE BEEN THERE.
YEAH SO --
ONE OF THE CONCERNS I HEARD WAS
WE'VE HAD SOME.
OF GROWTH.
THERE'S BIRTH NUMBERS AND OUR
MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS THOSE
AREN'T GETTING PASS IT DOWN TO
THE DIRECT SERVICE AND I KNOW
THAT THINGS COST MORE AND ALL
LEVELS.
BUT ESSENTIALLY WHEN WE ON ARE
ASKED TO DELIVER THE SAME AMOUNT
OF SERVICES OVER AND YEARS AND
YEARS THE COSTS GO UP IT BECOMES
MORE DEMANDING FOR US TO DELIVER
THE SAME LEVEL OF SERVICES IN
THE SAME QUALITY --
AND SO THERE IS A CONCERN
BECAUSE I I BELIEVE EVEN IN OUR
ON OUR OUR COUNTY THE
PENETRATION RATE THE AMOUNT OF
CHILDREN.
GETTING SERVICES AND RELATIONS
SO THAT SIGN THAT I DO HAVE --
THAT I JUST WANT TO BRING UP
WHEN I HEARD THAT GROWTH
HEADACHE INCREASED.
THANK YOU AND JUST A SIDE
COMMENT I WAS A TEACHER AND AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL EXCITED ABOUT
ALL THE MONEY THAT'S GOING BACK
TO THE SCHOOLS GOING BACK TO THE
SCHOOLS AND IT REALLY IS NOT
MAKING IT INTO THE CLASSROOM.
AND SO I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT IN ALL
OF OUR SALARIES GOING UP --
IT'S GOING TO DEFINITELY IMPACT --
THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE TRYING TO
RECRUIT JUST BASIC FOLKS FOR
BASIC SERVICES SO I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENT DON'T BE AFRAID TO
SAY TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S THE
REASON THAT WE'RE HERE.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HEAR
THEM BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
HAPPENED SOMETIMES FOLKS IN
THESE TYPES OF HEARINGS AND IN
THE SUB ONE HEARING THEY'RE FREE
TO TELL US THE TRUTH AND THE
REASON THAT WE'RE HERE IS. TO BE
TOLD THE TRUTH BECAUSE IF WE
LEAVE HERE THINKING THAT
EVERYTHING'S FINE THEN WHY ARE
WE HERE.
AND SO SOUL IF YOU CAN IF YOU
CAN JUST BE REALLY STRAIGHT AND
HONEST ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT ON
THIS WE KNOW WE STILL MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO DO MUCH ABOUT IT.
BUT AT LEAST WE KNOW THAT THOSE
ARE THE ISSUES AND WE CAN AT
LEAST WORK TOWARDS --
A RESOLUTION FOR THAT ANY
QUESTIONS OR ANY.
COME LARGEST MAKE A COUPLE OF
OBSERVATIONS I THINK --
A LOT OF THESE TARGET AND
SETTING QUESTIONS.
IT BRINGS TO MIND JOHN KENNEDY
WHO ONCE SAID THE GOVERNOR'S TO
CHOOSE.
YOU KNOW SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO
IS ACTUALLY CHOOSE AMONG
ALTERNATIVES [inaudible]
AND THINGS JUST SORT OF COME UP.
AS I SIT HERE I ACTUALLY STARTED
THE BUILDING THIS IS CRAZY MORE
THAN FORTY ONE YEARS AGO.
AND SINCE I'M A LAWYER I'VE DONE
LOOK LET'S JUST A WAR CONTINUES
IN VARIOUS SETTINGS ALL THAT.
TIME.
BUT MY FIRST BOSS SO THIS WOULD
HAVE BEEN ABOUT.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WHICH IS A NOT WHAT THIS
AREA.
BUT WAS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
AND THE CHALLENGE OF RETAINING
PEOPLE.
THAT YOU NEEDED TO PROVIDE A
SKILL LIBERAL LEVEL OF CARE.
A MORE EXPERIENCED PEOPLE THE
ONE ACTUALLY DO THE BEST AND
DELIVERING IT.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE
WORKED IN WAY BACK THEN WAS --
FIND IN A WAY TO PROVIDE STATE
DOLLARS TO BACK FILL IN SUPPORT
WHAT THEY WERE PAID. TO A VITAL
BETTER THAN INCOME ADVANTAGE.
I I'M JUST SAYING OKAY THAT'S
THAT'S AN IDEA TO DEAL WITH
RETENTION ISSUES AND HOW DO YOU
KEEP QUALITY PEOPLE THERE SO
MAYBE THAT'S IN SOME WAY SHAPE
OR FORM AN IDEA.
THINK ABOUT.
OF THE OTHER ISSUE NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO A. BE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY THREE WE SET.
IN AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
A BILL TO THE CURRENT GOVERNOR
WAY BACK THEN.
WHICH WAS DESIGNED TO SET ASIDE
A MINIMUM OF FIFTY GRAND FOR
EVERY.
EVERY COUNTY IN THE STATE. FOR
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION COURSE LA
COUNTY GOT A BIG PILE OF MONEY.
BUT THAT WAS THE FIRST
SYSTEMATIC WAY TO TRY TO FIND AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
A MULTI DISCIPLINARY LOCAL
ENVISION APPROACHES FOR DEALING
WITH CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION AND
DEDICATED THE FUNDS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO THE LOCALS HAD.
FUNDS TO WORK WITH.
AND KERRY THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
PRIORITY SETTING FOR THE STATE
LEVEL. TO KIND OF SAY WELL WE
CAN GO UNDER SHASTA COUNTY AND
LET THEM FASHION A SHASTA COUNTY
SOLUTION.
BECAUSE I WAS SUPPOSED TO KIDS
IN CHESTER COUNTY.
WHO WHO HAVE ISSUES?
HAVE DIFFERENT ISSUES THE KIDS
IN.
ALAMEDA OR SAN RECESS COR LA OR
SAN DIEGO.
AND SO AGAIN I DO THINK THIS
BRAINSTORMING.
HOW DO WE TRANSLATE IDEALS AND
POLICY IN AFFECTED PRIORITY
SETTING?
THAT SUPPORT GOOD OUTCOMES IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND I'M MORE SURE THESE OLD
STORIES BECAUSE IT IT DOES
RELATE TO WELL.
WHAT WOULD BE A GOOD SOLUTION?
AND THEN HOW DO WE GO ABOUT
TRYING TO MAKE THAT SALE.
SO THAT WE CAN CHOOSE TO GO ON
THAT WAY.
AND OF COURSE SURE YOU HAVE THE
STANDING COMMITTEE CHAIR IN THE
BUDGET CHAIR AND I SELECT
COMMITTEE CHAIR ALL TOGETHER.
SOUL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OKAY STEVE ELSON.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY --
I'M A DOCTOR STEVE EL SAN FROM
CASA PACIFICA --
WE HAVE SERVICES IN VENTURA
COUNTY AND IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY --
AND YOU NOTE JUST A WORD ABOUT --
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
WHICH IS A MASSIVE CHANGE IN THE
WAY IN WHICH WE WORK WITH KIDS
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM THAT
REALLY IS.
BEING CALLED ONCE IN A
GENERATION PERFORM.
AND I WANT A COMPLIMENT --
THE FOLKS IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
SERRA ROGERS GREG ROADS AND AND
THEIR TEAMWHO'VE BEEN WORKING
ON CC ARE IMPLEMENTATION AND I
THINK THEY'VE.
REALLY DEMONSTRATED A A STRONG --
EFFORT -- TO
AT TRY TO IMPLEMENTED IN THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND
BOTH THE YOUTH AND THE ISSUES ON
THE GROUND AMONG THE PROVIDERS.
SO -- ONE
THING YOU KNOW WE HEARD A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT --
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE MENTAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT MENTAL HEALTH
FOLKS AND THE H. C. S. AND AND
CHILD WELFARE SOCIAL SIR ONE
THING THAT IT SEEMS TO ME COULD
HELP.
WOULD BE ELEVATING THE THE THE
FOLKS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH TO LIKE A DEPUTY DIRECTOR
LEVEL.
THEY'RE SORT OF BURIED IN THAT --
BUREAUCRACY IN A DON'T I THINK
HAVE THE GRAVITAS --
THAT THEY USED TO HAVE WON THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH WAS A ITS
OWN --
DEPARTMENT WITH THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTEE AS THE AS THE DIRECTOR
SO THAT'S KIND OF AN ASIDE MY
OWN PERSONAL VIEW.
I WORD ABOUT CASA PACIFICA WE'VE
BEEN --
SERVING SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN OUR
REGION FOR ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
WE SERVE NOW ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED YOUTH A YEAR --
BY TWENTY INVENTOR AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY MANY OF THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE OUR
THOSE THAT A LARA.
DESCRIBED --
WITH STANFORD --
WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS ON TODAY IS
IS THE S. T. R. T. P. THE SHORT
TERM RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROGRAM WHICH IS KIND OF THE THE
DEEP AND IT IS THE DEFENSE
SERVICE? FOR KIDS YOUTH IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WE HAVE A
TWENTY FIVE ACRE CAMPUS.
WE HAVE FORTY TWO S. T. R. T. P.
BETS.
THE INTENT OF THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM AND THE ROLE OF S.
T. R. TWO PIECES TO REPLACE
GROUPON'S.
WE HEARD KATRINA TALK ABOUT
GROUP HOMES THOSE ARE GOING AWAY.
THAT'S THE INTENT OF THIS REFORM
EFFORT DO AWAY WITH.
A LONG TERM A GROUP HOMES AND TO
CREATE -- A
PROGRAMS AT THE HIGH END TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN PROGRAMS THAT CAN
PROVIDE TREATMENT.
A SERVICES ON A SHORT TERM BASIS
FOR KIDS WHO WHO REALLY NEED OF
SERVICE SO WE HAVE FORTY TWO S.
T. R. T. P. BEDS.
AND WE HAVE TWENTY BEDS OF THAT
WE NOW OFFER TO COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE.
OF FUNDED KIDS OF THESE TO BE --
EMPLOYER BASED INSURANCE KAISER
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS --
AT CENTER SO WE WE HAVE THE I
THINK UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO BOTH
COMPARE THOSE POPULATIONS
COMPARE RATES COMPARE.
OF THE KINDS OF SERVICES THAT
ARE BEING DEMANDED BY THE BY THE
PAYERS -- SO
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR
EXPERIENCES HONEST YEAR TO PAY I
THINK WE WERE THE THIRD STR KEEP
THE IN THE STATE TO BE LICENSED
AS MUCH WE'VE BEEN ASKED HERE TP.
FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN MONTHS.
ONCE WE WERE LICENSED REFERRALS
TO OUR PROGRAM CHEST XCELERATED
DRAMATICALLY.
WE GET ON AVERAGE OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN MONTHS ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE REFERRALS A MONTH. TWO OUR
STR TP WE SERVE BOTH BOYS AND
GIRLS IN THOSE FORTY TWO BEDS.
SOME MONTS WE'VE HAD OVER A
HUNDRED REFERRALS.
REFERRALS COME FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE WE'VE HAD REFERRALS FROM
FORTY DIFFERENT COUNTIES CENTS
WE BECAME LICENSED.
AN WE HAD MET KIDS FROM --
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
SUCH.
AS WELL AS SOUTHERN --
WHAT WE HEAR FROM COUNTY IS THAT
IT THAT IT'S HARDER TO PLACE
GIRLS WE HAVE MORE GIRLS?
MORE GIRL BEDS THAN BOYS.
WE GET REFERRALS FOR YOUTH UNDER
TWELVE ALTHOUGH WE DON'T ADMIT
THEM BUT TEN AND ELEVEN YEAR OLD
REFERRALS COUNTIES --
DESPERATE TO FIND A PROGRAMS
THAT WILL SERVE YOU HAVE.
CHILDREN OF THAT AGE.
WHAT WE SEE IS THAT THE PACKET
REFERRALS THAT WE GET REALLY
TEND TO FOCUS ON ON HOW?
EXTREMELY HE ARE DAMAGED OTHER
COMPLEX COMPLEX TRAUMA THAT THE
KIDS HAVE EXPERIENCED HOW
DIFFICULT THEIR BEHAVIORS ARE.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE IN THOSE
PACKETS ABOUT --
STRENGTHS ABOUT --
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT THE THAT
THE YOUTH HAVE HAVE HAD ABOUT
WHAT IS REDEEMING.
ABOUT THEM --
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
RELY ON IS PERSONAL INTERVIEWS
AMONG THOSE YOUTH ONCE WE SCREEN
PACKETS AND THINK WE CAN HELP
OUR YOUTH WE WANT TO THEM IN
PERSON.
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE OFTEN
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO FAR AWAY.
SO WE ASK COUNTIES TO DO SKYPE.
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO THEY THEY
SAY THEY DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY
PROBABLY 95% OF COUNTY SAY THEY
CAN'T DO IT WE SAY WELL WILL
PROVIDE YOU THE LINK.
WE HAVE THAT CAPABILITY ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS COLLECT
[inaudible]
AND TOM
OF THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IT OUR
SKYPE IS HIPPA COMPLIANT --
WEEK.
WE CAN DO IT AND IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US WITH A
PERSONAL INTERVIEW TO REALLY.
OF BEGIN TO CONNECT WITH A YEAR
WITH.
OUT ONE THING I I I DIDN'T
MENTION ABOUT CASA PACIFICA.
AND I THINK IS SOMEWHAT RELEVANT
IS THAT WE ARE --
AN APA APPROVED INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM SO THAT'S THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION.
WERE APPROVED BY THEM WE HAVE --
INTERNS WHO COME FROM ALL
COUNTRY WE GET ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY APPLICATIONS EVERY
YEAR. FOR FIVE TO SEVEN
INTERNSHIPS LOTS AND AND THAT'S
BEEN -- IT'S
A GREAT --
SERVICE I THINK FOR THE FIELD
BUT IT'S ALSO A RECRUITMENT TOOL
AND WE'RE ABLE.
TO HANG ON TO TO SOME OF OUR
INTERNS THAT WERE ABLE TO TRAIN
[inaudible]
THE SO I'M NOT SURE HOW THAT
RELATED TO SKYPE BUT IT DID
THERE WAS SOME CONNECTION I WAS
GONNA MAKE WELL BUT THE
CONNECTION I THINK IS THAT THAT
HAS SOME OF THE COUNTIES AREN'T
WILLING TO DO THIS WHICH IS
SOMETHING SIMPLE THAT COULD HELP
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS AND I THINK.
THAT'S THE CONVERSATION WERE
TRYING TO HAVE IS WHAT
CHALLENGES YOU HAVE WITH THE
I'LL SAVE YOU FOR IT ON BANKING
RIGHT THERE THAT I KNEW THERE
WAS SOME KIND OF A CONNECTION --
SO LET ME SAY A BIT ABOUT THE
YOUTH THAT WE WE DO IT MET THEY
THEY ALL MEET MEDICAL NECESSITY
OF COURSE THEY ALL REQUIRE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AS HAS BEEN DESCRIBED --
THEY THE ACUITY LEVEL THAT WE
SEE IS HIGHER THAN BEFORE WE
WERE AN STR TP.
WE HAVE --
KIDS WHO ARE.
REALLY ACTING OUT THEIR PAIN.
WHAT THROUGH --
PHYSICAL DEMONSTRATIONS OF THAT
PAIN WHICH INCLUDES PROPERTY
DAMAGE --
VIOLENCE TOWARD OTHERS --
KIDS COME TO US YOU'VE HEARD THE
DIAGNOSES WE'VE SEEN ALL THOSE
DIAGNOSES MAJOR DEPRESSION PTSD.
INTERMITTENT EXPLOSIVE DISORDER.
WE HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
PORTION A CHAIR OF TRANS
GENDERED YOUTH.
THERE'S A NEW ARM RELATIVELY NEW --
ACRONYM NOW IN OUR PARLANCE
CALLED SO G..
YOU'VE ALL HEARD LGBT Q. SO G.
IS SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY EXPRESSION OF SO G. R.
E..
AND WE HAVE A GROUP OF A WEEKLY
GROUP -- FOR
SOCHI KIDS.
AND MORE THAN HALF OF THE KIDS
IN OUR PROGRAM COME TO THAT
GROUP.
SO WE OF OF A PLENTY OF YOUTH
AND YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE OVER
REPRESENTATION OF TRANS GNDER
YOUTH IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
ORDER LGBT YOUTH IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM SO.
OF THAT CERTAINLY MANIFESTS IN
OUR PROGRAM --
WE ALSO SEE MORE SELF INJURIOUS
BEHAVIOR THAN WE DID BEFORE WE A
REAL SERIOUS CUTTERS.
KIDS WHO CUT A IS ANOTHER WAY OF
RELIEVING THEIR THEIR PAIN.
KIDS WHO WANT TO HANG THEMSELVES
WE AT WE ARE OUR CAMPUS.
IS -- ON A
BUSY ROAD THAT ACTUALLY LEADS.
TO OF THE NEWEST A CAL STATE CAL
STATE CHANNEL ISLANDS AND IN
CAMARILLO.
AND KIDS WANNA RUN OUT INTO
TRAFFIC AND GET HIT BY A CAR.
OF THE TALK ABOUT DOING THAT AND
MAKE THOSE ATTEMPTS WE WE DON'T
LET THEM IF YOU BELIEVE THEY'RE
THEY'RE SERIOUS OBVIOUSLY.
LARA MENTION THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAMS THEIR CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT --
TO OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF
PERMANENCY AND OF THE THE REFORM
OF THE INTENT OF THE REFORM
EFFORT OF CCIR WE HAVE SEE OF
TEASE ABOUT ONCE A MONTH --
AND OUT A LOT OF THE PLANNING.
A AND WHERE A YOUTH GOES NEXT
HAPPENS AT THE SEA OF TREES
THEIR CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AND WE SEE REAL --
DIFFERENCES AMONG THE COUNTIES
SOME ARE ON IT AND THEY ARE VERY
PARTICIPANT THEY OPEN THEIR
THERE --
THEY THEY SEE THOSE IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND THEY'RE
REAL WORKING VERY HARD.
ALL IN THE TRANSITION THAT A
YOUTH IS GONNA MAKE AFTER THEY
LEAVE OUR CARE --
OTHER COUNTIES NOT SO MUCH AND
THEY THEY DON'T PARTICIPATE --
KIDS ARE SUPPOSED TO COME TO US
TO IT AS STEERED TO BE WITH
CONCRETE.
A DISCHARGE AFTER CARE PLANS
WHERE THEY GOING NEXT WHAT IS
OUR ROLE IN HELPING THEM GET
THEIR THEY ALL COME WITH PLANS
BUT SOME OF THOSE DISAPPEAR --
FAIRLY SOON AFTER YOUTH IS
ADMITTED --
FAMILY VISITS ARE MORE DIFFICULT
OBVIOUSLY IF --
WE WANT --
TO STE HAVE KIDS STAY CONNECTED
TO FAMILY WE NEED TO HAVE
FAMILIES INVOLVED IN TREATMENT.
AND IF THEY'RE COMING FROM FAR
AWAY.
VAN -- WE'RE
HAVING.
TO CONVINCE COUNTIES THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BRING FAMILIES YOU
CAN YOU PAY FOR THAT COST.
I THINK ONE OF THE ON
ANTICIPATED --
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS REFORM
EFFORT.
WAS THAT IS GROUP HOMES KIND OF
WENT AWAY AND THE FOCUS BECAME.
ARE GOING AWAY AND FOCUSES ON
PERMANENCY THAT.
OF THERE ARE MORE AND MORE AS
STEERED HE'S LIKE CASA PACIFICA
WHO ARE SERVING MORE MORE OUT OF
COUNTY YOU.
ABOUT 80% A 75280% OF THE YOUTH
WE SERVE.
ARE NO LONGER VENTURA SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY THERE FROM
COUNTIES AROUND.
AROUND THE STATE AND THAT.
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT.
THOSE --
AFTER CARE CONNECTIONS FAMILY.
INVOLVEMENT WE'VE GOTTA.
HAVE WAYS OF HAVING THE FAMILY
CONNECTED WHILE THE YOUTH CENTER
KERR.
THAT'S COSTS THAT EITHER.
AND LOOKING AT OUR DATA WE'RE
SENDING ABOUT ONE STAFF A WEEK.
TO A DAY LONG TRIP TO SOME FAR
AWAY COUNTY ACCOMPANYING A YOUTH
TO EITHER COURT APPEARANCE OR A
FAMILY.
OF VISIT AND WE ALSO BRING
FAMILIES.
TO CASA PACIFICA THAT. TO
VENTURA COUNTY THAT IS THAT
ABOUT THERE'S A COST THAT WAS
NOT ANTICIPATED WE HANDLE THAT
COSTS THROUGH A A PRIVATE MONEY
PRIMARILY.
PART OF CALIFORNIA BUT INDEED.
YEAH THAT'S TRUE.
SO A WORD ABOUT OUR STAFF FROM
WE STRUGGLE WITH --
STAFF OF RECRUITMENT RETENTION --
ALSO ARE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY
FINDING.
RESOURCE FAMILIES WE DO HIRE
PARENT PARTNERS AND YOUTH
ADVOCATES WHO WERE PART OF OUR
STAFF WILL WORK WITH THE YOUTH
AND FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE --
BUT WE ARE SEEING MORE --
MORE STAFF INJURIES HIGHER
TURNOVER THAN WE DID IN PRIOR
YEARS SO THAT'S I THINK A
CONSEQUENCE OF OF REALLY SERVING
THE MOST VULNERABLE --
HIGHEST RISK CHILDREN IN IN OUR
IN OUR SYSTEM.
COUNTY SUPPORT IS CRITICAL --
AS I MENTIONED CFT PARTICIPATION
IS CRITICAL. ONE ISSUE THAT HAS
NOT BEEN MENTIONED THAT I WANT
TO BRING UP IS THE PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER WHICH ALSO.
IMPACTS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
SO.
ENTER COUNTY LIKE SHASTA COUNTY
ABOUT DIANA MIGHT MENTION THIS --
IS IS WHAT WE WOULD CALL A
HIGHLY IMPACT COUNTY.
SO -- AS A
HIGHLY IMPACTED COUNTY WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT THAT.
THERE ARE MORE KIDS BEING
IMPORTED TO USE THEIR VERY CRASS
PHRASE INTO VENTURA COUNTY.
THAT NOW VENTURA COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH IS RESPONSIBLE.
FOR SAME IN CHESTER COUNTY ALSO
SO.
YOU HAVE COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
TO EXPORT KIDS DON'T HAVE LOCAL
RESOURCES.
OTHER COUNTIES WHERE RESOURCES
ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH OUR WHERE
COUNTIES ARE DOING A BETTER JOB.
WELL -- MAY
BE HELD MAYBE THAT THEY THAT I'M
BUT I CAN TELL YOU VENTURA
COUNTY IS NOT HAPPY HAVING A
CASA PACIFICA A MAGNET SORT OF
PROGRAM.
OF FOR THE STATE WHEN THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THAT.
CHILD WHO WAS PLACED.
OUR OUR OUR WHAT WE'RE ASKING
OUR COUNTY TO SUPPORT IN TERMS
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO BE
PROVIDED. TO ALL OF THESE OUT OF
COUNTY YOUTH THE IS --
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN OUR
CONTRACT.
AND THEY ARE BEARING THE BRUNT
OF THAT.
BECAUSE OF PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER.
THE INTENT OF PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER WAS THAT IF.
SAY UP.
YOU THIRD A CHILD GETS PLACED
WITH GRANDMA FROM RIVERSIDE AND
THEY COME TO VENTURA COUNTY.
WE DON'T WANT GRANDMA TO HAVE TO
GO TO RIVERSIDE TO GET MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR THAT YOU.
SOLD VENTURA YEAR NOW
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING ALL
SERVICES.
THAT WAS FINE.
EXCEPT FOR STR KEEP PEAS WHICH
ARE THE HIGH COST --
BUT A SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
DELIVERED TO EVER YOUTH WHOSE.
WHOSE PLACED SO THAT PUTS A HUGE.
ON THOSE IMPORTED COUNTY SO DOES
THAT MEAN THAT AND GOING BACK TO
THE THE FUNDING MECHANISMS AGAIN
DOES THAT MEAN THAT --
THEY'RE NOT BEING REIMBURSED AT
ALL OR THEY'RE BEING REIMBURSED
TWO YEARS LATER WELL.
AND NOW THEY'RE NOT BEING
REIMBURSED AT ALL THIS IS THIS
HAS TO BE VENTURA COUNTY
REALIGNMENT FUNDS THAT ARE USED
AS THE MATCH.
AND THERE HASN'T DR YES.
AND THEY WOULD BE EVENTUALLY
REIMBURSE THE 50% FFP.
EVENTUALLY.
BUT YOU KNOW YEAR REALIGNMENT
ALLOCATION IS BUILT PRIOR --
TO THE YEAR STARTING.
AND SO THERE ARE COUNTIES --
ACCOUNTING I WAS ON THE PHONE
WITH A FEW WEEKS AGO WHO --
HAS ABOUT FOUR CHILDREN.
OUT OF COUNTY AND THEY HAVE A
HUNDRED BED IN THEIR COUNTY.
SO IT'S NOT QUITE FULL BUT THEY
POTENTIALLY WENT FROM FOUR KIDS
THEY WERE RESPONSIBLE. FOR TO
POTENTIALLY.
EIGHTY KIDS SUDDENLY THAT THEY
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR HIGH END.
VERY INTENSIVE DAILY SERVICES SO
IT'S A IT'S A BIG DEAL.
THANK YOUR DOCTOR RIGHT YEAH CAN
YOU SPEAK IF YOU CAN TO THE AB
TWELVE NINETY NINE WHICH WAS
CHAPTER IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN I BELIEVE THERE
WAS AN ALL COUNTY LETTER THAT
WENT OUT IN JULY HAS THAT
IMPROVE FOR WHAT WERE THE
RESULTS OF THAT ALL COUNTY --
THE LETTER REALLY WAS DESIGNED
TO JUST INSTRUCT ON THE PROCESS
IT DIDN'T.
CHANGE THE PROCESS OR CHANGE IT
DIDN'T CHANGE ANYTHING OF THE
STRUCTURE IT JUST IN --
CLARIFIED FOR FOLKS TO KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND AND AT THIS POINT
THERE'S PROBABLY STILL SOME
CONFUSION BUT THE BIGGER PIECES
THE COST.
THERE IS A PROCESS THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE DEVELOPED WITH --
CAL MESA --
AND SOME COUNTIES ARE OPTING
INTO THAT PROCESS AND SUMMER NOT.
AND I BECAUSE I AGAIN DON'T DEAL
SPECIFIC I MEAN I UNDERSTAND THE
FISCAL PEACE BUT I DON'T DEAL
WITH IT.
DAY IN AND DAY OUT I DON'T KNOW --
HOW THE FLOW IS GOING THAT
SOMETHING I CAN FIND OUT BUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW THE FLOW IS GOING?
AGAIN IT'S DESIGNED NOT ALL
COUNTIES HAVE SO THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES FOR THAT AND
CERTAINLY.
AN EXPORTER COUNTY.
THAT HAS NO BEDS IN THERE COUNTY.
SHOULD THEY OFTEN DO THEY OPT IN
YOU KNOW THERE'S ALL THOSE KINDS
OF CHALLENGES AND SO.
I WILL BE ASKING A DIFFERENT
WITH OKAY.
NONE OF THEM SEND THE MONEY BACK
TO THE STATE DO THEY THEY ALL
EXCEPT.
THE FUNDS REALIGN IT COMES WITH
THE REGIONALES COUNTY THAT THEN
DECIDE NOT TO PROVIDE SERVICES
AND EXPORT THOSE TO OTHERS.
IT IT IT'S YES AND IT IS NOT THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
CALL AS TO WHETHER A CHILD IS
PRESUMPTIVELY TRANSFERRED OR NOT
IT IS THE PLACING AGENCIES FINAL
DECISION.
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN IS INFORMED
ABOUT THE DECISION MADE HER
PARTICIPATE DURING THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAM.
BUT THEY CANNOT FORMALLY REQUEST
THAT PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER BE
WAIVED --
THAT IS THERE'S A VERY SMALL
GROUP OF FOLKS THAT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO SO SO THERE'S
SOME CHALLENGES.
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE FOR THE
MIDDLE HEALTH PLANS WITH THAT
I'M PROBABLY DELVING TOO FAR IN
FOR THIS COMMITTEE BUT WILL WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ONLY BECAUSE I I
WAS FROM PRESIDENT.
AND KINGS DIDN'T HAVE ANY BEDS.
AND AND SO YES THEY'RE RECEIVING
FUNDS BUT ARE THEY PROVIDING
CARE TO THE FOSTER CHILDREN IN
THEIR COUNTY.
IS IT THEN FAIR TO THE REST OF
THE COUNTIES THAT SURROUND --
TO STEP UP TO THE PLATE.
AND DO WHAT'S NECESSARY LIKE
CASA PACIFICA IS RIGHT AND AND
THERE ARE MANY COUNTIES THAT ARE
AND THERE'S JUST.
CHALLENGES WITH THE PROCESS AND
UNDERSTANDING.
AND THE PACE AND ALSO CHALLENGES
AS AS THEIR LEARNING
PARTICULARLY THE NEWER PROVIDERS
SOME OF THE SMALLER PROVIDERS AS
THEIR LEARNING.
THE SYSTEM AND THEY'RE LEARNING
TO BECOME TO SERVE THIS HIGHER
AND POPULATION THAT'S THERE'S A
GROWTH THERE'S A LEARNING CURVE.
WELL ONE OF THE IF IF I CAN TO
AND I JUST WANT TO GET IT RIGHT
IT IS CUT THAT ENOUGH RIGHT AND
JUST WE'VE HEARD MULTIPLE
PRONOUNCE.
THREE OKAY --
AS AS COMPANY NOW WAS TALKING
ABOUT I I'M REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
HOW WE MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
PERMANENCY.
YES.
AND AND ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
MOVING KIDS OUT OF THE COUNTY
THE ONLY COUNTY THEY MAY KNOW.
IT'S AN HOUR TALKING ABOUT
TRANSFERRING THEM ALL THE WAY
ACROSS STATE IN A PENDING MANY
FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS THEY HAVE
THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES ABSALOM
THE ACTIONS WE HOMES ON JUST.
FOR US TO HAVE REAL PERMANENCY
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THE BEST TREATMENT WE CAN THE
CLOSEST TO HOME THAT WE CAN.
SO CAN I I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
THING BECAUSE WE'VE TALKED WE
TALKED SOME ABOUT THE MONEY AND
OF COURSE WE NEED THE MONEY IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE SERVICES
HAPPENED.
I HAD TO GO TO THE BOARD AND ASK
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO AND TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF KIDS FROM
OUTSIDERS SHASTA COUNTY --
COMING IN --
THERE'S ALSO THE PIECE YOU JUST
TOUCHED ON IT.
THAT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN FOSTER YOUTH
THAT HAVE LEARNT LIVED IN ONE
COUNTY THEIR LIFETIME ARE
TRANSFERRED TO SHASTA COUNTY.
JUST COUNTY DOESN'T OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS WE DON'T KNOW THE
HISTORY OF WHAT'S GONE ON BUT
YET WERE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE HIGHEST NEEDS TO USE --
WITH IN ANOTHER COUNTY TO
PROVIDE THEM SERVICES AND DO WE
REALLY DO THE BEST JOB IF WE DO
NOT KNOW THE HISTORY AND WHAT
HAS HAPPENED WITH THEM.
ONLY TO HAVE THEM LEAVE SIX
MONTHS NINE MONTHS EVEN TWELVE
MONTHS LATER TO RETURN BACK TO
THEIR COUNTY.
IT WOULD SEEM LIKE RATHER THAN --
SO I I DO NOT DO THAT JUST
COUNTY -- I
WAY PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER ON ALL
MY YOUTH THAT ARE PLACED IN S.
T. R. T. PIECE SIMPLY BECAUSE I
AM RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
CHILDREN AND I WANT TO CONTINUE
TO FOLLOW THEM AND ENSURE THE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED TO THEM.
AND MY EXPECTATION WOULD BE THE
ALL SO THE PIECE OF STE FOR THE
RIGHT AND LISTENING TO THIS --
AND I KEEP STATING YOU KNOW THAT
I WAS A TEACHER BY I SEE SO MANY
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN.
TEACHING BECAUSE IT THEIR ALL
OUR KIDS SO AND I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT AND AN
EARLY TWENTY NINETEEN ABOUT THE
TRANSFER SITUATION BUT BUT FOR
STUDENTS WE HAVE.
THE MONEY FOLLOWS THE KID SOUL
SOUL YOU KNOW EACH STUDENT IS
ASSIGNED X. AMOUNT OF DOLLARS
AND NO MATTER WHAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT THEY GO TO THAT TIED
YOU RECEIVE THAT MONEY FOR THAT
CHILD.
NOW IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE POSSIBLE.
YOU IN THIS IS ALL.
YOU KNOW I'M JUST SPEAKING OUT
LOUD AT THIS POINT BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE MIGHT I
MEAN IF WE CAN DO IT FOR THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
I WOULD HOPE.
THAT WE COULD DO IT FOR SOME OF
THESE ESPECIALLY FOR THESE
CRITICAL SERVICES SERVER MARKET
JUMP AND TOOK TO MAKE THIS A
LITTLE MORE PRACTICAL TO IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THE HIGH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES COST PER CHILD
IN AN S. T. R. TP.
IT'S GONNA RANGE AROUND THE
STATE FROM BETWEEN FOUR THOUSAND
A MONTH TWO SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
FIVE HUNDRED A MONTH.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE AVERAGE
COST SO IF THE YOUTH IS IN
PLACEMENT.
IN A FACILITY FOR SIX MONTHS.
YOU'RE TALKING AS A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN VENTURA
COUNTY WE WENT TO THE COUNTY --
EARLY ON AND SAID WE'RE GONNA
NEED A MILLION MORE IN OUR
CONTRACT. TO SERVE THESE OUT
ACCOUNT KIDS AND DATE JUST ABOUT --
FAINTED.
AT THAT REQUEST --
WE WE WOUND UP DOING LESS THAN
THAN THAT BUT BUT AN AMOUNT THAT
WE THINK WE CAN MANAGE WITH WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS OVER TIME I THINK
THE THINKING HAS BEEN.
THAT WHAT HAPPENS OVER TIME IS
THAT BEEN TURKEY CLAIMS.
BASED -- FOR
THOSE KIDS WHO WERE NOW THEY ARE
NOW RESPONSIBLE.
FOR SO AT OVER TIME THEY'RE
GOING TO WIND UP GETTING THAT
MONEY NEXT YEAR'S ALLOCATION IS
GOING TO BE BASED ON THE AMOUNT
OF CLAIMS THEY HAVE OF THEIR
CLAIMS ARE GOING UP.
SO THE THEORY IS THAT OVER THAT
IN THE NEXT THREE YEARS LET'S
SAY.
EVERYTHING'S GONNA EVEN OUT
BECAUSE THE MONEY DOES FOLLOW
THE RIGHT.
BITE BUT BETTER THREE YEARS THEY
HAD ISSUE.
THAT COUNTIES ARE FACING IN THE
MEAN TIME.
THERE WAS A EFFORT A SOLUTION
THAT THAT ARE OF ASSOCIATION
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION.
DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND MONEY
WHICH IT LOOKS LIKE WAS GONNA GO
PLACES BUT IT DIDN'T.
FOR SOME REASON HERE --
I FOUND TO BE A REAL HEALTH
FOLKS THOUGHT THAT THIS CAL MESA
IDEA THAT THEY HAD WAS KIND ARE
GONNA DO IT BUT IN ANY EVENT IT
IS A IT IS AN ISSUE.
FOR I WOULD GUESS AT LEAST A
DOZEN COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA WHO
WERE IMPORTING KIDS AND YOU HAVE
THIS BIG CASH ISSUE RIGHT BUT
BUT AGAIN USING THE SCHOOL
ANALOGY --
WHEN THAT KID WHEN A STUDENT
TRANSFERS TO ANOTHER DISTRICT
THAT MONEY IS IMMEDIATE?
UP ON THE EIGHTY EIGHT AS WELL
AS THE CUMULATIVE RECORDS ONCE
THE STUDENT TRANSFERS OVER WE
ARE REQUIRED I'VE YOU KNOW MANY
TIMES SIXTEEN YEARS TEACHING I
HAD TO FILL OUT THE EXIT --
CUME WITH THE REPORT CARDS AND
YOU KNOW PROOF OF THE WORK
SAMPLES AND ALL OF THAT AND KIND
OF IN A REAL SMALL PARAGRAPH HAS
TO WHAT.
ISSUES IF THERE WERE ANY WITH
THAT STUDENT IN VACUUM GOES TO
THAT FOLLOWING SCHOOL IN NOW
GRANTED IT WOULD TAKE ABOUT A
MONTH.
BUT IT WOULD MAKE IT THERE AND
THEN THE FUNDING WAS DIRECTLY.
I YOU KNOW FOLLOWING THE CHILD
NOT THREE YEARS LATER AND I
THINK TO BE DISCUSSED LATER BUT
THAT'S IF WE CAN DO IT IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND CLEARLY THE
NEED IS SO HIGH.
IT'S NOT RIGHT FOR THOSE
COUNTIES THAT ARE DOING A GOOD
JOB TO GET THE INFLUX OF KIDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING A GOOD JOB.
AND THEN NOT BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
IT WHICH ESSENTIALLY IS GOING TO
ERODE YOUR PROGRAM BECAUSE NOW
YOU DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING FOR
IT AND SO THE HIGH QUALITY
SERVICES YOU'RE PROVIDING YOU
ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO PROVIDE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE THE MONEY.
BUT AGAIN THESE ARE ALL ME
SPEAKING OUT LOUD IN TRYING TO
KIND OF MAKE SURE THAT NEXT TIME
WE CAN REMEMBER YOU KNOW PARTS
OF THE CONVERSATION ARE ALL OF
THE CONVERSATION SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY MAKE SOME CHANGES. ONE OF
THE PRACTICAL ISSUES I THINK IS
GOING TO ULTIMATELY BE THAT.
THAT BOB PROVIDERS WHO HAVE BEDS
ARE GONNA SELL THEM TO
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE COMPANIES
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND NOT DEAL WITH HER OR OR
REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF BEDS THERE
MAKING AVAILABLE TO THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM SIMPLY BECAUSE OF OF
ISSUES LIKE AT THE IS
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER.
SO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOUR THERE'S
CLEARLY OF A LOT OF ISSUES BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS
AND YOU KNOW IF WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR OUR FOR
THIS PANEL.
RIGHT AT THIS MOMENT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A TON OF QUESTIONS FOR
LATER BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THIS DIALOGUE BECAUSE I
THINK YOU KNOW IF ANYTHING --
FOR US UP HERE --
WE CAN TAKE SOME OF THESE --
IDEAS IN THOSE PERFECT THE
SOMEONE --
THE AS SELECT COMMITTEE ON
FOSTER USE THAT HERE AND HUMAN
SERVICES IS HERE SO THAT BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S A TEAM EFFORT WE CAN'T
SOLVE IT.
CLEARLY NOT ON OUR OWN SO WE
NEED ALL OF YOU.
TO TO INTERJECT AND HELP US WITH
ALL OF THE INS AND OUTS OF THIS
SO THANK YOU AGAIN I APPRECIATED
AND AT I KNOW WE HAVE ANOTHER
PANEL COMING AND THEY HAVE TO
LEAVE ARE THERE.
SOMEBODY HAS TO GO ON A PLANE SO
THANK YOU AGAIN [inaudible]
LARA.
THANK YOU SO OUR NEXT PANEL
[inaudible]
IS.
KATHY DOES CENTER LINK DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CAN YOU
OFFER DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
QUORUM LATELY --
MPP JD MENTAL HEALTH ATTORNEY
LIAISON CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
LOS ANGELES AND SHE IS THE ONE
THAT HAS TO GO ON A PLANE SO WE
WILL.
I GIVE HER THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
FIRST AND THEN CAN BURKE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF ZENECA
FAMILY.
OF AGENCIES THANK YOU.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
SO PATIENT MY APOLOGIES.
SO I'M GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO
START BY THANKING --
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND CHAIRS
AND CO CHAIRS.
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON FOSTER
CARE IN THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES ON HUMAN SERVICES FOR
COMING TOGETHER TO FOCUS ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE --
MY NAME IS MORE MALANI AND I AM
AN ATTORNEY WITH THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS --
FIVE FORTY FIVE IS A CASE KERN
ATTORNEY IN THE COURT ROOM
EVERYDAY REPRESENTING.
FOSTER USE AND THE LAST TEN PLUS
AS A MEMBER OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCACY TEAM --
MY COLLEAGUES ALSO PRESENT TODAY
WITH ME --
OUR CLINICIAN MEMBER OF OUR
MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCACY TEAM.
SO STILL SEE THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER REPRESENTS CHILDREN IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IN LOS
ANGELES PLACER IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTIES.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN WHICH ARE HALF
THE STATE'S FOSTER CARE
POPULATION.
GOOD MENTAL HEALTH AS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY FOR A FOSTER YOUTH
INCLUDES.
I HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
COMMUNITY IDENTITY [inaudible]
CULTURAL CONNECTION.
AND MEANINGFUL WORK OR EDUCATION.
SOMETIMES IT REQUIRES
PROFESSIONAL INTERVENTION
THERAPY AND OR MEDICATION.
EACH CHILD ADOLESCENT AND YOUNG
ADULT NEED SOMETHING TO DO.
SOMEWHERE TO BELONG.
AND SOMETHING TO HOPE. FOR FOR
THE PAST TEN YEARS OUR MENTAL
HEALTH ADVOCACY TEAM IT'S STILL
SEE HAS WORKED COLLABORATIVELY
TO ENSURE A STRONG CLINICAL CASE
COORDINATION.
AMONG OUR ATTORNEYS LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN FAMILY
SERVICES.
LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND NUMEROUS COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS.
OUR GOAL IS TO SUPPORT THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
FOSTER YOUTH AND NON MINOR
DEPENDENCE.
AS A RESULT OF ARE DECADE LONG
EFFORT AT AT IN M. HAD TO BUILD
BRIDGES AMONG OUR ORGANIZATIONS
WE ARE ABLE TO REQUEST AND
RECEIVE --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR OUR
CLIENTS MUCH MORE EASILY.
NOW WITH THE PASSAGE OF CC ARE
WE ARE CLOSER THAN EVER TO
REALIZING OUR COLLECTIVE GOAL TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY FOSTER CHILD
AND YOUNG ADULT.
IS HEALTHY BENTLEY AND
PHYSICALLY.
SO FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT AT CLC --
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT POSITIVE
PIECES OUR THE SHIFT IN OUR
COLLECTIVE THINKING ABOUT --
MENTAL HEALTH A NEW AND GREAT ON
I UNDERSTAND THAT MENTAL HEALTH
AFFECTS US ALL AND SHOULD BE
VIEWED IN A MORE HOLISTIC WAY.
A NEW FOCUS ON FINDING A
PERMANENT HOME FOR EVERY FOSTER
YOUTH.
SO INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR A
CHILD TO STABILIZE BEFORE
FINDING A HOME WHICH HAS BEEN
THE PRACTICE PREVIOUSLY.
NOW WE LOOK FOR A HOME WHERE THE
CHILD CAN OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN
STABILITY.
THEY'RE NOT WAITING TO BE GOOD
ENOUGH --
ARE STABLE ENOUGH TO GET A HOME
THEY DESERVE A HOME FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THE REALIZATION THAT DISCHARGE
PLANNING IT'S CRITICAL THAT WAS
SPOKEN -- BY
THE GENTLEMAN FROM CASA PACIFICA.
EVERY FOSTER YOUTH WHO ENTERS
CONGRESS CARE MUST HAVE A
DISCHARGE PLAN FROM THE DATE OF
ADMISSION.
DISCHARGE PLANNING SHOULD BEGIN
WHEN THE CHILD ENTERS CONGREGATE
CARE NOT WHEN THEY'RE READY TO
TRANSITION.
UNLESS FOCUS ON DIAGNOSIS.
DIAGNOSIS AND BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS AND MORE FOCUS ON
STRENGTH.
AND FUTURE POSSIBILITY OF EVERY
CHILD.
ALLOWING THE CHILD TO DRIVE THE
CFT PROCESS RATHER THAN THE
AGENCY PROFESSIONALS COURSE.
OF THE CHILD THE CHILD AND YOUTH
NEED ON THE SUPPORT OF ADULTS IN
THEIR LIVES AND SOMETIMES AGENCY
PROFESSIONALS BUT THE SEA OF TO
PROCESS SHOULD BE.
DRIVEN BY THE CHILD.
SOME OF THE ONGOING CHALLENGES
THAT WE SEE IN COURT EVERYDAY --
OF C. C. R. INCLUDE THE RFA
PROCESS WHICH HAS MADE IT MORE
CUMBERSOME FOR RELATIVES TO
BECOME APPROVED CARE GIVERS.
THE DELAY --
IN APPROVAL THESE CHILDREN IN
FOSTER HOMES ARE CONGREGATE CARE
FOR LONGER PERIODS OF TIME.
AND LEAVES CARE GIVERS WITHOUT
NEEDED SOME IN THEIR CARE.
DISCHARGE FROM S. YOUR CHEAPEST
FACILITIES WHICH WERE STARTING
TO SEE NOW BECAUSE THE SIX MONTH
TIME FRAME HAS STARTED TO RUN ON
A LOT OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE BEEN
PLACED IN THE S. R. T. P.
FACILITIES.
SO ALTHOUGH THE STAYS ARE MEANT
TO BE LIMITED IN TIME THERE ARE
FEW SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT YOU THEIR TRANSITION
WHEN APPROPRIATE.
SO AS COUNSEL FOR THE CHILD WE
NEED LEVERAGE --
TO LIMIT OUR CLIENT STAND
CONGREGATE CARE.
A LACK OF TRAINING FOR LINE
SOCIAL WORKERS ATTORNEYS
PROVIDERS AND CARE GIVERS ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CCIR.
IT DOESN'T SEEM THAT THERE IS A
GENERAL UNDERSTANDING OF HOW TO
SCREEN AND CERTIFY FOR S. T. R.
T. P. PLACEMENT THERE'S LOTS OF
QUESTIONS FROM THE SOCIAL
WORKERS ON A DAILY BASIS.
ABOUT HOW TO GET --
S. T. R. T. P. SCREENING AND
CERTIFICATION MUCH LESS
PLACEMENT THOSE ARE ALL SEPARATE
PROCESSES AND THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN.
SEPARATE CHALLENGES.
LOTS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
AFFAIR APPROVAL STILL AND THE
PURPOSE AND PROCESS OF CF TEAM
MEETINGS.
ARE AS THE CHILD ADVOCATE THE
ATTORNEY FOR THE CHILD.
OFTENTIMES OUR CLIENTS WANT OUR
PRESENCE AT THE SEA OF TEAM
MEETINGS AND IF WE ATTENDED
COUNTY COUNCIL THEN.
IT WILL SAY THAT THEY NEED TO
ATTEND SO THAT IT BECOMES THIS
KIND OF BATTLE AS TO HOW TO
SCHEDULE THESE MEETINGS WITH ALL
THESE.
YOU KNOW ATTORNEYS PRESENT WHICH
IS TOTALLY NOT THE FOCUS OF WHAT
THE MEETING SHOULD BE ABOUT.
SO -- THAT
CAN BECOME WE CAN KIND OF GET
BOGGED DOWN IN SOME OF THOSE.
MY NEWS AND SOME OF THAT MY
NISHA.
IN THE N. C. C. R. WILL ONLY BE
AS EFFECTIVE AS ITS
IMPLEMENTATION TO ENSURE THEIR
CLIENTS HAVE COMPREHENSIVE AND
CHILD FOCUSED CASE PLANTS.
SO THIS IS MY OPPORTUNITY TO
ALSO LET YOU KNOW THAT OVER THE
PAST DECADE WORKING EVERY DAY
WITH ATTORNEYS AND AND CHILDREN.
ADOLESCENTS AND NON MEYER
DEPENDENT IN THE COURTROOM --
OUR MENTAL HEALTH TEAM HAS
ENCOUNTERED ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGES TO PROVIDING
EFFECTIVE AND APPROPRIATE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
THESE INCLUDE THE NEED FOR
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
LANGUAGE SPECIFIC THERAPIST TO
WORK WITH CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THERE'S OFTENTIMES WHERE
CHILDREN FAMILIES ARE WAITING --
TO BE RECONCILED.
THROUGH THE REUNIFICATION
PROCESS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
RECEIVING APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE.
BASED TREATMENT.
QUALITY HOMES FOR YOUTH AND
NOMAR DEPENDENCE WITH FOSTER
PARENTS WHO ARE TRAINED
SUPPORTED AND WILLING TO REMAIN
COMMITTED.
I'VE HAD QUITE A BIT OF
EXPERIENCE OF THE LAST DECADE
WORKING WITH IT OF STEEP FOSTER
PARENTS AND DESPITE.
THE TRAINING THAT FOSTER PARENTS
FOR STILL A REAL CHALLENGE AND
I'VE HEARD THAT TODAY IS TO
MAINTAIN PLACEMENT SO THAT'S A
CONSTANT STRUGGLE.
OUR EMERGENCY SHELTER FACILITIES
FOR NON MINOR DEPENDENT MALES.
THERE ARE NONE --
IN LA COUNTY SO THE A A YOUNG
MALES BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE AND UP IN ADULT
HOMELESS SHELTERS IN DOWNTOWN LA --
BECAUSE THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE FOR
THEM TO GO.
THERE'S A LACK OF BOARD
CERTIFIED CHILD PSYCHIATRIST SO
WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN DEBATE.
WHETHER MEDICATION IS A GOOD
THING OR NOT A GOOD THING BUT IF
A CHILD IS PRESCRIBED MEDICATION
THEY NEED TO BE SEEN BY A DOCTOR --
HAND SO.
IT'S VERY HARD A LOT OF OUR
CLIENTS WAIT FORTY FIVE DAYS TO
GET AN APPOINTMENT AND SO THAT
THIRTY DAY YOU KNOW EXITING
EITHER FROM THE HOSPITAL WITH
THE NEED --
FOR A REFILL THE PRESCRIPTION OR
ANOTHER MEDICATION EVALUATION --
THERE ARE RESORTING TO LOCAL
EMERGENCY ROOMS OR URGENT CARE
FACILITIES TO GET THAT MEDICAL
TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED AND I
KNOW YOU'RE ALL EDUCATED THAT.
THERE'S LAB TESTS AND ALL SORTS
OF OTHER MEDICARE MEDICAL AND
HEALTH A SAFEGUARDS FOR CHILDREN
ON MEDICATION. ONE OTHER REALLY
BIG ISSUE. FOR US WITH OUR
CLIENTS AS WE NEED THE REGIONAL
CENTER WE NEED GREATER
COLLABORATION FROM THE REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES. TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TARGETED TO ME OUR
CLIENTS NEEDS --
AT HOT WEATHER THERE AT HOME OR
IN CARE.
SO THAT IS ALSO A STRUGGLE --
CLIENTS THAT HAVE BOTH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY AND A MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSIS.
ARE MUCH GREATER RISK TO SPEND
MUCH MORE TIME OUT OF THE HOME
AND IN CONGREGATE CARE.
SO -- WE
HAVE ALL SORTS OF LEGAL
STRATEGIES AT OUR DISPOSAL WE
CAN SUBPOENA THE REGIONAL CENTER
AND JOIN THE REGIONAL CENTER BUT
IT IS A CHALLENGE TO GET.
THE REGIONAL CENTER TO
PARTICIPATE FROM THE BEGINNING --
IT'S INSTEAD OF IT BEING A FIGHT
TO KIND OF GET INVOLVEMENT --
AND FIND APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT.
SO OUR CLIENTS THAT HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES THAT ARE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED NEED A
DIFFERENT KIND OF TREATMENT IT
NEEDS TO BE TARGETED TO THEIR
OWN.
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS AND SO
SOMETIMES IT TAKES A SPECIAL
KIND OF KIND OF INTERVENTION --
ONE FINAL IMPORTANT ADVOCACY
CONCERN IS I HEARD DISCUSSION
EARLIER ABOUT THE MATTER
ASSESSMENT WHEN.
LA COUNTY DCFS.
WAS SPEAKING --
WE DON'T GET THE INFORMATION
ABOUT OUR CLIENTS HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AT THE TIME
THAT THE COURT MAKES THE
DISPOSITION PLAN.
SO EVERY CHILD THAT COMES AND
FAMILY THAT COMES THROUGH THE
COURT SYSTEM --
AT DETENTION THE JUDGE ORDERS --
A HUB WHICH IS THE MEDICAL.
EXAM AND A MAP ASSESSMENT.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE'S A
DISPOSITION CASE PLAN THAT'S
MADE FOR THE FAMILY THAT ORDERS
PARENTS INTO CERTAIN --
CLASSES IN PARENTING AS WELL AS
FOR THE CHILD AND WE DON'T HAVE
THE HEALTH.
DEVELOPMENTAL OR MENTAL HEALTH
INFORMATION WE NEED BEFORE MAKE
THAT DISPOSITION CASE PLAN AND
SOMETIMES WE DON'T EVER GET THE
MATTER.
SO THAT MEANS THAT THE THE THE
NEEDS OF THE CHILD OR THE
ADOLESCENT OR THE NON MY DEPEND
ARE COMING UP KIND OF WHEN THEY
COME UP IN THE COURT REPORTS ARE
BECAUSE OF BEHAVIORAL ISSUES AND
NOT.
ON THE FRONT END AND IT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR MANY YEARS AND DON'T SEEM TO
HAVE BE ABLE.
TO MOVE THAT FORWARD IT'S PART
OF THE READ PART OF IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE DELAY --
I MEAN ABOUT ASSESSMENT TIME
FRAME DOESN'T MATCH UP WITH THE
JUDICIAL TIME FRAME AND SO THERE
IS A LACK OF INFORMATION --
SO THESE ARE JUST SOME OF AND I
AM JUST VERY GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE
TO TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH TO
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO HEAR ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES MENTAL HEALTH
IS NOT --
ARE REALLY POPULAR CONVERSATION
SO THIS IS A REAL.
THIS IS GREAT FOR ME OF BEING ON
THE FRONT LINES EVERYDAY WORKING
WITH KIDS AND FAMILIES.
A DAY IN AND DAY OUT IT'S JUST
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO COME IN AND
SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF MY UP
KIND OF MY WISH LIST AND HOPES
FOR THE FUTURE SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
DR RANDALL YEAH --
FIRST I LOVE THE MENTAL HEALTH
AFFECTS US ALL IT REALLY DOES
AND ALL OF US HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF TALKING ABOUT IT
MORE -- I
WANTED TO SPECIFICALLY ASK YOU
ABOUT THE ARE SAYS --
IS THAT GETTING ANY BETTER THEIR
IT'S SLOW AND SO.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE WANT CARE
GIVERS TO BE APPROVED THE
PROBLEM IS AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
ALREADY TODAY IF THERE'S A
THERE'S A IT SEEMS LIKE THE BEST
A RELATIVES AND GRANDPARENTS AND
THE BEST PEOPLE THE MOST
COMMITTED PEOPLE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY TAKE THE
LONGEST TO GET ACTUALLY THE
MONEY THEY NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
THE CHILD.
AND BECAUSE THEY'RE SO GREAT AND
EVERYONE'S SO POSITIVE AND YOU
KNOW ABOUT THEM WE DON'T BUT WE
DON'T SUPPORT THEM THEY STILL
NEED THE FUNDING AND THEY NEED
THE RESOURCES AND SO WE GET HUNG
UP.
THE IT SEEMS LIKE SOMETIMES THE
COUNTY AGENCIES CAN GET HUNG UP
ON DOTTING THE I'S AND CROSSING
THE T.'S SEE IN THE OLD DAYS WE
ONLY NEEDED A A CLEAN KHAKI IN A
CLASS. TO PLACE WITH A RELATIVE
SO WE WENT THROUGH THOSE DAYS
WHERE IT WAS MUCH EASIER FROM
THE FROM DETENTION TO GET A
CHILD WITH FAMILY SO GETTING A
CHILD WITH FAMILY SO NOW WE HAVE
LIKE A HOLDOVER WHERE DO WE PUT
THEM.
BEFORE THEY GO WITH FAMILY AND
THEY WERE SHOULD BE WITH FAMILY
FROM THE BEGINNING I MEAN THE
LESS DISRUPTION.
THE BETTER CELL WILL AND WE'RE
GOING TO FOLLOW UP IF I CAN BUT
IF THERE ARE DELAYS THAT ARE
STILL HAPPENING UP TO SIX MONTHS
WHICH IS WHAT WE HEARD DURING
SOMEONE THIS LAST YEAR WHICH IS
UNACCEPTABLE THE TOPICS FOR
FAMILIES TO BE BEARING THE COST
FOR THAT LONG.
WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT IT AND
HELP OUT AND SO THAT'S WHY I
STARTED BY ASKING THAT QUESTION.
I DID WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
SOMETHING SOMETIMES THERE ARE
GOOD NEWS THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT --
WE INCLUDED FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN HERE TO HELP US
ADDRESS THE NEEDS WITHIN
PSYCHIATRY CHI AND SPECIFICALLY
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT CHILD
PSYCHIATRISTS AT THE UC SYSTEM --
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE THE NEED IS
SO GREAT --
AND THERE IS NEEDS AND I'LL JUST
HIGHLIGHT IT BECAUSE YOU SAID IT
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE SAID
EVERY TIME WE CAN.
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
LANGUAGE APPROPRIATE ARE SO
IMPORTANT FOR COMMUNITIES LIKE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
COMMUNICATING WITH PEOPLE AND
ALLOWING THEM TO HEAR IT AND
PROCESS IT OFTENTIMES HAVE TO
SPEAK.
IN A WAY THAT THE WHOLE
UNDERSTAND YOU.
AND SO --
MAKING SURE THAT OUR PROVIDERS
AND CLINICIANS ARE ABLE TO DO
THAT IS QUITE IMPORTANT SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTING.
ANY THE COMMON TO QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND
BEING PATIENT.
NOT THAT'S OKAY AND NOW I'M
GOING TO STAY AS LONG AS I CAN
OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KATHY SETTLING WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
ON THIS PANEL AND I THINK.
A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT ALL
MENTIONED HAVE YOU'VE HEARD AS
THEMES I THINK TODAY SO IT'S
BEEN HELPFUL TO BE LISTENING TO
THE OTHER --
PARTICIPANTS IN THE OTHER PANELS
AND EVEN MY COLLEAGUE HERE AND
HERE VERY SIMILAR THINGS
HOPEFULLY KIND OF WRAPPING THEM
TOGETHER AND GIVING SOME POTS
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE AND PERHAPS
WHERE WE ARE HEADED OR COULD
HEAD.
WITH THE RIGHT SUPPORT.
I AGREE THERE'S JUST BEEN SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT OF ENSURING THAT OUR
FOSTER YOUTH --
AT BEING BOTH IDENTIFIED AND
SERVED WITH APPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES FROM AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE AND OUR INTERACTION
WITH THEM.
YA I'VE BEEN AT THE SHOP FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS AND I DON'T THINK
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT VERY MUCH
FOR THE FIRST SEVERAL AND NOW
WE'VE BEEN.
I THINK SEEING --
THROUGH KATIE A THROUGH THE
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATIONS ISSUE
THAT NOW WE ARE TRACKING DATA ON
THAT AND HAVE MUCH HEIGHTENED
REQUIREMENTS AS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY.
TO GET THOSE MEDICATIONS
AUTHORIZED MONITORED AND THEN RE
UPPED IF THERE ARE THE YOUTH ARE
ON THEM --
FOR ANY PERIOD OF TIME AND THEN
I THINK NOW MOVING TO SUCH A
DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF TRAUMA
AND ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND HOW THAT AFFECTS
THE YOUTH THAT WE SERVE.
EVEN JUST BEING REMOVED FROM THE
HOME AS A TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE
THAT CAN LEAD TO THE NEED FOR
SOME SERVICES RELATED TO THAT --
SO I COULD HAVE THREE MAIN
POINTS IN THAT HAPPY TO ADDRESS
A COUPLE OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
COME UP THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
OUTSIDE OF THAT --
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE IDENTIFICATION OF
NEEDS FOR THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
WE SERVE.
THE COORDINATION OF SERVICES FOR
THEM AND THEN --
FRANKLY THE NEED FOR MORE
PRACTITIONERS AND PROVIDERS TO
SERVE THEM IN I'M A COUPLE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS IN WAYS --
RELATED TO THE IDENTIFICATION OF
THE IT USED TO BE MORE DELAYED
AND NOW WE'RE TRYING TO DO IT
EARLIER OF THAT'S TO ACROSS THE
SYSTEM CERTAINLY AND ARE.
ON CHILD WELFARE AREA THE
ASSESSMENT STARTED --
HAPPENING MUCH FASTER MUCH UP
FRONT YOU FOR THE EXAMPLES FROM
LOS ANGELES AND SHASTA TODAY.
AND WE ARE NOW MAKING A
TRANSITION TO THIS TOOL THAT YOU
HEARD REFERENCE CALLED CANS --
IT IS A NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT IS
BEING PERFORMED FOR CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND ALSO BEING USED
IN THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM
SO THAT THE TOOL THE TWO TOOLS
THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE USING ARE.
NOT IDENTICAL BUT THEY HAVE A
LOT OF OVERLAP AND SO ON
COUNTIES ON THE CHILD WELFARE
SIDE HAVE BEEN GIVEN SOME
CHOICES ABOUT HOW TO IMPLEMENT
THAT.
SOME COUNTIES ARE DOING IT
INTEGRATED WAY WHERE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLINICIAN
COMPLETES THE WHOLE THING
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN THERE REALLY
TALKING ENGAGING IN SOME
COUNTIES THE SOCIAL WORKER WHO
IS ASSIGNED TO THE CASE IS DOING.
THAT ASSESSMENT ON THE SORT OF
CHILD WELFARE SIDE AND THEN THEY
LATER GET TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT IT WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND IT FEEDS INTO THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAMS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT TODAY SO YOU GET --
THAT SORT OF TRACING THROUGH OF
THOSE ASSESSMENTS AND IT'S NOT
JUST ONE CONVERSATION UP FRONT
WHERE YOU JUST OBSERVE AND YOU
NEVER REALLY HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AGAIN THE INTENT IS
FOR THIS TO BE.
AN ONGOING CONVERSATION WHERE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE ASSESSED
AND TALKED ABOUT ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
I THINK --
WHAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN AND YOU'VE
HEARD REFERENCE A FEW TIMES
TODAY IS WITH THE PASSAGE OF
EIGHTY THREE FORTY BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO?
THAT IS A BILL THAT REQUIRES THE
SCREENING TOOLS THAT BAD THAT
DOCTORS USE THROUGH THE EARLY
AND PERIODIC SCREENING DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS A
REQUIREMENT UNDER MEDICAID AND
ALL OF SIR CARE.
ON IT APPLIES --
TO CHANGING THE SCREENING TOOLS
FOR THE ENTIRE MEDICAID
POPULATION EVERY CHILD THAT WE
SEE IS ENTITLED TO THESE
SERVICES.
ARE ARE FOSTER CHILDREN YOUTH
ARE SUBSET OF THAT AND SO YOU
KNOW WE'VE GONE FARTHER I THINK
WITHOUT LEGISLATION TO INCLUDE
ALL OF THE CHILDREN BUT
CERTAINLY FOR OUR CHILDREN YOUTH
WHERE WE KNOW THAT THAT TRAUMA
HAS BEEN --
LIKELY IN SOME FASHION ON
EXPERIENCE TO A GREATER OR
LESSER DEGREE BUT TO SOME DEGREE
MAKING SURE THAT WERE ASKING THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS AT THE RIGHT
POINTS IN TIME FOR THE CHILDREN
YOU CAN IDENTIFY THINK.
EVEN FASTER AT THE AT THE SORT
OF DOCTOR PRACTITIONER LEVEL
THAT SOMETHING'S GOING ON WITH
THESE CHILDREN --
I THINK ON THE COORDINATION OF
SERVICES I THINK THE EFFORTS ARE
CONTINUING TO IMPROVE THIS WE
ARE HEARING TODAY AND I THINK
YOU SEE DIFFERENT STRUCTURES
ACROSS DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
AND THEY ARE SEEKING THEIR BEST
TO MAKE IT WORK --
I THINK IT'SSTILL NOT FULLY
WHERE WE'D LIKE IT AS FAR AS
MAKING SURE THAT OUR TIME LINES
ARE ON THE SAME I THINK YOU JUST
HEARD.
SOMETIMES WE DON'T GET THOSE
ASSESSMENTS RIGHT AWAY OR OUR
CHILD WELFARE AND THE COURT
PROCESS IS ON PERHAPS A FASTER
TIMELINE THEN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM AB.
AND MENTIONING THAT DIVERT
DEVELOPMENTAL SYSTEM THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM IS EVEN A
LONGER SET OF TIME LINES AND YOU
CAN HAVE CO OCCURRING ISSUES YOU
CAN HAVE A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY OF SOME KIND.
AND BE ELIGIBLE FOR REGIONAL
CENTER SERVICES AND ALSO HAVE A
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE THAT COULD
BE TREATED THROUGH THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM AS WELL
AS ALL OF THOSE THINGS REALLY
NEED TO KIND OF CLICKED TOGETHER.
TO MAKE IT WORK FOR CHILDREN I
DO WANNA GIVE A LITTLE PLUG --
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY WE
WORK TO GET SHARE THIS IS --
AIMED AT THE HIGHEST NEED THE
MOST TRAUMATIZE YOU IT'S NOT THE
MAJORITY OF THE YOUTH THAT WE
SERVE BUT IT'S THOSE THAT ARE
RECEIVING SERVICES ARE NEED TO
BE RECEIVING SERVICES ACROSS
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS.
AND IT HASN'T BEEN WORKING AS
WELL AS IT COULD AND SO THIS
LEGISLATION WHICH WAS SIGNED --
WAS VERY HAPPY ABOUT --
SO WE'RE JUST ON THE FRONT END
OF IT BUT THE IDEA IS TO TRY TO
GET LOCALLY SOME RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT SET OUT FOR WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN ONE OF THOSE HIGHLY
TRAUMATIZE YOUTH.
COURT WE KNOW WE'RE GONNA NEED
SERVICES ACROSS SYSTEMS AND THAT
INCLUDES EDUCATION DD IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM AS WELL
AS UP COUNTY HEALTH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND OUR CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM --
WE WORK TOGETHER ONE OF THE
SILLY BRINGING A NEW SERVICE TO
THE TABLE THAT WE DON'T ALREADY
OFFER BUT WHAT WE HAVE WE NEED
TO TALK TOGETHER ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S BEING
PROVIDED TO THOSE HERE.
THERE'S ALSO A STATE LEVEL
COMPONENT TO THAT AS WELL WHICH
WERE VERY EXCITED ABOUT TO
CONTINUE SOME DISCUSSIONS THAT
STARTED LATE IN THE SESSION AT
THE STATE LEVEL I'M CAN BE IN BY
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WITH ALL OF THOSE.
ELEMENT RIGHT STATE LEVEL
PLAYERS AROUND THE TABLE TO SEE
WHY DON'T OUR TIMELINES MATCH UP
IS THERE A SITUATION WE CAN MAKE
SOME CHANGES TO POLICY TO MAKE
THIS WORK SO.
AT THE BEGINNING OF A JOURNEY ON
THAT AND THINKING ABOUT HOW THAT
CAN ALSO ALTERNATELY TRACE
THROUGH TO THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE TO ALL OF THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN OUR SYSTEM NOT JUST
TO THOSE REALLY HIGH LEVEL.
NEEDS YOUTH I HOPE THAT IT PUTS
STRUCTURES IN PLACE THAT CAN
WORK TO TO EXPAND THOSE
COORDINATED EFFORTS AS WELL --
AND I THINK FINALLY ON TO SORT
OF GETTING INTO THAT --
THIRD PIECE OF TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE IT'S A CURRENT LEVEL
COFFEE FOR CREW BEING --
YOU KNOW EDUCATED DEGREED SOCIAL
WORK PROFESSIONALS TRAINING IS
NEEDED ON GOING WE HAVE A A CORE
PRACTICE MODEL WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY THE CALIFORNIA SOCIAL
WORK EDUCATION CENTER --
BUT THINGS ARE CHANGING ALL THE
TIME AND THE CONTINUAL NEED FOR
TRAINING IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND NOT WELL SUPPORTED NOW I
THINK AT THE STATE LEVEL SO THIS
IS A CONVERSATION TED TO
DEFINITELY KEEP KIND OF TOP OF
MIND FOR BUDGET DISCUSSIONS OF
LEGISLATIVE WILL BUT IT'S NOT
JUST.
A AND IF I MAY OF NOT JUST THE
TRAINING PART BECAUSE I IN MY MY
STEP DAUGHTER GRADUATED FROM A
UNIVERSITY OF THE VERNE.
IN SOCIAL WORK I WENT TO LA
COUNTY DID THE WHOLE TRAINING
PROGRAM.
SPENT THE WEEK AND SAID I CAN'T
DO THAT SINCE IT'S AN EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT JOB YOU'RE SO RIGHT I
ACTUALLY MARRIED TO AN LCSW
RECENTLY LICENSED IN THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS SO YEAH HIM.
AND HE HAS PROVIDED SERVICES
MORE ON THE BEHAVIOR HAVE CITING
THE CLINICIAN AND IT'S BEEN A
IT'S BEEN SO THE POLICE WORK
WITH HOMELESS YOUTH POPULATIONS
HE HIMSELF GETS TRAUMA I YOU
KNOW YOU GO INTO THESE
SITUATIONS.
SO HELPING WITH SELF CARE AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT REALLY IS
THIS JOB AND I KNOW LIKE --
LOS ANGELES HAS A LAB A
SIMULATION LAB WHERE THEY BRING
SOCIAL WORKERS AND WORK WITH
THEM HERE IS WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO ENCOUNTER HERE'SHOW YOU CAN
THINK ABOUT HANDLING THAT --
LET'S SEE HOW WE CAN TAKE THOSE
IS THAT STATE WIDE AND REALLY
ENSURE THAT WORK TRAINING UP A
REALLY EXCELLENT GENERATION AND
THEN HOW DO WE RETAIN THEM AND
MAKING SURE THAT.
PART OF IT I DON'T THINK WAS SO
MUCH THE FACT THAT OF THE WE'RE
COMING I THINK THE WORK SHE WAS
LOOKING FORWARD TO I THINK THE
AMOUNT THE CASE WORK.
AND GOES BACK TO THE AT THE THE
HIDE.
A MAD THE BIG LOADS OF OF THIS
CASE WORK THAT THEY'RE
OVERWHELMED AND YOU KNOW TO THE
POINT OF THAT GOT THAT IN A MADE --
WEEK WE CAN TRAIN THEM BUT IF
THERE'S SO MANY IN THEIR CASE
LOAD HOW DO THEY DECIDE WHO IS
FIRST AND WHO IS SECOND AND WHO
DO THE FOSTER USED.
GO TO A THEY DON'T FEEL
SUPPORTED BECAUSE THERE REALLY
AREN'T I MEAN IF YOU HAVE. FIFTY
TWO ONE I MEAN THAT'S KIND OF
OUT OF HAND WHICH GOES BACK TO
THE I THOUGHT THAT VICIOUS
CIRCLE GOES BACK TO THE FUNDING
IF WE DON'T FIND THEM PROPERTY
THEN THE CASE --
KEEPS GOING UP AND UP AND UP AND
THEN NOT ONLY ARE THE CASE
WORKERS OVERWHELMED BUT THAT THE
KIDS ARE NOT GETTING THE THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
ABSOLUTELY BECAUSE THE SORT OF
BOTTOM LINE AS AM I SERVING ALL
OF THE YOUTH THAT I NEED TO BE
SERVING IN.
A WAY THAT I FEEL GOOD ABOUT AND
IT IN MANY PLACES IT'S JUST NOT
POSSIBLE AND I THINK WE'RE
SEEING FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE POPULATION.
THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT WERE MADE
ABOUT HOW MUCH --
SOCIAL WORK SERVICE WOULD BE
NEEDED BY THESE ADULTS YOU KNOW
I THINK WHEN WE WERE DOING AB
TWELVE TEN YEARS AGO TEN PLUS --
SO HE EIGHT EIGHT YEARS AGO --
WE THOUGHT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
ADULTS ANOTHER HERE'S THE YOU
KNOW KIND OF PERCENTAGES THAT WE
ASSUME BASED ON ILLINOIS AND
WE'VE SEEN OUR PARTICIPATION
RATES WELL PAST THAT WE SORT OF
BLEW THROUGH THOSE ORIGINAL.
ESTIMATES AND I THINK THE
ESTIMATES OF HOW --
READY THOSE YOUTH WOULD BE TO
KIND OF DO IT ON THEIR OWN WITH
JUST A LITTLE HELP FROM US
FINANCIALLY --
WE'VE BEEN TALKING INTERNALLY AS
WELL ABOUT HOW DO WE LOOK AT
THAT AREA OF SOCIAL WORK AND OUR
ASSUMPTIONS ARE AND HOW MANY
CASES THEY WOULD HANDLE UP
VERSES THE REALITY OF THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO REALLY.
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT JUST
DROPPING THIS YOUTH OFTEN OF
ANOTHER A CLIFF WHEN THEY TURN
TWENTY ONE SO IT'S A DEFINITE
ONGOING ISSUE AND I WANT TO SAY
TO WORK THINKING ABOUT AT THE
PRACTITIONER LEVEL --
AND I KNOW IT WAS MENTIONED IN A
COUPLE OF THE PANELS --
INSURING THAT WE HAVE THERAPIST
DOCTORS ABOUT PROGRAMS THAT CAN
SERVE OUR YOUTH AND THERE'S
WAITING LISTS THERE'S A SHORTAGE
OF PROVIDERS IT DEPENDS ON WHERE
YOU LIVE IF YOU CAN GET INTO --
ONE MORE REGULARLY AND SO
THINKING ABOUT WAYS AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE TASKS AND TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE AS FOR THAT STATE
LEVEL GROUP TO SAY.
HOW DO WE GROW HOW DO WE YOU
KNOW CREATE MORE TRAUMA INFORMED
PRACTITIONERS WHO ARE ABLE TO
SERVE OUR YOUTH BECAUSE HAVING --
AN IDENTIFIED NEED IS GREAT BUT
NOT IF YOU CAN'T TREAT IT FOR
MONTHS AND GET SOMEBODY AND ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO RECEIVE THAT
ONGOING SERVICE --
I THINK JUST ONE OTHER THING
THAT I'D LIKE TO MENTION IS --
THE THE SORT OF POLL COUPLE
THINGS ABOUT THE PROMISE OF CCIR
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE FORM ONE
OF THE IMPORTANT PROMISES THAT I
THINK WAS MADE IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT THE STATE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH COUNTY HE IS
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT ALL GOING TO
BE AND THAT SORT OF GROUP CARE
MODEL WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
CONTINUUM AND WE'RE GONNA STEP
YOUTH AND THE FAMILIES ARE GOING
TO KEEP THEM IN FAMILIES?
AND FAMILY TYPES OF PROVIDERS
LIKE A RELATIVE CARE GIVERS ARE
A FAMILY HOME TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE AND WE ARE GOING
TO BRING THOSE SERVICES TO THEM.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THOSE
SERVICES THAT ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE TO FAIL OUT OR HAVE THE
COPS CALLED ON THEM AND HAVE
THEM AND UP IN A CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITY.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE REALLY
SEEKING TO DO WITH --
STUFF LIKE AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM THAT DR ARAMBULA
MENTIONED WHICH UNFORTUNATELY
WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR ON
THE IDEA IS WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HELP PRESERVE PLACEMENTS.
BY PRESERVING THE FAMILIES AND
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE A PLACE
TO CALL IF SOMETHING HAPPENS
SOMETIMES AT THE BRAND NEW
PLACEMENT AND THE FOSTER PARENTS
AND THE YOUTH THEY DON'T KNOW
EACH OTHER.
THERE MAY BE A TRIGGERING EVENT
THAT HAPPENS JUST BY A THAT
THEY'D JUST FROM SOMETHING THAT
THE FOSTER PARENTS SAYS THAT
THAT THAT WAS OF RELATED TO THE
ABUSE AND THESE GUYS ALL IT'S
ANOTHER PLACE IT'S NOT GONNA
WORK FOR ME.
AND THINGS CAN ESCALATE AND GET
OUT OF CONTROL UNFORTUNATELY THE
POLICE CAN GET CALLED AND WE
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU CROSS
OVER TO JUVENILE JUSTICE WE WANT
TO AVOID THAT WHENEVER POSSIBLE
WE WANT TO AVOID HAVING THAT
PLACEMENT IS ROB.
AND HAVING THAT YOU'VE COME BACK
GO TO ANOTHER PLACE AND END UP
WITH THIRTY TWO PLACE THAT NONE
OF THAT IS GOOD WE WANT TO
CHANGE THAT AND SO.
THE IDEA IS --
OUT AT STAFF HOTLINE FRAME WITH
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND OUR FOSTER
YOUTH UNDERSTAND OUR SYSTEM AND
CAN HELP DEFUSE THE SITUATION.
ON AND ROLL OUT A MOBILE
RESPONSE TEAM IN ANY COUNTY.
TWENTY FOUR HOURS IF SOMETHING
IS NEEDED TO GET IN THERE TO
HAVE SOME THERAPY TO HAVE SOME
PROVIDE
NEEDED AND THEN THE FOLLOW UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A PLAN
IN PLACE.
ONGOING YOU KNOW SORT OF ONE THE
CRITICAL THING WE SENIOR STATES
NEW JERSEY SIMILAR STRUCTURE
THEY ACTUALLY OFFER TO EVERY
CHILD THE COURSE TO JERSEY IS
MUCH SMALLER THAN CALIFORNIA SO.
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO THAT --
AND THE CITY OF MILWAUKEE HAS A
SIMILAR KIND OF EFFORT AS WELL
SO WE THINK THAT IT'S VERY
PROMISING IN THE MEANTIME --
A LOT OF COUNTIES ARE USING
THEIR FOSTER PARENT RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION MONEY WE CAUGHT
DIPPERS SIZED SORRY FOR THE
ACRONYM.
ON THINGS LIKE THE VENTURA UP
HERE PARTNERS --
IS FOR IS FUNDED RIGHT NOW
THROUGH THAT FUNDING WHICH IS
GOING TO BE ENDING AT THE END OF
THIS CURRENT FISCAL YEAR SO YOU
CAN BUT WILL HAVE A CONVERSATION
I THINK AROUND THAT BOTH IN THE
POLICY IN FISCAL COMMITTEES. TO
SAY ARE WE THERE YET IT TAKES A
LOT TO BUILD A SYSTEM THAT CAN
SUPPORT THE FAMILIES AND THE
YOUTH IN A FAMILY SETTING AND
ENABLE THEM TO STEPOUT OF THE
S. T. R. T. P. TYPE OF FACILITY
OR AVOID IT IF.
AT ALL TOGETHER WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE SERVICES IN PLACE THEY HAVE
TO BE IN A WELL INFORMED BY THE
NEEDS OF OUR YOUTH AND WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THEM ON TIME
AND WITHOUT THAT ON THIS WHOLE
THING IT JUST ISN'T GOING TO
WORK LIKE IT.
SHOULD.
STOP THEIR THANKS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE WILL CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS I'M SURE YES
ORDERS A SAY SHE PLAYED A KEY
ROLE IN TWENTY EIGHTY THREE AND
MAKING THE CASE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AND I I DID NOTE THAT IT WAS IN
THE BACKGROUND PAPER.
BUT I ALSO THOUGHT YOU KNOW JUST
KEEP THE FOCUS ON THE WHOLE
SYSTEM IN OUR WORK CELLS.
THANK YOU FOR THE SHOUT OUT ON
YOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
WE HAVE OUR ME GET MY LIST HERE
CAN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
I LOVE GOING LAST BECAUSE OF
WHAT THEY SAID.
ME.
TO MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT EASIER --
AND BY THE WAY OF I'M FAMILY THE
AGENCIES AND WE'RE MULTI SERVICE
AGENCY THAT CROSSES EDUCATION
CHILD WELFARE MENTAL HEALTH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN A CONTINUE.
CONTINUE OF CARE AGENCY SINCE
OUR BEGINNING SO THANK YOU.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTY THREE BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE MY LIFE
EASIER.
AND I JUST I CAN'T I WOULD BE
REMISS I'M SO SORRY TO BREAK AND
IF I DID ALSO THINK DIANA BORDER
WHO IS OUR SEE AMAZING CWD A
STAFF IS ARE WE DON'T TELL
WELFARE ISSUES.
SHE'S HERE IN THE AUDIENCE TODAY
AND I JUST WANNA SAY SHE DID SO
MUCH LIKE WORK AND SO MUCH
BACKGROUND ON THAT SO SORRY I
DON'T USUALLY GET TO DO THAT AS
THE PERSON WHO SITS AT THE TABLE
SO.
THANK GOD SORRY BACK --
TO I WANTED STEP BACK FOR JUST A
MINUTE AND TELL YOU THAT ABOUT
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO MY WIFE AND I
WERE DOING A PRESENTATION IN
SPAIN OF ALL PLACES.
ABOUT INNOVATION AND CHILD
WELFARE AND CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THAT TALK OF IT PERSONAL
I WAS PRESENTING WITH MY WIFE
WHICH IS SORT OF LIKE BEING
STEDMAN EVERYBODY'S WAITING --
FOR BRED A COME ON IT I GOT IT
BY THE LONG BECAUSE THEY WANTED
HER AND THEY THOUGHT SHE WOULD
COME IF I CAME BUT ANYWAY.
SO WE'RE PRESENTING AND I WENT
PERSON I'M PRESENTING TO THIS
AUDIENCE SO MY SPANISH IS AWFUL
SO I'M PRESENTING AN ENGLISH
THROUGH A TRANSLATOR.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HEAR IN A
ROOM AND YOU'RE NOT CONNECTING
WITH AN AUDIENCE AND YOU CAN SEE
IT AND AT SOME POINT.
WE LOOKED AT EACH OTHER AND WE
STOPPED AND WE SAID.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU MIGHT NOT BE
UNDERSTANDING OR YOU MIGHT NOT
BE --
KNOWING WHAT QUITE WHAT WE ME
INTO THE TRANSLATIONS NOT
WORKING AT AS WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS NEW PHENOMENON OF
WRAPAROUND IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS VERY NEW SERVICE.
ANNA A VERY POLITE WOMAN IN THE
BACK OF THE AUDIENCE RAISED HER
HAND.
AND SIX INCH INTO TRYING TO BE
SO KIND SHE SAID WHAT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HERE.
YOU MEAN BEFORE YOU HAD THIS
WRAPAROUND SERVICE YOU USED TO
TAKE CHILDREN AWAY FROM THEIR
PARENTS BEFORE YOU HELP THEM.
WE WERE IN ONE OF THE MOST
FAMILY CENTRIC COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD.
TELLING THEM THAT WE USED TO
TAKE KIDS AWAY BEFORE WE HELP
THEIR FAMILIES.
NEEDLESS TO SAY THE TALK DID NOT
GO WELL.
BUT SOME THINGS HAVE GONE REALLY
WELL SINCE THEN.
SOME THINGS HAVE GONE REALLY
WELL WE HAD VIRTUALLY ZERO SLOTS
WE AT SOME EXPERIMENTATION
AROUND THE STATE.
AND NOW BY BEST ESTIMATES THERE
ARE AT LEAST EIGHT THOUSAND
FLIGHTS A PROPER AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE ABLE TO HELP KIDS IN
WAYS THAT WE'VE NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO HELP THEM BEFORE WE'RE ABLE
TO HELP THEM ACROSS SYSTEMS
SOMETIMES IN WAYS THAT WE'VE
NEVER BEEN ABLE TO HELP THE
BEFORE.
THAT'S THE GOODNESS AND YOU'RE
GONNA GET GOOD NEWS BAD NEWS AND
GOODNESS.
SO LET'S SAY WE HAVE TEN
THOUSAND VOTES BECAUSE NOBODY
QUITE KNOWS HOW MANY SLOTS
WRAPAROUND WE HAVE.
WE STILL HAVE SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
KIDS IN OUT OF HOME CARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH EASIER TO GET REMOVED
FROM YOUR HOME IN THE STATE.
THAT IS TO GET INTENSIVE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT PICTURE
FOLKS.
THERE'S STILL SOMETHING WRONG
WE'RE DOING A LOT BETTER.
MOST OF THOSE SLOTS ARE USED
EITHER FOR STEP DOWN --
AT FROM OUT OF HOME CARE.
OR AS A AS A PREVENTION
INTERVENTION AFTER REPORT IS
MADE THE CPS.
BUT I HAVE ON THIS PANEL KIND OF
ALL THE PEOPLE I NEED BECAUSE OF
TEACHER.
EMERGENCY ROOM DOC AND A PERSON
WHO HAD SOMEONE IN THEIR HOME
THAT DIDN'T GET TO THE SUPPORT
THEY NEEDED TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SO IF YOU'RE A TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU NEED
INTENSIVE IN HOME SERVICES FOR
YOUR CHILD.
WHAT DO YOU NOTED DO?
I GUARANTEE YOU EVERY TEACHER IN
THE STATE THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
AS AMENDED REPORTER EVERYONE OF
THEM DO.
AND THEY KNOW HOW TO MAKE A
REPORT TYPICALLY THEY'LL GO TO
THEIR PRINCIPLE THEY KNOW HOW TO
MAKE A REPORT.
GO BACK TO DISTRICTS AND ASK THE
TEACHER AT RANDOM IF YOU HAVE A
FAMILY THAT'S IN TROUBLE.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO TO GET THAT
FAMILY HELP?
AND MOST OF THEM WON'T BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION IN A
CLEAR DEFINITIVE SMOOTH WAY.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT PICTURE.
SENATE HASHAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
DOING A SERIES OF PILOT'S FUNDED
BY THE TEACHER A LONG FOUNDATION --
AND AND PUT BY THE GATES
FOUNDATION BUT THE THE
PARTICULAR ONE I WANT TO TALK TO
ABOUT IS IN WEST CONTRA COSTA
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA.
AND IN THOSE PILOTS WERE ABLE TO
TAKE OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH CHILD
WELFARE WE HAD WITH THE
WRAPAROUND PROVIDER FOR CONTRA
COSTA.
WITH THE MOBILE RESPONSE
PROVIDER FOR CONTRA COSTA.
AND WE'RE MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER
FOR CONTRA COSTA.
AND PARTNER WITH SCHOOLS THAT
ARE AT 809096% FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH.
IN NEIGHBORHOODS THAT HAD SOME
OF THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGES OF
CPS REPORTS.
IN THE IN THE STATE I'M AND
CERTAINLY INCOME CONTRA COSTA.
IN IN THOSE SCHOOLS THERE'S
SOMEONE CALLED IN AND
CONDITIONAL EDUCATION COACH.
AND THE COACH IS THE PERSON
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HANG OUT WITH
BECAUSE THERE THE PERSON HAS
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES THAT
COACH IS AVAILABLE FOR OFFICE
HOURS.
AT LEAST THREE DAYS A WEEK AND A
DEVIL ONE DAY A WEEK WHEN ANY
TEACHER ANY PARENT AND THE
STUDENT CAN COME TO THEM WITH
THE PROBLEM.
AND IT'S THAT COACHES
RESPONSIBILITY TO BRING SERVICES
TO THAT CHILD AND FAMILY.
WHAT WOULD WE WILL BE LIKE
SYSTEMICALLY?
IF EVERY TEACHER HAD ACCESS TO
SOMEONE.
WHO COULD GET VERY SMOOTH ACCESS
TO SERVICES AND FAMILY A RICH?
I CAN TELL YOU ONE OF THE
RESULTS.
WE HAVE FEWER REPORTS TO CVS.
BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT NECESSARY
WHEN YOU CAN HELP A FAMILY
RATHER THAN MAKE A CPS REPORT
AND YOU CAN DO IT SEAMLESSLY AND
I REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE YOU
CAN DO IT SEAMLESSLY.
BECAUSE IF THERE'S A DELAY YOU
HAVE TO MAKE THE CBS REPORT
RIGHT IF YOU CAN'T GET SOMEBODY
OUT THERE RIGHT AWAY IF YOU
CAN'T CALL MOBILE RESPONSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I HOPE YOU'RE GONNA TRY AGAIN
BECAUSE THAT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
IF YOU CAN'T CALM OF A RESPONSE
THEN YOU'RE FORCED TO CALL CPS
FOR ENERGY --
THERE ARE NO BAD PEOPLE OUT
THERE WANTING TO DO BAD THINGS.
THERE'S NO BAD MENTAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ARE SAYING I DON'T
WANT TO SAVE KIDS.
BUT THERE'S A HUGE FEAR OF RISK
IN OUR SYSTEMS.
AND THAT'S WHERE YOU GUYS CAN
COME IN.
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE WHERE I
THINK WE CAN BE HELPFUL IN A
DIFFERENT WAY --
BECAUSE WE CAN CREATE A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM THAT CAN
RESPOND IN MORE PROACTIVE WAY.
AND WE CAN'T DO THAT WITH THE
SINGLE SYSTEM RESPONSE IT CAN'T
BE CHILD WELFARE IS
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT CAN'T BE EDUCATIONS
RESPONSIBILITY AND IT CAN BE
MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSIBILITY.
WE GIVE YOU ONE MORE PIECE OF
GOOD NEWS WE WORK BUT WE DO A
LOT OF WORK IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
ALAMEDA COUNTIES.
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MANY KIDS
ARE IN THE JUVENILE HALL IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW IT'S FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT WE BUILT A BIG HALL.
AND IT'S MOSTLY EMPTY I WANNA
DANCE THROUGH THOSE EMPTY.
BROOMS AND THAT HALL SOMETIMES
BECAUSE I'M IT'S SUCH A HUGE
DIFFERENCE FROM WHERE IT WAS
WHEN I STARTED WHEN WE USED TO
HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY KIDS.
IN THE JUVENILE HALL AND THEY
WOULD STAY THERE FOR VERY LONG
PERIODS OF TIME WE'VE DONE THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE M. S. T. WE HAVE
A MENTAL HEALTH COURT ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE HAVE A WHOLE SERIES OF
INTERVENTIONS THAT CAN OCCUR.
NOW WE PROBABLY WILL HAVE
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN.
AROUND TWELVE HUNDRED KIDS THAT
WILL COME THROUGH THAT ALL.
WE DON'T HAVE AN OF SERVICE FOR
ALL OF THOSE KIDS TO RECEIVE
ACCESS IN THAT SMOOTH SEAMLESS
WAY THAT I'M DESCRIBING
[inaudible]
CáC.
SO IF WE COULD WE ENVISION.
A SYSTEM THAT SAYS WE CAN
INTEGRATE THESE SERVICES.
IN A WAY THAT USES THE
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING AND
AT AND AND FUNDS --
AND TAKES AWAY RISK OR FUNDS
INSTEAD INCENTIVIZE IS RISK FOR
COUNTIES TO DO THINGS.
THAT ARE NEW --
A WHO'S TALKED ABOUT HOW
WONDERFUL THEIR CHAU WAS --
AND THERE'S A LOT OF WONDERFUL
CA AS OUT THERE.
BUT THIS CHAU HOLD THE MENTAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR FISCALLY
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND THE CHILD WELFARE DIRECTOR
AND AT THAT'S THEIR JOB THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
AND WHAT WE CAN DO WHAT YOU CAN
DO IS PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO TAKE
AWAY THE RISK WHERE IF YOU TRY
TO DO SOMETHING NEW AND YOU
DON'T GET THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IMMEDIATELY.
AND YOU WON'T.
WE KNOW THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT
IS THAT IMMEDIATE.
YOU CAN HANG IN THERE AND YOU
CAN INCENTIVIZE NEW PRACTICES
LIKE IN CONDITIONAL EDUCATION
LIKE INTEGRATED SERVICE RESPONSE
LIKE MOBILE RESPOND --
JUST JUST FINALLY THE THE WISDOM
IT'S ALWAYS FUN TO HAVE AN
EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTOR ONE OF THE
PROGRAMS WE RUN.
IS A PROGRAM THAT TAKES KIDS OUT
OF THE EMERGENCY ROOM WE DO THIS
FOR VENTURE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
AND AND BRINGS THEM IMMEDIATELY
INTO A SYSTEM THAT HAS A TWENTY
THREE OUR ASSESSMENT.
THEY CAN INTERVENE AND THEN NEXT
DOOR IN BOTH SITUATIONS IS IN
ONE CASE A PUFF INTO THE CASE
THAT STR TP.
WHERE IF KIDS NEED LONGER TERM
UP SUPPORT THEY CAN BE HELPED?
WE HAVE A BETTER THAN 50% OF
DIVERSION RATE FROM
HOSPITALIZATION.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS OUR AMBULANCE
WAIT TIME IS AROUND FOUR MINUTES.
FOR THAT MEANS ARE AMBULANCES
GET BACK ON THE STREET THAT
MEANS THE KIDS ARE IN RESRAINTS
GET PULLED OUT OF RESTRAINTS
VERY QUICKLY.
AND SAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PAIN IT ALSO MEANS THAT KIDS
DON'T SIT IN A WAITING ROOM.
ABOUT 45% OF THE KIDS THAT COME
TO US COME TO CHILD WELFARE.
THE KIDS ARE IN CHILD WELFARE
THE REALLY CUTE CRISIS.
THAT KIND OF PRACTICE SHOULD
SHOULD BE STATEWIDE AND IT AND
AND THAT KIND OF PRACTICE WHEN
YOU PAIR IT WITH MOBILE RESPONSE.
WHERE MOST OF THE KIDS DON'T
NEED TO EVEN COME TO THE TWENTY
THREE HOURS CENTER CAN BE VERY
POWERFUL AND REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF KIDS THAT COME IN THE CHILD
WELFARE?
SO WE HAVE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
THANK YOU ANY.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS DR ARAMBULA
NO I SOMETIMES IT SEEMS THAT
WERE OF A PENNY WISE BUT POUND
FOOLISH.
RIGHT AND WE ALL KNOW THAT AN
OUNCE OF PREVENTION CAN REALLY.
IS WORTH A POUND OF CURE WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY AS A STATE AND
FRANKLY RESPONSIBILITY TO TALK
ABOUT THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU ARE.
ELICITING HERE BUT WILL
SOMETIMES IT IS FRUSTRATING TO
LOOK AT WHAT WASN'T ACCOMPLISH
THIS YEAR I DO WANT TO AGREE
WITH YOU THERE IS SOME LIGHT OUT
THERE AS WELL --
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO FOCUS A
LITTLE BIT ON FEB FIRST BECAUSE
OF WHAT YOU HAD SAID KATHY AND
JUST WANTED --
TO WAY IN A LITTLE BIT FOR THE
REST OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE IS
THAT WILL HALF WHAT'S THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
REMOVING OF THAT AND WHAT SHOULD
WE EXPECT.
OVER THE NEXT YEAR TO TO WITH
THE REMOVAL OF THOSE PAPERS
FUNDS.
SURE I'M HAPPY THAT TO START
TACKLING THAT THE SO SO FIRST I
WANT TO JUST SAY AS THAT SORT OF
POINT OF COMPARISON.
THERE WAS A RECENT FEDERAL LAW
I'M AN ACTOR CALL THE FAMILY
FIRST ACT AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE FAMILY FIRST ACT DOES
IS MAKE A LOT OF CHANGES.
TO HOW STATES ARE ALLOWED TO
DRAW DOWN FEDERAL TITLE FOR EACH
FUNDING FOR GROUP CARE
PLACEMENTS AND IT CREATES A
SYSTEM THAT'S GONNA SOUND VERY
SIMILAR WHEN YOU START HEARING
MORE ABOUT IT NOT THE POINT OF
THIS HEARING.
ON TO WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN
CCR BUT THERE'S SOME --
CAM DEVIATIONS FROM THOSE --
FROM WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT WE THINK CAN I GET IN OUR
WAY AND SO IT'S FRUSTRATING AND
WE WERE NOT HAPPY WITH THAT. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THE FEDERAL
BILL WANTS TO DO IS TO REDUCE
PLACEMENT AND CONGREGATE CARE
JUST LIKE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THE C. R..
WE WHAT THE BILL CONTAINS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AS NINE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STATES TO RECRUIT
FOSTER PARENTS.
AND AND RELATIVES AND WE'VE
SPENT I MEAN AT THE TIME THE
BILL WAS INITIALLY PUTTING
THROUGH WE'D SPENT ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON THAT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
AND NOW IT'S WILL ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH IT BECAUSE
NUMBER ONE WE HAVE MORE NUMBERS
OBVIOUSLY --
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A TO GO
AND I THINK BOTH ON THE LICENSED
FOSTER PARENTS SIDE AND ON THE
RELATIVE SIDE.
YOU HAVE NEEDS OF THOSE CARE
GIVERS TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEM AND A GOOD EXAMPLE I
NOTICED THAT SORT OF HARKEN BACK
TO THE INITIAL SPEAKER ON THE
PANEL -- ONE
OF THE IMPORTANT CHANGES THAT WE
MADE THIS YEAR WAS --
AS PART OF THE BUDGET TO APPROVE
AND YOU HAD A BILL --
WAS TO ALLOW PAYMENTS AT THE
TIME OF PLACEMENT TORE RELATIVE
CARE GIVERS SO THE HUGE CHANGE
WE KNOW THAT THE RFA PROCESS IS
SIGNIFICANT.
AND OUR RELATIVES ARE BEING
ASKED TO GO THROUGH A LOT OF
TRAINING THAT THEY NEVER HAD TO
GO THROUGH WE'RE GETTING GREAT
COMMENTS BACK THAT THE TRAINING
IS SO HELPFUL WHY DIDN'T I GET
THIS BEFORE KIND OF THINGS.
SO WE THINK THAT IT IS THE RIGHT
THING BUT IT IS TAKING LONGER
THAN WEWANTED --
TO WE KNOW THE NUMBERS ARE GOING
DOWN I DON'T HAVE THEM NOW I
DIDN'T GET THAT BEFORE THE
HEARING BUT WE'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT BUT WE ARE DOING
FASTERNOW THAT WE'VE MADE SOME
STREAMLINING CHANGES TO THE
PROCESS.
BUT IT'S STILL TAKING LONGER
THAN WE WANT AT ANY DAY ANY TIME
MORE THAN LIKE A DAY WAS NOT.
READY FOR THE RELATIVE CARE
GIVERS FROM WHAT WE GET FROM A
LICENSE PLATE PARENT THOSE FOLKS
THEY THOUGHT ABOUT IT TAPES ON
ADD MAYBE ONE OTHER FRIEND SAID
ADOPTED OR HAD BEEN A FOSTER
PARENT I CAN DO THAT.
TOO AND SO THEY CAME IN AND IN
ADVANCE THEY WENT THROUGH ALL OF
THAT PROCESS SO THEY'RE READY TO
GO AND SO HAVING --
A GREATER UNDERSTANDING LIKE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT FAMILIES AND
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
YOU CAN DO WITH THE FUNDS FOR
THOSE PARENTS. TO SUPPORT THOSE
PARENTS WITH TAKING ADDITIONAL
CLASSES SAY --
SAY THAT THEY HAVE --
NOT REALLY HAD EXPERIENCE WITH
THE YOUTH WHO IDENTIFIES AS
TRANSGENDER AND NOW THE BLIGHTED
TO TACKLE THAT YOU KNOW WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THERE WERE
SOME ABUSE RELATED TO THAT.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW TO BE
THOUGHTFUL AND BE CARING CAN YOU
HELP ME.
GET SOME MORE TRAINING AND THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
DO WITH THOSE FUNDS ON BOTH
RELATIVES A NON RELATIVE CARE
GIVERS WE COULD PROVIDE RESPITE --
ESSENTIALLY ENABLE THEM TO HIRE
A BABYSITTER MAYBE TAKE A
VACATION HAVE SOMEONE THAT WE
ALL FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
CHILD STAYING WITH FOR THAT TIME.
ON TO GIVE THEM A BREAK
BASICALLY ON A LOT OF TIMES --
WE CAN ALSO PAY FOR THE KID ON
VACATION WITH THEM THEIR FAMILY
AND SO IF MAYBE IT WOULD BE COST
PROHIBITIVE FOR THEM WE CAN STEP
IN AND WE CAN PAY FOR OTHER SORT
OF ACTIVITIES FOR THE YOUTH WITH
US FUNDS --
ON THE RELATIVE SIDE IN ADDITION
TO SUPPORTING THOSE RELATIVES
NOW FROM DAY ONE A WHICH IS KIND
OF OUTSIDE OF FLIPPERS --
WE ALSO CAN SUPPORT THE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE THAT MAY NOT BE
THE SAME AS A FOSTER PARENT
WHO'S BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS --
IT COULD BE --
YOU KNOW WHAT I DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE A BEDROOM SET UP FOR THAT
KID I'D CONVERTED THAT INTO AN
OFFICE I DIDN'T KNOW I WAS GOING
TO BE TAKING AND MY NIECE OR
NEPHEW.
AND SO THERE CAN BE JUST SORT OF
TANGIBLE SUPPORT SITE SO YOU
ONLY FINDING ACTIVITIES WE WANT
TO DO THE BEST JOB WE CAN'T
IDENTIFY AS MANY RELATIVES FOR
THESE CHILDREN WHEN THEY FIRST
COME INTO CARE.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT COUNTIES
HAVE USE THOSE FUNDS FOR AND
THEN GENERALLY RECRUITMENT
TRYING TO GET MORE FOSTER
PARENTS TO STEP UP AND COME IN
AND BECOME PARENTS BECAUSE WE WE
DO HAVE A SHORTAGE I THINK.
SOME OF IT IS VERY SPECIFIC LIKE
WE SAW IN I THINK LOS ANGELES
WHEN WE HAD SUCH A HIGHER TAKE
OPERATE ON ON THE A. B. TWELVE
THE EXTENDED FOSTER CARE.
ON THOSE YOU STAYED IN THEIR
FOSTER PLACEMENT AND THAT WAS
AMAZING I MEAN THAT WAS GREAT
THEY HAD THIS LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP WITH THOSE PARENTS
THEY WANTED TO STAY THERE.
AND SO THAT WAS EXCELLENT BUT
WHAT THAT MEANT WAS WHEREAS
BEFORE AB TWELVE AT EIGHTEEN
THAT YOUTH WOULD HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT AND WE WOULD HAVE HAD
THAT HOME TO PLACE WITH WE DON'T
HAVE THEM ANYMORE SO NOW WE NEED
TO REPLACE THEM.
SO WE'RE SORT OF WORKING THROUGH
A LOT OF THOSE TYPES OF ISSUES
SO THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT WE
CAN USE THOSE FUNDS.
FOR THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO SHIFT
FUNDS OR SHIP SERVICES FROM
OTHER AREAS TO BUILD TO MAKE UP
FOR BECAUSE THE WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO IN HIS AREA IS NOT
YET COMPLETE WE DON'T HAVE A
PLACE THAT'S WELL SUPPORTED.
THAT WE CAN COUNT ON TO RETAIN
AND TO BE THERE FOR ALL OF OUR
YOUTH AS WE MOVE THEM OUT OF
THESE HOMES THAT ARE GOING AWAY
OR AS THEY REMAIN IN THE HOMES
PASS EIGHTEEN TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT WE NEED TO REPLACE THOSE
SO THOSE ARE SOME.
EXAMPLES THAT I HOPE FOR HELPFUL
ONE LAST THING I JUST WANTED TO
SAY IS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN
OUR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
TRANSITION OUT OF CONGREGATE
CARE INTO A HOME SETTING WE ALSO
SEE.
A RETURN TO OLD BEHAVIORS AND SO
THE WHOLE IDEA OF TRANSITION
PLANNING WELL ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S WORKED INCREDIBLY WELL IN
LA COUNTY THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
CHILD PROTECTION.
IS KIND OF MORE FRONT END
THROUGH THE XCELERATED PLACEMENT
TEAM AT DCFS A LOT OF FUN AND
WORK WITH THE FOSTER PARENTS
LIKE HAVING A SIT DOWN WITH ALL
THE PROVIDERS BEFORE --
THE CHILD OR YOUTH EVEN GOES
INTO THE HOME AND THEN
CONTINUING THE MOBILE RESPONSE
THROUGHOUT THAT BUT TO TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE A WITH THE FOSTER
[inaudible]
AND SO SPRINT'S KNOWS WE'RE NOT
GOING AWAY DAY IN HERE KNOWING
THAT IT'S GOING TO GET TOUGH
WITH ALL OF THE ATTACHMENT
ISSUES AN INSTITUTIONALIZATION
THAT HAPPENS --
AND SO IT'S GREAT TO HEAR THE
THINGS YOU'RE SAYING BUT THE
BIGGEST SUCCESS I'VE HAD WITH A
REALLY HARD TO PLACE YOUTH
INCLUDING TRANS YOUTH.
WHO --
THERE'S A HUGE REJECT REJECTION
PIECE THERE AND NOT FEELING
COMFORTABLE AND IT TAKES HOME
AFTER HOME AFTER HOME AFTER HOME
TO FIND A PLACEMENT WHERE A LOT
OF THESE --
YOU FEEL SAFE AND SO --
I JUST THINK MORE WORK ON THE
FRONT END HAS REALLY MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE TO MAINTAIN STABILITY.
IF IF I MAY THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT FURS AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT DAY.
SOMETIMES WHICH WE WOULD HAVE
HAD MORE OF THAT BEFORE.
THE VETO BUT THAT'S FOR ANOTHER
YEAR -- YOU
KNOW IN THE E. R. I WAS HAD TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN FOR WHEN
THERE WAS A CRISIS.
HOW DO WE NOT EXPECT THERE TO BE
CRISES?
WITHIN OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND WHAT'S OUR RESPONSES A STATE.
DOES IT MEET THE NEED OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND YOU KNOW DO WE
HAVE THE RIGHT SOLUTION IS A
STATE I THOUGHT FIRST WAS ONE OF
THOSE THAT REALLY ALLOW US.
TO LISTEN TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
RESPOND IN MOMENTS WHEN WE
NEEDED HELP THE MOST --
IF I MAY.
CREATING SOME FLEXIBILITY WITH
IN THE SYSTEMS --
IT ONE OF THE THE BEST WAYS TO
GET BETTER ACCESS TO WRAP AROUND.
UP BELIEVE IT OR NOT IS TO SAY
THAT.
THESE CAN COME BACK AND A
WRAPAROUND FOSTER FAMILIES CAN
COME BACK INTO WRAPAROUND ON
DEMAND.
AND AND IT IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY
GET BETTER THAT MUCH FASTER.
NOBODY'S AFRAID THAT IF THEY
CLOSE THE CASE THAT THEY'LL HAVE
TO GO TO A VERY LONG.
TO WIND UP TO COME BACK IN.
SO WE EIGHT THIS SORT OF THE
SYSTEMIC RESPONSE THAT SAYS
WE'VE GOT YOUR BACK.
AND WILL COME IN AND PROVIDE
WHATEVER SUPPORTS NECESSARY --
IT ACTUALLY CREATES MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE SYSTEM SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN COME IN AND OUT
RATHER THAN HAVING LONGER LENGTH
OF STAY.
THANK YOU K. ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY WELL AT THIS POINT --
WE ARE GOING TO OPEN FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT --
JUST TO BE SENSITIVE OF THE TIME --
WE ARE SCHEDULED TO AND AT FOUR
THIRTY BUT WE'RE PAST THAT BUT
KNOW THAT WE ARE AVAILABLE --
AT ALL TIMES THE COMMITTEE IS --
AVAILABLE TO KIND OF DRAFTING
HEALTHCARE AVAILABLE IT AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO REQUEST IF
YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS BECAUSE THIS
IS A LOT.
AND I KNOW --
DAPHNE TOOK NOTES BUT IF YOU
HAVE SPECIFIC IDEAS OF WHAT WE
CAN DO IN.
THE NEXT YEAR PLEASE SEND THEM
TO US SO THAT AND I WILL SHARE
WITH THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE
EVEN THOSE THAT ARE NOT HERE SO
THAT WE CAN START THINKING ABOUT
WHAT --
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGES WE MIGHT
TOGETHER NEXT YEAR OF I'D LOVE
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT EXPERTS AND IDEAS AND
YOU KNOW WE HAD OUR OWN --
BUT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE YOU KNOW WE
ARE HERE --
TO LISTEN TO WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY AND HOPEFULLY TAKE THAT ON
TO THE NEXT LEVEL AND SO WITH
THAT WE ARE OPEN FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AND CO CHAIRS I'M
FARMING DATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IT'LL BE VERY BRIEF I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING.
HOW CAN BE EATING THESE EXPERT
PANELS YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THE ISSUES AND YOU KNOW COUNTIES
ARE THE GROUND ZERO WE HAVE OUR
TROUBLE FOR SERVICES ARE WORKING
REALLY HARD WE EVER BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES WHO ARE WORKING
REALLY HARD WE HAVE OUR PROVIDER
COMMUNITY WORKING REALLY HARD?
AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO THAT
HELPS WITH SHARING OF
INFORMATION --
COLLABORATION AND COHESION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SO WE STAND
READY TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
COMING YEAR.
ON BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES
BROADLY BUT FOR CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN
AND MR COACH I JUST WANTED TO
ALSO REITERATE THE SAME THING
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS --
THIS IS DEFINITELY A PRIORITY
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION IS
SIGNIFICANT.
AND WE GREATLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK YOU'VE DONE --
WITH LEGISLATION IN THE BUDGET
TO PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT THAT WE GREATLY NEEDED --
AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH COUNTY WHAT FOR
DIRECTORS AND SEE SACK AND
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES --
DEFINITELY WANT TO PARTNER WITH
YOU AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU REACHED
NEED TO BE --
AT THE TABLE AND AND PRESENT IN
OUR OF WHAT WE'RE DOING LOS
ANGELES CAN YOU MENTAL HEALTH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
WELL THIS WITH THAT AGAIN PLEASE
I REALLY DO --
DO YOU TO SEND US THE
INFORMATION OR ANY IDEAS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE OF FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATION --
AND WITH THAT OUT WILL GO HEAD
IN A TURN AT FOR FOR THIRTY FIVE
AND I'M SORRY IT'S DOCTOR
ARAMBULA HAVE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS.
MISTER KING --
COOLEY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN THIS
IS YOU KNOW I HOPE THAT YOU GOT
AS MUCH OUT OF IT AS WE DID
BECAUSE I I PRO AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED.
THIS IS EXCELLENT --
NOT RUSHING AROUND --
WE REALLY I THINK ALL OF US GO
BACK TO OUR OUR OFFICES AND AND
START THINKING ABOUT NEXT YEAR
AND WHAT HOW WE CAN SUPPORT THE
FOSTER YOUTH --
IN A MORE.
MORE --
SERVICES AND NOT JUST MORE MONEY
I THINK THE SERVICES ARE
CRITICAL THE MONEY IS GREAT BUT
IF WE DOESN'T CHANCE IF WE CAN'T
TRANSLATED INTO SERVICES THAN
THE MONEY AS USELESS SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
DURING THANK YOU